GOOD MORNING I'D LIKE TO CALL --
THE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO ON RESOURCES
ENVIRONMENT PROTECTION ENERGY
AND TRANSPORTATION TO ORDER.
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible] ONE REQUIRE.
ALL RIGHT A QUORUM IS A STAB
WISH THIS IS A REMINDER -- ON
ISSUES THAT ARE BEING HELD OPEN --
WILL HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
HEARD AT THE END OF EACH
DEPARTMENTS -- TEMPTATION AND
ISSUES WERE GONNA HAVE A VOTE ON
IT THEN WE WILL HAVE A OBVIOUSLY
HAVE THE PUBLIC HEARING BEFORE
THE VOTE ALL RIGHT -- BUT WITH
THAT SAID LET'S MOVE FOR VOTE ON
THE ONLY CALENDAR THE CHAIR WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR ITEMS ONE
THROUGH. SIX EIGHT TO SIXTEEN IS
THERE A MOTION SENATOR JONES.
THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER JONES
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HOW SCHEME HI [inaudible]
WIRE [inaudible]
MONEY.
I WILL KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THERE IS
A NOW A MOTION ON ITEM SEVEN AND
SEVENTEEN ON THE CONSENT ORDER.
BUT ONLY PLEASE IS THERE A
MOTION.
SOME OF HIS MOST BY CENTER
MINING PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CASKEY HI [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONEY.
I THAT MATTERS APPROVED.
FOUR ZERO WE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE FIRST
MOTION [inaudible]
HI.
THAT CLOSE THE ROLE THAT THOSE
MATTERS ARE APPROVED. FIVE ZERO
FOUR ONE FOUR ONE ON THE SECOND
MOTION.
THAT WAS SAID ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN ON THE DISCUSSIONS.
RESOURCES.
THIS IS VERY SUGGESTIONS
AMENDMENTS.
IN ADDITION TO VARIOUS BUDGET
TRAILER BILLS [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
SECRETARY CASHMAN.
OUR CASH.
NO MAN.
THE PROPOSAL'S YEAH BEFORE YOU
ARE A CONSOLIDATION OF ALL THE
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE
HAVE FOR THE BUDGET IN THE
SPRING SO THE READ THREE
APPROPRIATIONS AS EXTENSIONS OF
LIQUIDATIONS.
AND REVISIONS -- FOLLOWING THE
EARLIER HEARINGS WERE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE CONSOLIDATED A
CONSOLIDATION OF ALL THE
PROPOSALS WE DID MEET WITH STAFF
AND WITH THE LA -- AND WE
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
FOR THIS SET OF REQUEST I THANK
YOU FOR THAT ELLIE -- YOU HAVE A
FILE.
NO FILE.
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN TILL WE
FINISH EVERYTHING.
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
HI THIS IS THE ONLY.
MATTER FOR THE AYE RESOURCES
AGENCY.
ALL OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING
ANYONE WANT TO COME BACK.
COMMENT ON THESE VARIOUS.
BUDGET.
BILL ITEMS IN.
REIMBURSEMENT LOCAL SYSTEMS
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HOLE THAT MATTER
OPEN ITEM NUMBER.
NINETEEN ONCE AGAIN IS SHE
CONSERVATION CAMP REPLACEMENT
KITCHEN LET'S CALL OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION.
AND ONCE AGAIN.
MISTER PORTER CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR CONFIRMATION ON THE SENATE
FLOOR TODAY.
WE'RE A PLEASED TO HAVE YOU
OFFICIALLY ON BOARD.
THANK YOU SENATOR WACO SKI --
AND MEMBERS OF THE OF THE
COMMITTEE -- TOM PORTER.
RECTOR CAL FIRE.
I WILL BE PRESENTING -- FIRST ON
THE ISSUE NUMBER.
NINETEEN ISSUE CONSERVATION CAM.
FIVE A REPLACEMENT KITCHEN.
THIS REQUEST IS FOR FIVE POINT
THREE TWO EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
OF GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE COSTS OF
REPLACING.
THE KITCHEN AND DINING FACILITY.
AT ISSUE CAMP IN TO HIM A COUNTY
IT'S A ONE OF OUR CONSERVATION
CAMPS.
A HUNDRED AND TEN MEMBER CAMP.
I AND WAS BUILT IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE
UNFORTUNATELY THE THE KITCHEN
FACILITY BURNED IN JULY OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND WAS A
COMPLETE.
LOSS SO.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
REPLACING THAT FACILITY FOR
FEEDING OF MEMBERS?
OF THE CAMP.
LEE AFTER THE FIRE WE WERE
FEEDING THEM OUT OF ONE OF OUR
M. K. USE OUR MOBILE KITCHEN
UNITS THOSE ARE THE ONES WE TAKE
OUT THE FIRES.
WE NEED TO HAVE THOSE AVAILABLE
TO OUT THE FIRES WE DID REPLACE
SOME OF THE KITCHEN FACILITIES
SO THAT THEY COULD.
USE SOME OF THE OTHER BUILDINGS
AT THE CAMP -- FOR FOR FEEDING
AND DINING -- BUT THAT IS
IMPACTING THE USE OF THOSE
FACILITIES FOR STAGING OF
EQUIPMENT AND AND PERSONNEL --
AS WE MOVE THEM AROUND THE STATE
FOR FIRES IN THAT AREA.
THAT CAMP HI A NEEDS TO GET BACK
TO A NORMAL OPERATIONS -- IT IS
KEY TO OUR FORCE MANAGEMENT A
WORKING OBJECTIVES IN THE AREA
AND WILL HELP US WITH ROOM --
THE REMOVAL OF DEAD AND DYING
TREES IN THE SIERRAS.
WHEN I'M YOU'VE SEEN THE STAFF
REPORT IN THE LA GOES COMMON AND
A HUNDRED AND?
EIGHTY THOUSAND GALLON.
TANK AND THE PUMP STATION ABOUT.
APPS WILL BE A DIFFERENT SIZE
THAT MAY.
REDUCE THE PRICE.
POTENTIALLY HAVE A COMMENT ON
THAT BECAUSE OUR CELIO.
ON THEY'VE SPOTTED THE ISSUES I
WANT TO KNOW IF YOU'VE GOT A
CHANCE.
TO REVIEW IT.
WOULD YOU LIKE LA -- TO PRISON
FOR NO I WANNA I'M GONNA SAFETY
ALEJO WAS. FOR THAT I I I
BROUGHT WITH ME.
THIS IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
TECH SERVICES MIKE DUGGAN AND HE
WON TANK SPECIALIST -- YES WE'VE
HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH THE LA --
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
WHEN WE CARE ABOUT.
GETTING THE INFORMATION AS FAR
AS THE TANK SIZE IT WAS.
LATE IN THE PROCESS OF THAT'S
HOW IT GOT PUSHED HERE -- WE
TALKED WITH THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL'S WELL ON ALTERNATIVE
MEANS JUST LIGHTLY TOUCH OUR
GOING OVER THE CALCULATIONS TO
SEE IF WE CAN.
YOUR REDUCTION I RARELY THAT
WATER TANK IS -- TO SUPPLY ONLY
FIRE WATER DEDICATED FIREWATER
FOR THE NEW INSTITUTIONAL
MISSION.
SO -- I I BELIEVE IN THE LA
THOSE COMMENTS -- THAT THERE
WASN'T -- AMPLE TIME FOR THE
REVIEW OF THAT IMPOSSIBLE
REDUCTION AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING INTO AN ACTIVELY.
IT WAS THE FIRE PUMP.
WAS THAT ANTICIPATED IN THE
ORIGINAL BED THAT YOU WERE GOING
TO USE THE EXISTING FIRE PUMP
AND THAT SAID PETITION ACOSTA.
THE COMPLETE REPLACEMENT.
WELL MOVING MOVING AT A FEW
YEARS AGO -- WE HAD A MINOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECT TO
INCREASE -- WATER STORAGE AT THE
FACILITY BUT THAT WAS -- JUST.
GENERAL USE WAS COMBINED SO WE
HAD WAR HYDRANTS THROUGHOUT THE
FACILITY AND WAS FOR DRINKING
WATER -- BECAUSE THIS IS A I
DEDICATED -- FIRE REQUIREMENT
FOR THAT KITCHEN THE PREVIOUS
KITCHEN DIDN'T HAVE SPRINKLERS.
SO IN ORDER TO DELIVER THE FIRE
FLOW AS WELL IT WAS REQUIRED
THAT WE HAD. TO ADD A BOOSTER
PUMP FIRE PUMP -- SO IT IS A
NECESSITY [inaudible]
HOW YOU?
THIS COMPUTERS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M
MISTER CHARITIES ARE ALREADY
NOTED WE HAVE THREE SOME
CONCERNS WITH -- THE PROPOSAL
YOU SAW IT THE PROPOSAL FOR
FUNDING FOR THE CONSTRUCTION
PHASE OF THIS PROJECT.
I CAME BEFORE YOU AS PART OF
THAT JANUARY PACKET OF PROPOSALS
AND AT THE TIME THE COST FOR THE
KITCHEN WAS ABOUT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
I WITHIN THE SPAN OF THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS THE COST HAS
NOW GONE UP TO OVER ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE KITCHEN
AND THE AND THE PRIMARY COST
DRIVER IS THE SCOPE CHANGE TO
ADD TO THIS VERY LARGE -- WATER
TANK TO SUPPLY A FIRE PROTECTION
WATER FOR THE KITCHEN I WHAT WE
WOULD KNOW IS THAT TYPICALLY
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT MIGHT SEE
EYES SIGNIFICANT COST INCREASE --
ESPECIALLY SOMETHING DRIVEN BY A
SCOPE CHANGE THAT'S UNEXPECTED
AND THEY WOULD TYPICALLY HAVE
THE TIME TO KIND OF GO BACK AND
FORTH.
I'M LOOKING AT OPTIONS TO REDUCE
THAT IS THE FULL SCOPE TEENS ARE
CHANGE REALLY NECESSARY ARE
THERE OTHER WAYS TO MITIGATE THE
COST INCREASES OR VALUE
ENGINEERING THINGS THAT THEY CAN
DO. TO BRING THE COST DOWN
BEFORE THEY COME FORWARD TO THE
LEGISLATURE REQUESTING FUNDING
I'M JUST GIVEN THE TIMING OF
WHEN AT THE DEPARTMENT LEARNED
ABOUT THIS.
AND THEY HAVEN'T HAD THE CHANCE
TO DO THAT AND WAS -- SPOKEN TO
ALREADY THEY'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF STARTING THAT EFFORT.
ON IN ORDER TO ENSURE THEY
CONTINUE THOSE EFFORTS TO TRY TO
MITIGATE THIS COST INCREASE WE
WOULD RECOMMEND PROVIDING THE
FULL FINDING THAT THEY'RE
REQUESTING.
ADDING PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IN
THE BUDGET TO MAKE ON THIS
AUGMENTATION IN THAT THE SPRING
FINANCE LETTER AVAILABLE ONLY
AFTER THEY HAVE GONE THROUGH
THIS EXERCISE OF TRYING TO
MITIGATE THE COST.
AND REPORT BACK THROUGH THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE I'M JUST OF THE
LEGISLATURE CAN HAVE SOME
CONFIDENCE AND COMFORT THAT
THEY'RE TAKING ALL THE STEPS TO
MITIGATE THE COST INCREASES.
GIVEN THAT THIS IS BASICALLY A
DOUBLING OF THE COSTA JUST OVER
THE LAST THREE MONTHS.
I RECALL THE CHAIR WAS HAVING
KITTENS AT FIVE POINT.
THREE MILLION FOR THE KITCHEN
AND TO HIM A COUNTY SO ELEVEN
FOUR FOUR IS.
A MADE A GIFT FINANCE YOU HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE IF YOUR SERVER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
WANTED TO KNOW THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
LA -- ON THE L<c.cyan>G AND LANGUAGE</c>
YOU MAY THINK AND THE PROPOSED
NOT -- CLASSIC A CATASTROPHIC
DELAY TO THE PROJECT AS IT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED [inaudible]
MEMBERS [inaudible]
SENATE MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO JUST LOOK.
AT THIS IS NOT WHERE THE
DIRECTOR WANTED TO GO I WANT THE
WORDS IN YOUR MUTH BUT I CANNOT
IMAGINE RIGHT BECAUSE THIS IS.
WAY ABOVE I BELIEVE AT THE
ESTIMATE ON THAT WHERE YOU
THOUGHT SO.
IT'S A PRETTY EXTREME CASE.
I DON'T SEE THIS ALL THE TIME.
I WOULD ADD CARE TRIES THIS IS
ALSO ISOLATED BUT TALK TO US
ABOUT.
WORKING WITH THE GS.
IN THE DEPARTMENT.
IN WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD.
AND AND BECAUSE THIS IS A REALLY
BIG SWING FROM WHERE WE ALL
THOUGHT WE'D BE AND WHERE WE'RE
AT NOW.
I THINK THE OTHER CONCERN THAT I
HAVE IS VERY SIMILAR CAMP.
IS THE CHAIR OF REFERENCE
[inaudible]
DIFFERENT COUNTY.
I DIDN'T NEED THIS AT LARGE
RESERVOIR IF YOU WILL UP ON THE
GROUNDS SO -- AND I KNOW YOU
NEED MORE TIME TO BE ABLE TO
WORK THROUGH THIS.
I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE FOR
FLIPPING KITCHEN THAT WE'RE
GONNA I I NEED SOMETHING THIS
LARGE JUST MY OWN OPINION AND
I'M NOT A PROFESSIONAL BUT WOULD
LIKE TO GET A HERE YOUR FEEDBACK
ON ALL THE ITEMS.
ALONG WITH STATEMENTS AND MAKE.
RIGHT -- BEFORE I PASS IT AGAIN
TO MIKE DUGGAN -- JUST RELATED
TO WHAT WE ARE RETROFITTING AND
BUILDING ON TO A VERY OLD
FACILITY AS WELL.
AND THE THE NEED FOR FIRE WATER --
IS EVIDENT IN THAT KITCHEN BEING
GONE -- AND THE FIFTH DINING
FACILITY AS WELL AND MORE OF THE
FACILITY COULD HAVE GONE WITH IT --
SO -- THIS.
WELL WE KNOW WE NEED FIRE WATER
I THINK WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK INTO ALL OF OUR OPTIONS --
IT WE JUST HAVEN'T HAD THE TIME
TO DO THAT AND IN MOVING FORWARD --
THIS WILL GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT AND MOVE
FORWARD SO US THE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS -- RELATED TO THE
OTHER CAMP AND FIRE WATER AND I
MEAN I THINK THAT TO MY GOODNESS
YOU'RE DOING THIS IS A GIANT
RESERVOIR -- I WOULD SEEM GET IT
IN REGARDS IS A SPECIAL
CONDITIONS.
THAT THE DIRECTOR JUST MENTION
BUT I THINK THIS IS A BIT OVER
KILL.
I'M NOT SURE IF IT'S OVER KILL
AS FAR AS A REQUIREMENT -- EVEN
IF YOU'RE GONNA HAVE.
MEANS OF GETTING THAT SORT OF
WATER STORAGE AND DELIVERY -- WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE TIME TO GO
THROUGH WITH THE G. S. ON THAT
WE HAVE BEEN IN CAMP ENGINE.
AND THAT THE NEAREST FIRE
STATIONS WITHIN TWO MILES ONE OF
OURS PAINS CREEK -- THAT SHOULD
REDUCE THE VOLUME -- IN A
PREVIOUS FIRE -- THEY DRAFTED
OUT OF THE CREEK THAT RUNS
THROUGH CAMP THAT'S A WATER
SOURCE AS WELL -- WE'RE STILL
GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE DECADE
FIREWATER BUT WHAT WE'RE HOPING
TO DO IS LOOK AT ALL THE
ALTERNATIVE MEANS TO TO ADDRESS
WHAT THAT THE CODE IS.
IN IN WHEN I SAY OVER KILL IS
THE THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE THE
TANK RIGHT BECAUSE HE AS YOU
JUST MENTIONED.
YOU HAD A IN IS IT A WATER
TENDER IS AN ACTUAL -- FIRE
TRUCK THAT'S ON THE NATION IT'S
AN ENGINE BECAUSE THAT'S THE
OTHER PIECES IF NEED BE YOU CAN
LOOK AT BRING AN INTERNAL TENDER
TO BE ABLE TO KEEP IT THERE
RIGHT.
WITH AGAIN YES YOU YOU COULD
LOOK AT THAT OR WE COULD -- BOLT
A A FIRE PUMP TO THE GREAT.
ACTUALLY IN THE PROJECT AS FAR
AS DILLON DELIVERING THE FIRE
FLOW AND THAT'S WHY I USE THE
TERM OVER KILL AS FAR AS THE
ACTUAL TANK WITH ALL THE OTHER
MECHANISMS THAT YOU COULD DEPLOY.
TO BE ABLE TO FIRE SUPPRESSION
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IN THIS.
THEY SERVE A VERY CONDENSED
AMOUNT OF TIME GOOD TIMES
[inaudible]
HELP CHARGING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
UP JUST THAT KIND OF ADD ON WHAT
WE'RE DOING AS FAR AS WITH THE
G. S. WE'VE TALKED WITH -- DR --
A LITTLE BIT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND AND WHAT WE
THOUGHT WAS APPROPRIATE AND
ACCURATE ON GETTING -- ACCURATE
ESTIMATES EARLIER KIND OF TALKS
TO THE NEXT ISSUE -- ALSO AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE DISCUSSING
THAT WITH THE GS BUT PRIMARILY
WHAT WE SEE IS AT ABOUT 75%
WORKING DRAWINGS.
IS SO YOU'RE A FEW MONTHS AHEAD
OF GOING TO BED -- VERIFYING
THAT -- WITH THE G. S. AS FAR AS
OUR AND AND DISCUSSING WITH
FINANCE SO WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME
PAGE BEFORE THE PROJECT WAS WARD.
I SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS SIR
INTEREST AS MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY THIS IS.
THE CHALLENGE OF GETTING.
LABOR IN THE SANTA CRUZ
MOUNTAINS SAYS REPLACE HARD
GARAGE MUSIC.
SEE.
THE TRUE.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY AGAIN TOM
PORTER -- CAL FIRE.
THIS IS THE SAN MATTEO SANTA
CRUZ UNIT HEADQUARTERS A
RELOCATION OF THEIR AUTO SHOP.
HOW WE ARE REQUESTING SEVEN
POINT THREE FOUR THREE MILLION
DOLLARS OF LEASE REVENUE BONDS --
IN ADDITION IF IF FOR ADDITIONAL --
CONSTRUCTION COSTS -- THAT ARE
RELATED.
TO MOVING THIS FACILITY TO A NEW
LOCATION -- AND THAT IS -- AS
YOU MENTIONED IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY IN THE SANTA CRUZ
MOUNTAINS.
FROM FELTON TO BEN LOMOND -- THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE -- WENT OUT
FOR BID AND WE FOUND THAT THE
THE ESTIMATES THAT WE HAD BUILT
THE BET BUDGET ON WERE NOT
COMMENSURATE WITH THE COSTS OF
DOING.
CONSTRUCTION IN THAT AREA AT
THIS POINT IN TIME -- AND SO
THERE IS THE BUDGET OVERRUNS ARE
AT IN IN ALL AREAS -- IT'S THE
THE ABOR AND MATERIALS -- AND
THEN ALSO OVERHEAD RATES AND
CONTINGENCY THAT ALL INCREASE
BASED ON THOSE RATES GOING UP.
GET A NICE TEN YEAR DELAY RIGHT.
SEVEN AND THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED PROJECT AS
WELL.
WHO DO GUEST IN BEN LOMOND I
ALEJO?
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THOUGH AS WAS SORT OF ALLUDED TO
BY A AS SOME OF THE SOME OF
SENATOR MAGUIRE'S COMMENTS ON
THE THE LAST ITEM AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE WOULD ROUTE I
RECOMMEND FOR THE LEGISLATURE IS
JUST AND MAYBE DIGGING IN A
LITTLE BIT.
MORE ON SOME OVERSIGHT SO THEN
IT.
THANK COST INCREASES HERE ARE
PARTLY RELATED TO THE MARKET
CONDITIONS I IN THE AREA THE
PROJECT IS BEING BILL.
I'M FROM OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT WITH FINANCE IT
DOES SOUND LIKE AND BECAUSETHIS
PROJECT WAS USING THE DESIGNS
AND ESTIMATES FROM EIGHTY HAVE
PRIOR VERY SIMILAR PROJECT --
SOME OF THOSE THINGS WERE SORT
OF JUST EXPORTED OVER TO BE USED
FOR THIS PROJECT.
AND THERE MAY BE THINGS THAT
WERE NOT AND FULLY UPDATED TO
REFLECT ON BOTH THE SPECIFIC
LOCATION OR MAYBE TO REFLECT
CHANGES THAT HAPPEN ON THE OTHER
PROJECTS OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT PROJECT.
ON ENDED UP I'M EXCEEDING ITS
BUDGET VERY SIGNIFICANT OTHER
PROJECTS OTHER PROJECT ON AND SO.
I THINK FOR US WE SORT OF A AT
THIS POINT THERE'S NOT A WHOLE
LOT YOU KNOW IF YOU WANT TO GO
FOR THE PROJECT IT SORT OF IS
WHAT IT IS -- BUT IN TERMS AT
ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIA -- HAS
APPROPRIATED AND PROCESS SEASON
PLACE IN THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE D. . S. AND HOW THEY ARE
WORKING BACK AND FORTH TO MAKE
SURE.
THAT IF THEY ARE USING THE
ESTIMATES ARE DESIGNS FROM OF A
PRIOR PROJECT THAT THEY ARE
BEING.
I'M FULLY UPDATED TO ACCOUNT FOR
ALL THE VARIOUS THINGS THAT LED
TO THE COST INCREASE ON THIS
PROJECT -- AND TO REALLY ENSURE
THAT THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN
IF THIS PROCESS THESE AREN'T IN
PLACE.
I'M YOU MIGHT SEE THIS HAPPENING
AGAIN ON FUTURE PROJECTS AND SO
WE THINK IT'S JUST A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY -- FOR FOR SOME
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT ON ME JUST
WITH THE I INITIAL REACTION IS
IT'S IT'S AN AUTO GARAGE I MEAN
IT'S AN AUTO REPAIR SHOP IT'S
TWO TWO LIVES TO FIVE LIVES OKAY
IT MIGHT GET A LITTLE
COMPLICATED THE LAST TEN YEARS
BUT IT'S STILL.
AN AUTO REPAIR SHOP IN TH MUNA
FROM FELTON.
TO YOU KNOW BEN LOMOND OKAY.
AND YOU'LL COME BACK WITH US ON
THEYEAH I'M TRYING TO BE --
VERY CAREFUL WITH THAT
PROPERTIES WE ABANDONED SO I DID
YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT THE IT'S
EXPECTED THAT.
DEVELOPMENT SHOP IS GOING TO BE.
DESTROYED AND OF AN ABATED AND I
KNOW THAT THEIR I ASSUME BECAUSE
OF THE OIL AND THE ACTIVITIES
THAT WENT ON THERE SINCE
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE OR WHATEVER
IT IS.
THERE THERE IS A HAZARDOUS WASTE
ISSUE THE QUESTION IS IS THAT
YOU KNOW FELT AND DOESN'T HAVE
THOSE MANY BUILDINGS RIGHT I
MEAN THIS SO I DON'T KNOW IF I
ASSUME THAT THE THE AUTO SHOP IS
GONE GONE GONE IS JUST READY TO
BE DESTROYED BUT WILL DEAL WITH.
THAT LATER MEMBERS.
IN THE AREA THAT CENTER MONEY
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
SHE THE COMMENTS I WOULD JUST
HIGHLIGHT SOME.
BUT I THINK WAS REFERRED
[inaudible]
TO IN.
IN THE ASSESSMENT HERE IN OUR
NOTES SOME.
THE PROJECT WAS BID IN FEBRUARY
OF THIS YEAR.
IN THE LOWEST BID WAS 67% HIGHER.
THAN THE STATE ESTIMATES.
THAT DOES REFLECT THE CURRENT
MARKET CONDITIONS IF YOU CAN'T
GET ANYONE.
THE BUILD FOR WHAT THE STATE'S
OFFERING.
THEN THE DIS SERVICES ULTIMATELY
TO KEEPING.
THESE VEHICLES IN SHAPE IN
RUNNING THE RESPOND TO FIRE SO --
I THINK SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE.
FOR TRYING TO FINE TUNE HOW.
OUR PRICING THESE AT THE OUTSET
IN NOT USING OUTDATED.
DATA -- THIS IS THE AREA WHERE
WE NEED IT -- YOU MIGHT GET.
A LOWER BID IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT THAT'S NOT GONNA
HOME SERVICING VEHICLES IN THIS
HIGH.
PROPENSITY FIRE AREAS SO.
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD I WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE.
ONCE FOR CONDITIONS TO HOLD IT
OPEN TODAY BUT LET'S MOVE BEYOND
THE KITCHEN BEYOND THE GARAGE
THE SCHOOL.
TO SENATE BILL NINE NO ONE IN
THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR THE
WILD FIRE MITIGATION PROGRAM.
SO.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY ONE AND THE ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY ONE AGAIN TOM PORTER --
CAL FIRE -- THIS IS A A CALPERS
REQUEST FOR EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLAR I'M SORRY
EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
THAT'S A BIG CHANGE.
OF GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUNDS.
DO OF FOR THE ADDITION.
OF TWO POSITIONS ABOVE THAT THE
ONE THAT'S CURRENTLY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET -- TO
MEET THE REVIEW AND ASSESSMENT
NEEDS -- IN CONJUNCTION WITH C.
P. YOU SEE THIS IS THE CAL FIRE.
COLLABORATIVE WITH CPUC.
THAT ARE IN ADDITION TO WHAT
NINE NO ONE CALLED.
FOR AND BASED ON CHANGES THAT
WERE MADE IN JANUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES.
ASSESSMENTOF OF AND ADDS TO
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE IN THOSE
PLANS.
AND THE REVIEW OF THOSE PLANS --
THAT CALIFORNIA IS GOING.
TO HAVE TO DO UNDER THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE.
WE'RE CLEAR BECAUSE I THINK
MAYBE.
LEGISLATORS NAIVELY ASSUME THAT
WHEN YOU YOU ALLOCATE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION AND WE DID IT IN
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE BEFORE NINE A
ONE THAT THAT SORT OF INCLUDED
THE WHOLE NOT.
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW IN THE
DIFFERENT POSITIONS IMAGES ALL
THERE AND YOU'RE SAYING THAT THE
JUDGE DETERMINED.
UC DETERMINED THAT WE NEEDED TO
EXPAND TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
UNDER NINE A ONE IS AT THE NOT
SHALL.
FINANCE HOUSING HERE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IT JUST TO CLARIFY
I'M THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
PROVIDED BY A SB NINE NO ONE IS
REALLY INTENDED FOR FOREST
HEALTH AND FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES AND PROJECTS -- OF
THAT AMOUNT THERE'S A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY MILLION FOR PROJECTS
AND THEN SIR.
I AM. HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION
FOR PROJECTS AND THEN THIRTY
FIVE MILLION FOR PRESCRIBE
FACTOR SO THAT THAT ALLOCATION
IS REALLY SPECIFIC FOR WHAT IT'S
INTENDED.
TO THEN THERE'S THE BROADER
REQUIREMENTS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE GENERALLY SB NINE A ONE
AB TWO NINE ONE ONE AND IT'S SO
THERE'S OTHER BILLS WITHIN THAT
PACKAGE SB TWELVE SIXTY AS WALL.
THAT.
NEED TO BE IMPLEMENTED AND SO
THAT DOESN'T COME OUT OF THAT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WOULD BE A ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
GIVEN THE PURPOSE FOR WHICH I
THAT TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
WAS PROVIDED.
THIS IS INTERESTING BECAUSE THE
YEAR BEFORE WE DID TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IN HERE AND IT WAS SORT
OF I'VE I WAS UNDER THE DELUSION
THAT WAS JUST A COPY CAT. FOR
FIVE FIVE YEARS ALEJO YOU AGREE
TO ANNOUNCES YEAH A THINK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I HAS
SAID IS ACCURATE SO WE DIDN'T WE
DON'T HAVE ANY ISSUES WHEN WE
LOOKED AT THAT PROPOSAL FOR THE
TWO POSITIONS. TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT MORE CONTEXT ON THE
JANUARY BUDGET INCLUDED ONE
POSITION AT CAL FIRE OF FOR
DOING AT THE REVIEW OF THE WILD
FIRE MITIGATION.
PLANS FROM THE UTILITIES AND
REALLY THAT'S WHAT THESE
POSITIONS ARE GOING TO BE DOING
AND SUPPORTING THAT.
ON THIS WOULD ADD TWO MORE
POSITIONS CURRENTLY I'M AND
RECENTLY THE DEPARTMENT HAS HAD
IT WINE TEMPORARY POSITION.
I'M WORKING ON THE PRE AS BEING
I KNOW WHEN WELFARE MITIGATION
PLANS AND THAT WAS FUNDEDTHROUGH A COOPERATIVE AGREEMENT
WITH THE P. C..
AND AND CAL FIRE WASN'T
SPECIFICALLY CALLED OUT
NECESSARILY AS HAVING A ROLE IN
THAT THEY WERE JUST MORE
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
UNDER SB NINE A ONE BECAUSE HOW
FIRE ON IS SPECIFICALLY CALLED
OUT AS HAVING A ROLE IN I'M IN
REVIEWING THE PLANS.
AND WE THINK OF THEM HAVING
THEIR OWN STAFF SEEMS REASONABLE
AND THREE POSITIONS GIVEN THE
NUMBER IN THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
PLANS I'M SEEMED REASONABLE --
ARDOR STANDING OF THAT
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE RULED
LEAN AND JUST REALLY AFFECTS THE
NUMBER AS WELL FOR MITIGATION
PLANS SO GOING FROM I THINK SIX
TO ELEVEN ON AND SO THAT'S PART
OF WHAT IS CHANGING THIS FROM
WHAT YOU SIGNED JANUARY IS THAT
THERE'S NO MORE PLANS THAT
THEY'RE GONNA.
HAVE TO BE.
REVIEWING AND AND TO US THAT
WOULD BE SEPARATE AND APART FROM
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION WHICH IS
GOING TO BE GRANT FUNDS GOING
OUT FOR FOREST HEALTH.
AND FIRE PREVENTION AND THIS IS
REALLY ON THE UTILITY SIDE SO
WOULD I BE TOO NAIVE TO I
ANTICIPATE THAT THERE'S COULD BE
A LOT OF WEALTH UTILITY WILDFIRE
MEDICATION PLANS FILES SO WE'LL
TO HAVE THREE PEOPLE REVIEWING
THEM.
THAT THEY WOULD BE.
LOOK DAD REVIEWED AND APPROVED
AT A FASTER PACE OR IS HE JUST
MORE APPLIQUE -- APPLICATIONS
COMING IN UNDER THE MITIGATION
PLAN SO WILL BE AT THE SAME
[inaudible]
TEMPO.
RELATED TO THAT AND I I DO HAVE --
CHIEF MIKE RICH WINE THE FIRE
MARSHAL HERE BUT I I'M GONNA --
JUST MENTION THE THE CPUC HAS A
TIME LINE THAT IS REQUIRED FOR
THE MIDDLE REVIEW AND APPROVAL --
SO WE WOULD FIT INTO THAT
TIMELINE OF CPUC.
HELL FIRE IS PROVIDING A MORE --
IN DEPTH.
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT AND REVIEW
OF THOSE DOCUMENTS AND THOSE
DOCUMENTS ARE ARE HAVE BEEN
ENHANCED FROM WHERE THEY WERE
WHEN WE STARTED THIS PROCESS AS
WELL. TWENTY I THINK YOU YES
JUST TO ADD ON TO WHAT YOU
PORTER SAID.
WE WERE MARRIED UPPER WILDFIRE
EXPERTISE WITH THE UTILITIES
ENGINEERING AND AN INTERVIEW
EXPERTISE -- OF THEIRS OF THE
ELEMENTS THAT ARE BEING REVIEWED
THERE'S TWENTY ELEMENTS
ESTABLISHED IN A TEMPLATE THAT
THAT WE WORKED ON WITH
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE CPC.
SEVEN OF THOSE ARE WILDFIRE
INTENSIVE AND THAT'S YOU KNOW
RIGHT IN OUR WILL HOUSE -- THESE
PLANS ARE HUNDRED A HUNDRED
EIGHTY PAGES -- AND SO THEY'RE
THEY'RE PRETTY DETAILED AND ALSO
WE'RE GONNA BE TRANSITIONING TO
THESE WERE ALL SUBMITTED AT ONCE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE COMING IN IN
FUTURE YEARS -- WHEN THEY WHEN
THEY EXPIRE AND SO WE'LL BE
REVIEWING THESE PLANS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS EVERY YEAR ALSO
CONDUCTING EDUCATION WE'RE
UPDATING OUR?
OUR PYRO OUR POWER LINE -- GUIDE
THE EDUCATE OUR FIELD UNITS ON
HOW TO CONDUCT INSPECTIONS AND
ALSO WILL BE -- CONTINUING TO
PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT
OVER THE OVER TO ENSURE THE
UTILITIES ARE MEETING THE GOALS
IN THEIR PLANS HOUSE THE WORK.
RECESSION GOING BECAUSE AND
WE'VE HAD SEVERAL DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT FIRE SEASON WE GOT SEVERAL
DISCUSSIONS ANIMATED DISCUSSIONS
I MAY SAY ABOUT THE PREVENTION.
SO THESE ARE MITIGATION PLAN SO
I PRESUME THAT THE DAY AFTER
FIRE SEASON ENDS THAT ALL THESE
MITIGATION PLANS ARE GOING TO BE
ACTED ON SO IS THE ANTICIPATION
THAT THE WORK.
ON THESE HUNDRED HUNDRED EIGHTY
PAGES ARE THAT.
I HAVE PREPARED AND THEN ONCE
IT'S ALL ALL CLEAR THAT WE CAN
GO THAT THAT THE WORK IS GOING
TO BE PACKED COMMENCED.
I MEAN BECAUSE WE DO HAVE IT
SEASON HERE.
CORRECT.
AND THOSE PLANS WERE DUE TO THE
C. P. U. C. ON MARCH NINETEENTH.
AND SO THAT REVIEW IS IS GOING
IS UNDER WAY RIGHT NOW -- BUT WE
WILL BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
C. P. C. TO ENSURE THAT YOU KNOW
THE THE ELEMENTS IN THE PLANS.
ARE ARE BEING BROUGHT FORTH INTO
THE FIELD.
OKAY MEMBERS QUESTIONS THIS IS
THE URBAN WILDLIFE.
OUR UTILITY WILDLIFE MEDICATION
PLANS.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS MATTER
OPEN MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WE
HAVE THREE MATTERS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION ISSUES NUMBER.
NINETEEN THE ISSUE IS SHE CAMP
KITCHEN ISSUE TWENTY THE
CEMETERY SANTA CRUZ.
AUTO GARAGE IN ISSUE NUMBER --
TWENTY ONE THE UTILITY WHILE
FIRE MITIGATION OPEN THE PUBLIC
HEARING MEMBERS COMMENT.
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I THANK YOU NEXT TIME THIS CALL
OF THE STATE.
HE DIRECTOR BOTTOM WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
WE'D LIKE.
TO GO TO ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY FOUR THIS IS THE SERVICE.
PLEASE BUDGET -- REVIEW
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
THE TIMES THEY ARE A. CHANGING
PLEASE.
DEPUTY BOTTOM GO AHEAD THIS IS
AN EXCITING PRESS RECTOR
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS CHUCK BOTTOM ON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
I APPRECIATE THE REQUEST FROM
COMMITTEE STAFF TO SPEND EXTRA
MOMENT AND EXPLAIN SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING. FOR THE COMMITTEE AND
OUR PROGRESS TODAY.
SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO IS
COVER THE WHO.
THE WHAT.
THE WHERE IN THE Y..
SO THE TECHNICAL REQUEST IN
FRONT OF YOU -- THIS SPRING
FINANCE LETTER IS FOR A ONE TIME.
TWO MILLION DOLLAR.
APPROPRIATION FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE FUND
STAFF RECOMMENDATION OF COURSE
IS APPROVED AS BUDGET.
WHAT IS SERVICE BASED BUDGETING?
IT TURNS OUT IT'S ACTUALLY A
BUSINESS DISCIPLINE.
WITHIN THE MANAGEMENT
CONSULTANCY WORLD.
FOLKS TO GO TO GRADUATE SCHOOL
FOR BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION
SPECIALIZE IN IT.
AND IN FACT THERE'S A SUB NIECE
WITHIN SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
THAT IS FOCUSED ON PUBLIC SECTOR.
ENTITIES ENTERPRISES
[inaudible]
IT'S A ASPECT OF MANAGEMENT
REVIEW WHICH FOCUSES ON FOUR KEY
THINGS.
THE FIRST THING THAT THE FOCUS.
DIREXION SELF TOWARDS IS
ANALYZING AN ENTITY OR AN
ENTERPRISES TASK.
THE ACTUAL ACTIVITIES THEY DO AT
A VERY GRANULAR LEVEL.
FROM WHETHER IT'S SENDING A
PATROL BOAT OUT INTO THE CHANNEL
ISLANDS TO CLEANING THE
RESTROOMS AN ECOLOGICAL RESERVE
AND EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
THE SECOND KEY ASPECT IS THAT
IT'S LABOR FOCUS.
YOU ANALYZE THE TASKS OF THE
ENTERPRISE.
BENCHMARKED AGAINST THE MISSION.
AND THEN YOU GO THROUGH A
SCRUTON IS ATION OF THE HOURS
YOUR LABOR FORCE ARE APPLYING.
TO RID THE RESPECTIVE TAX.
THE THIRD PRONG IS.
YOU ORGANIZE THIS REVIEW BY
SERVICE.
INSTEAD OF THINKING IN WORD
ABOUT THE BUREAUCRACY OF THE
ENTERPRISE YOU LOOK OUT WORDS IN
YOU PONDER.
AND REVIEW WHAT DO YOUR CLIENTS
EXPECT.
AND YOU STRUCTURE THIS REVIEW OF
TASKS.
LABOR FORCE AROUND THE SERVICES
YOU'RE PROVIDING TO THE CLIENT
OR IN THIS CASE THE PUBLIC.
AND THE LAST THING YOU DO IS YOU
BRING ANALYTICS TO BEAR.
AND YOU CREATE A TECHNOLOGICALLY
INNOVATED SYSTEM TO TRACK ALL
THESE METRICS AND THEN ANNUALLY
UPDATE THEM.
SO THAT'S SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING HOW DID WE GET HERE.
WELL IT'S A SEVENTY YEAR OLD
DILEMMA.
I ACTUALLY TOLD YOU LAST YEAR
THAT I FOUND A NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT BOOZ ALLEN REPORT.
I TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE.
ANALYZING OUR DEPARTMENT AND ITS
FUNDING SITUATION BACK IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A FISHING GAME CODE
PROVISION SEVEN TEN POINT FIVE
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE IS FOUND
AND DECLARED.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS UNDER
FUNDED AND MUST SEEK RELIABLE
FUNDING.
IT IS MANY OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS KNOW -- BACK IN
200-010-2000 ELEVEN ASSEMBLY
BILL.
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX
INSTRUCTED OUR DEPARTMENT TO
CREATE A STAKEHOLDER DRIVEN
PROCESS.
AND GO THROUGH A REVIEW OF THE
REFORMS NECESSARY FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT TO MODERNIZE IT.
AND OUR SISTER ENTITY ARE
FISHING GAME COMMISSION.
AND IN A NONPARTISAN REPORT.
A VERY BROAD STAKEHOLDER GROUP
CAME UP WITH TWENTY EIGHT
RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD ABOUT TWO
BUDGET CYCLES.
WHERE ID BEEN IN FRONT OF YOU
IN PRETTY TENSE MOMENTS TALKING
ABOUT FEE INCREASES ACROSS
SEVERAL SECTORS?
AND HOW TO DEAL WITH OUR COST OF
SERVICE DYNAMIC.
THEN IN THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN YOU
INSTRUCTED OUR DEPARTMENT TO
BRING OUR BAND BACK TOGETHER. TO
GET ALTHOUGH STAKEHOLDERS BACK
TOGETHER AND ASSESS OUR STATUS.
IN FILLING THOSE TWENTY EIGHT
RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE SUBMITTED A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN OCTOBER.
OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ABOUT
THAT.
THEN IN NOVEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THAT STAKEHOLDER BASE
CAME UP WITH AN EXPENDITURE
CONCEPT.
THAT LED INTO LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
CYCLE.
AND HERE'S THE TAKE AWAY THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN APPROPRIATED AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR OUR DEPARTMENT.
IN A SIGNED US THE TASK OF DOING
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING.
WHY ARE WE IN THE SPOT I THINK
WE ARE IN THE SPOT BECAUSE?
OF THE PURSUIT OF SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION.
WE HAVE MORE ANIMALS AND PLANTS
IN THE STATE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE IN THE UNION.
MORE OF THEM ARE FOUND NO WHERE
ELSE IN THE WORLD.
SO THEY'RE INCREDIBLY RARE.
WE HAVE AN INTERSECT OF A
THRIVING ECONOMY.
AND INCREDIBLE NATURAL WEALTH.
IN MAKING THOSE WORK TOGETHER IS
A LOT OF OUR DEPARTMENTS
JURISDICTION.
SO WHY SERVICE BASED BUDGETING.
I THINK TO ME FOR OUR DEPARTMENT
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING IS OUR
MOMENT IN TIME. TO DO RIGHT
AROUND TRANSPARENCY.
AROUND TRUST.
AROUND INNOVATION AROUND
EFFICIENCIES AROUND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
YOU GAVE US SPECIFIC ASSIGNMENTS
AND SB EIGHT FIFTY FOUR HERE
THEY ARE.
YOU TOLD US BY DECEMBER
FIFTEENTH OF TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN GET A CONSULTANT FIRM
UNDER CONTRACT CHECK.
WE'VE HIRED.
BEFORE THAT DEADLINE DELOITTE
THE NATIONAL CONSULTING FIRM.
WHO BY THE WAY IS THE FIRM THAT
DID A SIMILAR PROCESS FOR OUR
STATE PARKS DEPARTMENT?
WHICH HAS FACILITATED THAT PARKS
DEPARTMENT'S RELATIONSHIP.
AND I THINK YOU SEE IT FEET INTO
PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT AND OTHER STRATEGIC
REFORMS FOR THAT DEPARTMENT.
SO WE HARD DE EXPERT. TO BE OUR
CONSULTANT.
YOU TOLD US BY DECEMBER OF LAST
YEAR.
THE FORMER LEADERSHIP TEAM WE'VE
DONE THAT.
YOU TOLD US TO FORM AN EXTERNAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE WE'VE DONE
THAT IT HAS ABOUT EIGHTY PEOPLE
ON IT.
AND YOU TOLD US TO GIVE YOU A
STATUS REPORT WE'VE DONE THAT.
BY APRIL FIFTEENTH OF TWENTY
TWENTY YOU HAVE ASKED US TO GIVE
AN INTERIM STATUS REPORT AND
APPEAR IN OVERSIGHT HEARINGS ON
THE PROGRESS.
BY JANUARY FIFTEENTH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE YOU TOLD US TO
COMPLETE OUR FINAL REPORT.
AND MY APRIL FIFTEENTH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE YOU'VE ASKED US TO
REFER.
HOW THE OUTCOMES HAVE BEEN
INTEGRATED INTO OUR BUDGET
CHANGE PROCESS [inaudible]
SO.
WHAT I HAVE DONE AS DIRECTOR IS?
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
PEOPLE ACROSS OUR DEPARTMENT.
YOUNG TO OLD DIVERSITY IN
EXPERIENCE BACKGROUND AND
POSITION WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
TO DO THIS.
I'M PERSONALLY ENGAGED ON A
WEEKLY BASIS.
WE SAT DOWN WITH THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT COUNTLESS TIMES TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY LEARNED.
SO WE CAN SAVE MONEY TO ITS
SMARTER FASTER THE SECOND GO
AROUND.
WITH BRIEF JURORS.
AND I AM VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
BECAUSE THE BENEFITS TO ME PROVE
WHAT I THINK PEOPLE WANT FROM
GOVERNMENT.
IT IS POSSIBLE TO PAUSE PLAY
RIGOR TO YOUR ACTIVITIES AND
COME OUT MORE TRANSPARENTLY
FORMED IN SHAPE FOR OUR FUTURE.
WHAT'S THE REQUEST. TO THE
ORIGINAL FUNDING ALLOCATION WAS
TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
WE TOOK ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
AND WE HARD TO LLOYD.
WE TOOK FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
WHICH COVERED ARE.
OUR BURDEN OF YOU KNOW
REDIRECTING A HUNDRED THIRTY
PEOPLE ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
DO THIS.
WE WILL BE DONE WITH MOST OF THE
MILESTONES AS WE GET TO THE END
OF THIS YEAR BUT THERE'S A
SECOND PHASE WHICH I WOULD ARGUE
IS MORE IMPORTANT. ONE OF THE
OUTCOMES IS A TECHNOLOGICALLY
DRIVEN TOOL A DASHBOARD.
IT ALLOWS YOU TO SEE THESE TASKS
THESE SERVICES AND OUR
ACCOUNTING.
BENCHMARKED AGAINST OUR CURRENT
ABILITY.
AND ARE PROJECTED FUTURE NEEDS.
WHAT'S LEFT TO DO IN THE SECOND
PHASE IS I NEED THIS OUTCOME TO
BECOME A WAY OF LIFE WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT.
I NEED TO TAKE THREE THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES.
RETRAINING.
THROUGH CHANGE MANAGEMENT.
AN INSTITUTIONAL CULTURALLY
AWARE.
KIND OF EMPLOYEE SENSE THAT THIS
IS OUR TOOL FOR OUR FUTURE.
THAT WE USE THAT ARE THINKING
ARE PLANNING IN OUR ACTIVITIES.
THAT'S THE REQUEST FOR THE
ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION DOLLARS
AS WELL AS COMPLETE THE FINAL
REPORTING.
THAT HAPPENED OUT IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I'LL STOP AND
SEE IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
EXCELLENT.
THIS IS A APPROVE IS REQUESTED
LA -- YOU HAVE COMMENTS.
YES GOOD MORNING RACHEL EHLERS
WITH THE LEGEND LISTS OFFICE I
WE HAVE BEEN REALLY ENCOURAGED
BY THE ENTHUSIASM AND PROGRESS
AND COMMUNICATION THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS -- BEEN SHOWING
WITH REGARD TO THIS EFFORT IT
WAS SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADDED AN REQUEST IT
WASN'T SOMETHING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT CAME FORWARD TO
REQUEST BUT THEY'VE.
CLEARLY REALLY BOUGHT INTO IT
AND ARE RUNNING WITH IT.
SO WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THIS IS
REALLY GOING TO YIELD A HELPFUL
TOOL BOTH FOR THE DEPARTMENT FOR
YOU AS POLICY MAKERS AND FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THE FUTURE.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THE VERY
READ MISTER CHAIRMAN TO SAY.
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE DIRECTOR
WORKING ON THIS?
WITH A BIASED VIEW TOWARDS
FISHERIES I END UP ON THE MANY
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD ON
WHICH FISHERIES BEING.
I HOW YOU IN CUMBER FISHERY
COUNTS AND HOW THAT WORKS HAS
BEEN A CHALLENGING AT TIMES
THANK EVERYONE EVEN INTO
INTERNALLY OF HIT THEIR HEAD
AGAINST A WALL.
IN BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS
TRANSPARENT PROCESS IS GONNA BE
HUGE BOTH.
FOR FISHERIES THE INDUSTRY AND
INTERNALLY AS WELL TO BE AGAIN
ACCURATE ACCOUNTING I'M CAN YOU
JUST REAL QUICK RUN DOWN.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THE MONTHS
TO COME TIMELINE FOR US JUST SO
WE HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
LITTLE MORE DETAIL.
YES [inaudible]
SO.
IN ADDITION TO THE STAND UP
ACTIVITIES HIRING CONSULTANT
GIVE FORMING TEAMS.
WE'RE IN A HEAVY MEETING MOMENT
AND I SEE THAT RUNNING THROUGH.
THE REST OF THIS SUMMER AS AN
INDICATOR.
WE'VE DONE OUR FIRST CUT WITH
THOSE A HUNDRED AND TWENTY OR
THIRTY PEOPLE OF OUR TASKS.
AND DAY IDENTIFIED -- THREE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE TASKS WE PROVIDE
AS SERVICES TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
BASED ON THE ACCOUNT THE
INDIVIDUAL COUNTY YOUR LIVER ACT
AND ALL THE WORK WE DO LITERALLY
CHANGING THE TOILET PAPER AT THE
RESERVE.
TO THE SURVEY FOR HEARING AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN BIGGER AND
SMALLER. TO WEAR DOWN AT THAT
LEVEL OF GRANULARITY NOW WE NEED
TO DO SOME SORTING AND FILTERING.
IT DEPENDS A LITTLE BIT ON
WHETHER YOU'RE A LUMP OR A
SPLITTER I PROJECT WE GET DOWN
TO ABOUT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
TASK WHEN WE'RE DONE.
THEN WE'VE GOT TO GO OUT AND
CONTINUE OUR EXTERNAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MEETINGS TAKE IT BACK
TO ARE STAKEHOLDERS GET THEIR
FEEDBACK.
WE'VE ALSO.
FORCED OURSELVES TO STOP TALKING
ABOUT OUR OWN BUREAUCRACY WE'RE
CURRENTLY STRUCTURED.
USING OUR OWN LINGO.
AND WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THE LAST
MONTH.
IS FIGURE OUT HOW TO WAIT TO
DEFINE OUR SERVICES USING PLAIN
ENGLISH PLAIN LANGUAGE.
THAT THE CUSTOMER CONNECTS WITH
BETTER.
WE'VE TAKEN ALL THOSE CATEGORIES
OF SERVICES BACK OUT TO THE
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY AND WE
SECOND FEEDBACK.
SO I SEE THAT ITERATIVE EXCHANGE.
GOING THROUGH THE REST OF THE
SUMMER SECOND MAIN ACTIVITY.
WE'RE BUILDING AT THE
TECHNOLOGICAL TOOL.
THAT THEN TAKES ALL THIS INPUT
AND DISPLAYS IT IN.
LET ME GIVE YOU SOME
HYPOTHETICALS YOU WANT TO LOOK
AT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN HUMBOLDT
COUNTY.
YOU CAN CLICK ON THIS TOOL YOU
CAN FIND IT HUMBOLDT COUNTY YOU
GO TO LANCE MANAGEMENT.
YOU SEE ALL THE PROPERTIES YOU
CLICK AND THEN SEE A PIE CHART
WHICH DESCRIBES CURRENT
EXPENDITURES BENCHMARKING.
AGAINST IF WE REALLY WERE
ACHIEVING SUCCESS RIGHT.
SO WE'RE BUILDING THAT
TECHNOLOGICAL TO AT THE SAME
TIME AND I THINK WE'RE TEST
DRIVING IT INTERNALLY.
I THINK BY THE TIME WE GET TO
LATE SUMMER EARLY FALL KIND OF
DAYLIGHTING THAT AND WORK
SHOPPING THAT AS WELL.
IN IN SIX SAME IDEA ON CRAB
HERESY HIM IN RIGHT TO JUST. TO
ALSO PERMITTING -- FOR
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS TO INSERT
EVERYTHING TO GETTING PEOPLE
OUTDOORS TO ENHANCING WILL SAVE
YOU KNOW CONSERVATION IN THE
OCEAN.
AND EVERYTHING WE'RE TRYING TO
DO.
I THINK THAT'S THE MAJORITY OF
THIS YEAR.
AND BY THE END OF THIS YEAR
WE'RE IN A GOOD POSITION WITH
ALL THE THE ANALYTICS THE DATA.
AND THE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
IN GREEN LIGHT AS FAR AS THIS IS
NOW GOING TO BE A USABLE TOOL
WITHIN THE OFFICE WHAT WAS YOUR
GOT.
I THINK AT THE END OF THIS YEAR
WE SHOULD HAVE A TOOL THAT'S
REALLY HELPING US BE MORE
STRATEGIC AS WE'RE WORKING WITH
OUR SISTER AGENCIES.
IT MAY NOT YET BE FULLY FINAL.
OR PUBLISHED IF YOU WILL A GOOD
ENOUGH TO HAVE IT START TO GUIDE
OUR OWN DECISION MAKING AND
POTENTIALLY USED BY THE TIME YOU
SEE ME YOUR NEXT YEAR.
ASSUMING I'M STILL AROUND WHICH
I DIDN'T END UP.
BUT WHAT IS THE WHAT I'M SEEING
HE SAYS I FOR EXAMPLE AND AGAIN
I'M NOT TRYING.
TO FOCUS JUST ON FISHERIES JUST
BECAUSE IT'S SO MUCH TOP OF MIND
RIGHT.
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO STAY ON THE
CRAP ACCOUNT.
THIS IS HOW MUCH PEOPLE POWER WE
USED.
TESTING COST US ACTS OF ME.
I'M JUST USING Z. EXAMPLES
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE HOPING TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO DE GIVE THAT'S
WHAT I'M HOPING TO I DON'T KNOW
THE LEVEL OF COMPLETE PRECISION.
IT'S HARD TO TAKE AN INDIVIDUAL
PERSON AND SAY 10% OF U. S.
CRASHERS.
AND PERCENT OF YOU IS ROCK SAYS
10% OF U. S. LAFOREST BUT WE'RE
GOING TO GET TO A BETTER LEVEL
OF PRECISION.
THEN WE ARE TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANKS WORK.
IN OUR MONEY.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO ADD MONEY --
DOES FOR THE WORK IN JUST A
QUICK QUESTION.
HOW ARE YOUR STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
SOME?
COMPRISED IN WHICH THE%
GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION AND WHAT
DO YOU DO.
TO GUARANTEE DIVERSITY IN THOSE
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS.
THE FIRST THING WE'VE DONE IS
FORCE OURSELVES TO REALIZE.
THAT OUR CONSTITUENT BASE TODAY
IS DIFFERENT THAN THE ONE WE'VE
HAD HISTORICALLY.
AND TO REALLY FORCE OURSELVES.
TO INVITE A BROADER RANGE OF
PEOPLE.
AND I'M PLEASED WITH HOW WE
APPROACH THAT.
I WOULD ARGUE WERE A STATE
DEPARTMENT THAT PERHAPS HAS THE
MOST ONE OF THE MOST DIVERSE.
CORE CONSTITUENCY BASIS FROM --
YOU KNOW HUNTING AND FISHING
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION FARM BUREAU RULE
COUNTIES.
ALL THE WAY OVER [inaudible]
TO YOU KNOW [inaudible]
VARIOUS SPECIFICS DRIVEN
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
HUMANE SOCIETY ANOTHER'S.
AND WHAT I FOUND MOST PLEASING
IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
IS THE FULL RANGE.
HAS REMAINED IN PRETTY STRONG
CONSENSUS.
THAT THERE IS AN IMPROVEMENT
THAT CAN BE DONE AT THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND SUSTAINABLE FUNDING WILL
LIFT ALL THOSE CONSTITUENT BOOKS.
AND THE OTHER THING THAT I FOUND
MOST SURPRISING IS WELL THIS
STAKEHOLDER BASES STAYED WITH US
FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS OF
DIALOGUE.
I WAS EXPECTING MORE SKEPTICISM
INTERNALLY WITH OUR EMPLOYEES.
AND LIKE CENTER MCGUIRE
MENTIONED A MOMENT AGO.
I ACTUALLY THINK WHAT I HAVE
FOUND IS.
THEY WELCOME SUCH A TOOL AS WELL
HELP THEM NAVIGATE A PRETTY
CONFUSING BUDGET WORLD.
ALRIGHT LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING IN THE NBA CANDIDATES
WANT TO DAZZLE THE COMMITTEE ON
THEIR KNOWLEDGE OF SERVER SPACE --
BUDGETING OR OTHERS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
JENNIFER FEARING ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AN AWESOME
OUTLINED FOUNDATION AS AN
PARTICIPATING AS A STAKEHOLDER
ALL THE WAY BACK TO THE
IMPANELED GROUP IN. TWENTY
ELEVEN AND HAVE BEEN ROBUSTLY
ENGAGED WITH THIS SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING PROCESS IN PART HAVING
WITNESSED FIRST HAND THE THE IT
TO HELP VALUABLE THAT TOOL IS
BEEN FOR STATE PARK SO WE'RE
VERY HAPPY WITH HOW ENTHUSIASTIC
THE DEPARTMENT HAS EMBRACED
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING AND CS
AT A REAL.
INFLECTION POINT FOR THE FUTURE
OF OF CONSERVATION IN CALIFORNIA
LIKE HOW THIS GOES.
REALLY DIDN'T DESK YOU CREATES
UP EITHER OF PATH FORWARD WHERE
WE REALLY KIND OF LIVE UP TO OUR
CONSERVATION EXPECTATIONS OR OR
SORT OF DROWNED IN OUR FAILURE
AT IT SO WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL
AT AT HOW THE DEPARTMENT HAS
ENGAGED THE STAKEHOLDER
COMMUNITY AND AND THAT.
AMOUNT OF EFFORT THEY'RE ADDING
TO THEIR DAILY DAILY WORK TO
TAKE THIS ON SO WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
SUPPORT AND AND HOPE THAT IT IS
IN THE FINAL BUDGET THANK YOU.
TAX.
SIR TURN MEMBERS THE SILENCE AS
WITH THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
DIFFERENT ON AND BE A CANDIDATE
BUT WE DO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AS OUTLINED IN ISSUE
TWENTY FOUR AND WE WOULD HONOR
COMMENTS MADE BY JENNIFER FRANK
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR IS THE COMMITTEE
HELD FEDERAL ON THE ON BEHALF OF
MY MOM DEFENSE FUND THE K.
CALIFORNIA TO FIND SADIE AS WELL
AS AS SOON.
ALL IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE THE WHICH I AM FOR YOU AND
ALIGN OUR OUR COMMENTS WITH
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE THANK YOU.
ONE OF THE MEAT ON A WITHOUT A
BY CALIFORNIA ALSO SUPPORT THIS
SITE LINE ITEM WE HAVE BEEN VERY
PLEASED WITH HOW THE DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN.
ENGAGED IN VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
AND THE WAY THEY THE BEEN
HANDLING THIS SELF THANK YOU.
THEN CONCERT AMOUNT LINE
FOUNDATION AND I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS -- MADE A
GOOD POINT IN TERMS OF NOT JUST
GETTING A SNAPSHOT OUT OF THIS
PROCESS BUT HAVING THE DASHBOARD.
AS A TOOL TO MOVE FORWARD I'M
WE'VE SEEN THAT PRESENTATION WE
DON'T FOM DELIGHT AND THAT'S AN
EXCITING CHALLENGE FOR THE
FUTURE. TO BE ABLE TO TAKE THIS
NOT ONLY FROM TODAY BUT ALSO.
I'M TO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO
USE IT AS A TOOL -- FOR DECADES
TO COME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERS RIKA MUST FOR THE NOT A
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND
IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL.
OTHERS ONE COMMENT ON THIS.
IT WAS CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING IS
THERE A MOTION BY SENATOR --
MINING TO APPROVE THIS REQUEST
TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MONEY.
ALL RIGHT THAT'S FIVE ZERO THAT
MATTERS APPROVED LET'S MOVE --
TO FISHING GAME PRESERVATION
FUND REALIGNMENT.
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY FIVE SO THIS IS A THREE
FOUR PROPOSAL ARE FISHING GAME
PRESERVATION FUND IS ONE OF THE
OLDEST FUNDS IN STATE GOVERNMENT
IT DATES.
TO NINETEEN OH NINE OUR SPRING
FINANCE REQUEST.
SIX INCREASE OF TWO POINT TWO
FOUR EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
THIRTY MATCH OUR REVENUE.
AND THIS ALLOWS OUR PROGRAMS
WERE REVENUES OUTPACING
AUTHORITY TO USE THE ADDITIONAL
REVENUE.
AND CONVERSELY.
WHERE?
WE NEED TO REDUCE OUR AUTHORITY
WHEN REVENUE IS LESS AND KEEP A
BALANCE ACROSS A LOT OF SUB
ACCOUNTS WITHIN THAT FUND.
HELLO YOU HAVE COMMENTS ON EAST
TWENTY NINE COUNTS.
TECHNICAL PROPOSAL NO CONCERNS.
THERE'S A RECOMMENDATION WAS
OPEN UP PUBLIC HEARING OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON THIS
DEDICATED.
GYM WILDLIFE PRESERVATION FUND
REALIGNMENT.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING.
THIS MOTION BY CENTER MONEY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
WHEN [inaudible]
MONEY.
I WILL KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT.
MEMBERS ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY SIX
THAT RODENT OF UNUSUAL SIZE IS
BACK AGAIN BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
PLEASE PROCEED THIS ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX SPRING FINANCE
REQUEST IS GOOD NEWS IN SOME
REGARDS.
THE LAST TIME I WAS HERE YOU
APPROVED -- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL OF ONE POINT NINE TWO
MILLION BUDGET YEAR.
AND ONE POINT SIX TWO MILLION
ONGOING TO DEAL WITH THIS
INVASIVE SPECIES RISK.
SINCE THAT TIME OUR DEPARTMENT
IS CONTINUED ITS FUND RAISING
EFFORTS.
AND WE SECURED A GRANT FROM --
SISTER ENTITY CALLED THE
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
DELTA CONSERVANCY.
IN THE SPRING FINANCE REQUEST IS
TO INCREASE OUR REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY OVER THREE YEARS.
SO THAT WE CAN SPEND THAT GRANT
NINE POINT THREE EIGHT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND BUILD THE CAPACITY FURTHER
TO ACCOMPLISH THE RESULTS
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
RIGHT WAS OPEN UP TO PUBLIC
HEARING THIS IS OUR REQUEST --
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROVE
HIS.
REQUESTED.
AN AFTERNOON READY THOMPSON WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PICKING YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DON'T GIVE IS THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
ALSO URGING SUPPORT.
I CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING.
THERE'S A MOTION BY SENATOR
MINING TO APPROVE THE REQUEST.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CASTING HI
[inaudible]
REQUIRE.
MONNING.
KEEP THOSE MATTERS -- OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS OF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE DONE.
LIST.
GO BACK TO THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AND THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER -- TWENTY TWO GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER Là CAZZIE
I'M THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
HI THIS ITEM REQUEST THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM VARIOUS FUNDS INTO
PERMANENT POSITIONS IN FISCAL
YEAR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND
TWENTY AND ON GOING TO IMPLEMENT
THE COMMISSION'S RECENTLY
ADOPTED ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
POLICY.
IN FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THEN LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR IN COMMISSION CHAIR
GAVIN NEWSOM DIRECTED COMMISSION
STAFF TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A
COMPREHENSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE POLICY.
AND ACT AND PROVIDED FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE DURING FISCAL YEAR
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
TO BE USED FOR POLICY
DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING TRAINING.
LISTENING SESSIONS AND OTHER
COMMUNITY OUTREACH ACTIVITIES.
THE COMMISSION ADOPTED ITS NEW
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE POLICY IN
DECEMBER.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FUNDING
FOR THE POLICY DEVELOPMENT STAGE
HAS BEEN EXHAUSTED AND THE
COMMISSION REQUIRE WEEK REQUIRES
ONGOING DEDICATED STAFF SEEN AND
FUNDING. FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT.
THE COMMISSION'S NEWLY ADOPTED
POLICY DIRECTS THE COMMISSION
AND STAFF TO ACTIVELY CONSIDER
THE IMPACTS OF ITS ACTIVITIES
AND ITS DECISIONS AND PROGRAMS
ON ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES.
WITH REGARDS TO CLIMATE CHANGE
RESILIENCE PUBLIC ACCESS AND
CONSERVATION RENEWABLE ENERGY
DEVELOPMENT SEA LEVEL RISE
WATERFRONT REDEVELOPMENT AND
PUBLIC LAND AND RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT.
THE COMMISSION HAS ALREADY BEGUN
TO INCORPORATE THESE
CONSIDERATIONS INTO ITS DAILY
WORK THE REQUESTED STAFFING
CONTRACT FUNDING WILL PROVIDE
THE FOUNDATION FOR COMPREHENSIVE.
AND SUSTAINABLE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE PROGRAM AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YEAH I SEE
THAT THE ONE OF THE REQUESTER
FOR MEETING SPACES AND WE KNOW.
AS WE SIT HERE ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THERE'S A LOT OF
STATE PROPERTIES WERE WE ALREADY
OWN THE PROPERTY WE ALREADY HAVE
AN AUDITORIUM OUR HAVE A MEETING
ROOM -- THIS IT IS NOT MY A LOT
OF DETAIL HERE CAN YOU.
EXPLAIN WHAT YOU ANTICIPATE
THESE MEETINGS. TO WHERE THEY
THERE ARE GOING TO TAKE PLACE
RIGHT SO SO -- IN THE POLICY
DEVELOPMENT OVER THE YEAR AND A
HALF THAT WE WORKED WITH --
COMMUNITIES -- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- WHEN WE -- CONDUCTED
THE LISTENING SESSIONS A
COMMUNITY OUTREACH -- MEETINGS
WE REALLY TRIED TO IDENTIFY
MEETING LOCATIONS -- AND TIMES --
WITH THAT WERE MOST CONVENIENT
FOR THE COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS USING -- PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION OTHER MEANS OF OF
THE TRANSPORTATION TO GET THEIR
ADDRESS CHILD CARE ISSUES AS
WELL AS AT BE ABLE TO HAVE
MEETINGS -- DURING OFF WORK
HOURS IN THE EVENINGS OR EARLY
MORNINGS AND SO WE WANTED -- TO
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE
TO CAST THE NET WIDE IT WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT CONTRACTING OUT
TO HELP FACILITATE THESE TYPES
OF MEETINGS ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
OF COURSE OUR OUR PROCESS
SIMILAR -- TO AT HOW WE PLAN OUR
COMMISSION MEETINGS --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- WE
ALWAYS LOOK -- FOR STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT -- BUILDINGS THE
LOWEST COST POSSIBLE AND THAT
ALSO PROVIDES -- THE MOST
CONVENIENT AND EASILY ACCESSIBLE
FOR THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO
PARTICIPATE.
AND HELP OUT THE COORDINATION
WITH OTHER STATE AGENCIES WE
HAVE A CLIMATE ACTION TEAM THE
STATE MEETS ALL THE TIME
PUBLIC.
REALLY DOESN'T KNOW THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION FROM THE EP A
FROM THE COASTAL COMMISSION YEAH
THAT DIED OUT WHEN WE MAKE A BIG
DEAL ABOUT IT BUT AS YOU CAN SEE
FROM TODAY'S AGENDA.
BUT A LOT OF DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS ARE ALL HERE UNDER
THE SAME ROOF TALK ABOUT
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT STUFF.
GIVE ME AN IDEA OF SINCE WERE
MOVING IN THIS YOU KNOW
RESILIENCY SEALEVEL RISE
DISCUSSION THAT IS MULTI
DISCIPLINE MULTI AGENCY WHAT YOU
ANTICIPATE RIGHT -- SO WE WORK
VERY CLOSELY -- WITH -- THE
RESOURCE AGENCIES UNDER -- ALL
THE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES CLIMATE
CHANGE AND SEA LEVEL RISE --
ADAPTATION RESILIENCY
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE -- ISSUES
TRIBAL CONSULTATION -- WE WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL COASTAL
COMMISSION BE CDC STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY STATE PARKS THE S.
AT STAFF LEVEL AS WELL AS ALL
THE WAY UP TO THE LEADERSHIP
LEVEL OF OUR AGENCIES. TO TALK
AND DISCUSS COORDINATE
COLLABORATE -- ON ALL OF THESE
ISSUES IN ORDER TO BE ABLE -- TO
SPEAK WITH ONE STATE VOICE AND
MAKE IT AS AS EASY AND
ACCESSIBLE FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS WITHOUT
HAVING TO DEAL WITH THE VARIOUS
AGENCY BUREAUCRACY SO THAT IS --
AT THE TOP OF OUR MIND
ESPECIALLY WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PROGRAM WE
DON'T WANT TO SHOVE IT OFF ON
THE COMMUNITIES -- TO DO THE
WORK OF PARSING OUT WHICH AGENCY
DOES WHAT ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES -- TO COASTAL RESOURCE
AGENCIES -- BUT SO WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY SO THAT WE DO THAT WORK
MORE EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
WITH OUR RESOURCES AND STAFFING.
EXTRA BECAUSE WE'VE GOT A
BOATLOAD OF MONEY IN THE EXCITED
THE AND THE THE CAN.
HAZARDOUS WASTE AND I'M JUST I
AM I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE COORDINATING THESE THINGS
WHEN WE HAVE A MEETING BECAUSE
JUST LIKE.
TYPICAL CITY COUNCIL MEETING
SOME HAVE AN ABUNDANCE OF
ATTENDANCE AND SOMEBODY HAD SOME
OF THEM HAVE NO NO PEOPLE COMING
SO.
THIS IS THAT A CHALLENGE ALL
RIGHT -- MEMBERS OF QUESTIONS
THIS IS A OR ALEJO YOU HAVE A
FILE ON THIS.
THIS IS YOUR IS TO PROVE AS
REQUESTED MAKING SURE THAT WERE
THERE.
US OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
THIS IS THE STATE LANDS.
COMMISSION DJ PROGRAM.
THIS TURNED OUT OF THE ROOM ON
BEHALF OF US SOON I'M JUST
REALLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE THE
WORK AT THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION STAFF HAS DONE IN
DEVELOPING A CEDAR POLICY.
HAVE BEEN AT THE TABLE ALL ALONG
THE WAY APPRECIATE THAT -- THERE
HAS ALSO BEEN A A LETTER
SUBMITTED BY A COALITION WHICH
INCLUDES A A SOON TO THE
COMMITTEE ON DIGITAL BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE HARD COPIES IF NEEDED --
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
REQUEST THANK YOU.
THIS IS THREE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS SCISSOR MOTION
[inaudible]
APPROVED AS THERE'S A MOTION BY
CENTER MONEY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ASKING AYE OWNS [inaudible]
REQUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING.
I THAT VOTES TO ONE WILL KEEP
MATTER OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS LET'S GO.
TO OIL AND GAS DE COMMISSIONING
LITIGATION.
WHEN IN CO L. L. C. N. RENCONTRE
LLC?
YOU KNOW HERE UNFORTUNATE THAT
YOU GOT A CHAIR THAT HAS A
BACKGROUND IN BANKRUPTCY YES SO
MY MY CHALLENGE HERE.
IS THE BANKRUPTCY JUDGE WHEN
WHEN YOU HAVE AN ADVERSARY
PROCEEDING EVERY DEBTOR IN
POSSESSION EVERY DEBTOR THINKS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO SUE
EVERYBODY IN ORDER TO GET SOME
MONEY TO FUND THEIR PLAN.
THAT'S THAT'S JUST GIVEN AND
WHAT THE JUDGE DOES IS THAT SAYS
YOU HAVE O MUCH MONEY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO WASTE MONEY ON ATTORNEY
FEES GOING AFTER LITIGATION WITH
THE PRAYER THAT YOU MAY GET.
SOME RECOVERY.
DO YOU CAN YOU BUT YOU'VE GOT TO
GO WHEN THEY'RE AND JUSTIFY THE
EMPLOYMENT OF PROFESSIONALS TO
GO IN TO GO AFTER ASSETS.
SO I'M CONCERNED HERE THAT WE'RE
ASKING -- FOR ASSISTANCE OF
ASSISTANCE IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
A A PIECE IS WHERE WE AT LEAST
WHEN I FIRST GOT TO BE THE CHAIR
HERE I THOUGHT WELL THESE WERE
ABANDONED WELLS THERE THEY
DIDN'T DO THE CLEAN UP.
THERE'S NO ASSETS THEY'RE
THEY'RE ALL THE WILL OF HIS
BINGE.
I BEEN TRAIN FROM THEM -- SO.
I'M A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED I
GUESS OF COURSE -- AND THAT
YOU'RE CONCERN IS WELL FOUNDED I
AM -- HAPPY TO REPORT TO YOU
THAT -- WERE NOT SEEKING
LITIGATION -- COST SUPPORT -- TO
PURSUED THE STATE -- SHARE IN
THE BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDINGS WE'VE
BEEN DOING THAT FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS -- IN THE VAN
ECHO PLATFORM HOLLY SITUATION --
THE TRUSTEE HAS ACTUALLY FILED
SUIT AGAINST THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION FOR INVERSE
CONDEMNATION OF AN UPSWING
PROCESSING FACILITY THAT THE
STATE -- LANDS COMMISSION IS --
OPERATING AND MAINTAINING FOR
THE PURPOSES OF DECOMMISSIONING
THE THIRTY TWO WELLS OFF SHORE
AND SO THE LITIGATION REQUEST
ASSOCIATED WITH VAN ECHO REALLY
IS -- FOR DEFENSE COSTS AS WE
FIGHT THE TRUSTEE ON THIS
INVERSE CONDEMNATION -- ACTION
WHICH THEY FILED IN BANKRUPTCY
COURT WHICH IS AS YOU KNOW A
LITTLE -- UNUSUAL -- AND
UNPRECEDENTED FROM THE STATE'S
PERSPECTIVE AND SO WE ARE I AM
APPEAL THAT WE HAD AN ADVERSE
REAL RULING IN THE BANKRUPTCY
COURT ON THE INVERSE
CONDEMNATION ACTION WE'VE
APPEALED TO THE U. S. DISTRICT
OF DELAWARE.
WE ARE FIGHTING THAT -- TO WITH
THE GOAL OF REMOVING THAT CASE --
FROM THE UMBRELLA OF BANKRUPTCY
TO STATE COURT IT WOULDN'T GO TO
THE BATTERY WENT DIRECTLY TO THE
DISTRICT BECAUSE NORMALLY GOES
THE BANKRUPTCY APPEAL PANEL THE
BACKUP.
YEAH -- BUT IT JUST WENT
DIRECTLY TO THE DISTRICT COURT
WHICH IT CAN HAPPEN YEAH I THINK
THE THE RULES ARE A LITTLE DE UM
A DIFFERENT IN DELAWARE -- AS
I'M NOT AS FAMILIAR WITH -- THE
SPECIFIC PROCESS SEES -- BUT WE
JUST PARTICIPATED IN -- A
MEDIATION SESSION ON MONDAY IN
DELAWARE -- AS A CASES BEFORE
THE US DISTRICT COURT IS I'M
JUST CONCERNED THAT THE TRUSTEE
REALLY THINKS THAT HE CAN.
WHERE SHE CAN WHOEVER CAN GET
MONEY OUT OF THE?
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S AN ASSET
THAT INVERSE CONDEMNATION CLAIM
THAT ITS MERIT MERIT TESTS.
WHICH IS IT WE COMPLETELY AGREE
WHICH IS WHY WE ARE FIGHTING IT --
TOOTH AND NAIL BECAUSE JUST UP
THE HOW OBNOXIOUS.
REALLY THE POSITION BY THE
TRUSTEE IS HERE SINCE THE STATE
IS.
MONACO'S MASS -- AND WE ALSO
DON'T WANT ANYTHING LIKE THIS TO
SET PRECEDENT.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD ON THE RINCON
ISLAND AND I APOLOGIZE
COLLEAGUES.
THEY FILE TWO DAYS BEFORE THE
LEASE EXPIRED RIGHT TYPICALLY
UNDER THE THE CODE THE DEBTOR
HAS A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS.
TO ASSUME THE LACE THERE'S
NOTHING TO ASSUME HERE THAT'S
WHAT IT TOOK LIKE. FIFTEEN
MONTHS TO FINALLY GET DONE WITH
THAT.
JUST GIVE ME A HIGHLIGHT HOW DID
THAT HAPPEN HOW.
HOW IN THE WORLD THAT THAT
HAPPENED RIGHT RIGHT WELL WE
WERE UNDER AND ADMINISTRATIVE
STAY RIGHT NOW LIKE I GET YET
BUT BUT NORMALLY YOU COULD HAVE
SAID HEY THE DEBTOR DIDN'T
ASSUME THE LEASE THERE'S NOTHING
TO ASSUME?
IT'S REJECTED BY LAW I MEAN I
IMAGINE SOMEBODY DID A MOTION
THIS TO THE COURT TO SAY MAKE IT
KNOWLEDGE IS JUST TAKE JUDICIAL
NOTICE AT THE LEASES EXPIRED.
RIGHT -- SO -- ACTUALLY THE THAT
WAS PART OF THE ARGUMENTS THAT
WE ARE MAKING IN BANKRUPTCY
COURT WE DID HAVE A POSITIVE
RULING -- THAT REALLY FORCED
RINCON R. I. L. P. TO QUIT CLAIM
THE LEASES EVENTUALLY WHAT WE'RE
SEEKING HERE ACTUALLY IS -- TO
BE ABLE TO GO AFTER FORMER
PARTNERS -- THROUGH YOU KNOW TO
ESSENTIALLY BREAK THROUGH THE
CORPORATE STRUCTURE AND GO AFTER
FORMER GENERAL PARTNERS -- AND
THE LARGER CORPORATE STRUCTURE
TO BE ABLE TO RECOUP THE STATE'S
COSTS SO -- SOME OF THE FORMER
GENERAL PARTNERS -- FORM -- AND
OTHER CORPORATE STRUCTURE --
OVER I'LL P. IS RECCA OIL AND
GAS.
WERE SEEKING -- LITIGATION COSTS
SUPPORT TO BE ABLE TO GO AFTER
THOSE FOLKS TO ROOF RECOUP THE
STATE'S COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH.
THE PLUGIN AND ABANDONMENT AT
RINCON ISLAND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LET'S OPEN UP TO PUBLIC HEARING
ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO JUMP IN ON
THE RING CONN ISLAND OR VENN
ECHO L. L. C..
BUT A LOT OF THEM AND AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF US SOON WE SHARE THE
FRUSTRATION OF THE CHAIR AND THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION ON THIS
ITEM.
AND REALLY JUST WANTED TO KIND
OF GET ON MY SOAPBOX OR TO SAY
THAT WE'VE BEEN IN COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION IT'S MOVING IN BOTH
HOUSES -- THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION TO SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE THAT BEGAN LAST YEAR
WHEN THE STATE FOUND ITSELF
HAVING TO FOOT THE BILL OF A
HUNDRED EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
TO INITIATE THE ACTUAL PLUGGING
THE BANNING OF THESE WELLS -- TO
REALLY JUST SAY YOU KNOW.
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY THE
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN IN COMMITTEE
TO OPPOSE THOSE LOOK THOSE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS AND THIS
HERE JUST VERY -- CLEARLY SHOWS.
SHOWS US THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO
ACT.
MORE INTENTIONALLY IN IN
ADDRESSING THIS IS IN THE FUTURE
SO WE CAN BE READILY SUPPORT THE
THE REQUEST BUT ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS IS PRETTY RIDICULOUS.
THE TEN OF HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS A MONTH ALL RIGHT.
LET'S CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING.
THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER
MINING [inaudible]
GOOD LUCK.
PLEASE CALL ROLL.
CASKEY HI OWNS [inaudible]
CHOIR MINING
AT THAT MATTER HAS THREE VOTES
WE GIVE TO MATH KEEP IT OPEN FOR
THE THANK YOU FOR THE UPDATE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION.
LET'S GET THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY SEVEN IT HAD THE BENEFIT
OF MY REMARKS ON MEETING SPACES
COLLABORATION WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES.
LESS WORK TOGETHER.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO BE ABLE -- TO SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE STEP ON THE
COMMISSION'S.
TO SPRING FINANCE LETTER ITEMS
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT FOR
ITEM.
TWENTY SEVEN THE COMMISSION DID
ADOPT OUR ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE
POLICY AS DID OF THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION JUST RECENTLY IN
MARCH OF THIS YEAR.
IN OUR TRIBAL CONSULTATION
POLICY IN AUGUST OF LAST YEAR.
AND THIS FUNDING TO BE REALLY
CRITICAL TO AMPLE MADS OF TO
FULLY IMPLEMENT THESE WROTE
THESE TWO REALLY IMPORTANT --
POLICY DIRECTIVES GOING FORWARD --
TO HELP US GUIDE US IN OUR
PERMIT DECISIONS AND OUR LOCAL
COSTA PROGRAM WORK GOING FORWARD.
SO WE'RE HERE TO HAVE A HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
NOW YOU HEARD YOU HEARD MY
GRAPHITE I JUST DON'T WANT TO
HAVE ONE MEETING WITH THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION ONE MEETING
WITH THE GOALS COMMISSION WOMEN
WITH THE PARKS AND JUST YOU KNOW
JUST LET TO IT ALL TOGETHER.
HI ELLIE -- NO FILE.
I HAVE NO OTHER QUESTIONS THIS
OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS.
STAFF RECOMMENDATION APPROVED AS
REQUESTED.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON THE
CLOSE THE COMMISSION E. J..
OF ALSO -- AGAIN OF BROTHER WILL
NOT BE HAVE A SOON AGAIN BEEN
INTIMATELY ENGAGED TO STAY CLOSE
TO COME COMMISSION ON ON THIS
ISSUE -- AND BEEN REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE STAFF WORK
THAT'S GONE INTO DEVELOPING THE
THE POLICY THAT WAS RECENTLY
ADOPTED -- COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ISRAEL.
I IT TELLS.
THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER
MONICA PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI [inaudible] ONE MONNING.
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN THAT'S
TO THE ONE CALLED AFTER MEMBERS
WHEN THEY ARRIVE ITEM.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT IS
EXTERNAL COUNSEL COSTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THIS FUNDING REQUESTING TO HER
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND -- FUNDS FOR
EXTERNAL COUNSEL COSTS RELATED
SOME LITIGATION OVER THE COSTA
COMMISSIONS PROVISION OF A
DEFENSE FOR THE AND AND
INDEMNIFICATION OF FIVE
COMMISSIONERS.
RELATED TO A UNDERLYING A COURT
DECISION -- RELATED TO SOME EX
PARTE VIOLATIONS THE COMMISSION --
WE'REHAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
THIS MATTER WE CONTINUE WILL
CONTINUE TO OVER THE OVER THE
OVER THE YEAR.
COURSE ANY FUNDING THAT -- OF
THAT IS -- WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
OUR FOR OUR TO THAT WILL KEEP
OUR COSTS TO THE MINIMUM WITH
REGARD TO THIS THIS ISSUE AND
ANY UNUSED FUNDS OF COURSE WILL
BE RETURNED BACK TO THE THE
GENERAL FUND SO WE'RE HAPPY
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
ON ON THE OTHER THAN THE
ADMONISHMENT OF ALL.
MIKE AND COMMISSIONERS PRIOR TO
A MEETING THAT THEY SHOULD
ANNOUNCE IN A TIMELY MATTER AND
THEIR EGGS ANY EX PARTE WAS
THERE I CAN'T REMEMBER BECAUSE
WE'VE HAD THIS A COUPLE TIMES.
IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL --
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT OR
TRAINING THAT.
THAT YOU'RE NOW GIVING AS A
ROUTINE BASIS TO THE
COMMISSIONERS ON THIS ERA.
ABSOLUTELY -- EVEN BEFORE THE
BALL OF THE LAWSUIT WAS FILED WE
UPDATE OUR PROCEDURES AND OUR
GUIDE TO THE COMMISSION WITH
REGARD TO EX PARTE
COMMUNICATIONS.
JUST LAST MONTH WE HAD A
REMINDER TO OUR COMMISSIONERS
AND PASSED OUT THAT -- THAT --
THAT GUIDE AND SHE TO OUR
COMMISSION WITH REGARD TO EX
PARTE SUI ARE ALSO I PERSONALLY
DEEP WITH EACH NEW COMMISSIONER
AS WELL AS MY CHIEF COUNSEL.
AND WE GO OVER THOSE EX PARTE --
RULES AND REGULATIONS.
AND HIGHLIGHT THIS LITIGATION TO
MAKE SURE THEY UNDERSTAND THE
GRAVITY OF THE OF COMPLIANCE
WITH THE EX PARTE RULES.
HAND IN AUGUST OF THIS YEAR WE
WILL BE HAVING A WORKSHOP
TRAINING IN OPEN SESSION.
ON THIS VERY MATTER LED BY OUR
LEGAL STAFF AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
YOU HAD TO STICK. TO HIGHLIGHT
YOUR STAFF COMMENT THAT THAT
QUESTION BEFORE YOU IS TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND BUT DOLLARS BUT
THERE WAS THAT LETTER PROCESS
THROUGH THE JAIL B. C. FOR A
CURRENT YEAR AUGMENTATION.
OF ONE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
SO THAT THE ISSUE IS IS THAT
LARGER THAN WHAT'S BEFORE YOU
NOW JUST FOR CONTEXT
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY EIGHT LET'S HAVE A PUBLIC
HEARING IS THERE ANYBODY HERE IN
THE PUBLIC THAT.
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT EX PARTE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING.
THIS IS A REQUESTED FOR THE
AUGMENTATION -- THE THE PREVIOUS
LETTER OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS LIMITED EMOTION.
IS A RECOMMENDATION.
MOVE FIVE CENTER MINING PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
SB HI AND WHERE [inaudible]
MINING.
RIGHT THAT MATTERS ALPHA ON A
VOTE OF FOUR TO ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- LET'S GO BACK AND
CALL THE ROLL FOR THE MATH THE
MEMBERS WHO.
MISSED THE PORTION.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE
DJ PROGRAM FOR THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
DEVELOPING TWO ONE THE CHAIR IN
FAVOR [inaudible] TWENTY TWO
THANK YOU.
THAT MATTERS APPROVED FOR ONE
CLOSE TO ROLL ITEM NUMBER OR
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THREE THIS
IS OIL AND GAS DE COMMISSIONING
LITIGATION COSTS.
THE THE VOTE IS THREE ZERO THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
REQUIRE I I MATTERS OUT AN A
FIVE OH VOTE.
HI ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE THIS IS THE DEDICATED
FISHING GAME PRESERVATION FUND
REALIGNMENT.
THE VOTE COUNT IS FOUR ZERO VICE
CHAIR AND CHAIR VOTING I PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CLOSE THE ROLE THAT MATTERS OUT --
FIVE ZERO THE THAT PASSED OF
UNUSUAL SIZE THIS IS NUTRIA
REVOCATION CONTROL PROGRAM.
THE VOTE IS THREE ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING.
IN FAVOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
PLAN.
LOS ROLE THAT'S FIVE ZERO AND
FINALLY THE PGA PROGRAM FOR THE
COASTAL COMMISSION.
THE VOTE BEING TO THE ONE CHAIR
VTING I'D BUY SHARE VOTING NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WIRE.
RIGHT THAT CLOSER ROLE THAT'S
MATTERS FOR ONE IT'S APPROVED
ALRIGHT THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY NINE THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY.
THIS IS TWO MILLION FOR THE
APPROPRIATION FROM A VIOLATION
REMEDIATION ACCOUNT FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE [inaudible]
THIS IS.
THE IRA BUTTONS PLEASE FOR SEE
AN AFTERNOON I MERRY SMALLER
DEBBIE DIRECTOR OF THE STATE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY.
THIS IS A REQUEST FOR AN
APPROPRIATION OF TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE VIOLATION
REMEDIATION ACCOUNT.
THESE FUNDS ARE GENERATED WHEN
THE COASTAL COMMISSION --
SETTLES COASTAL ACT VIOLATION
CASES AND THE COASTAL
CONSRVANCY USES THE FUNDS IN
CLOSE COORDINATION WITH THE
COMMISSION ON PROJECTS.
HOPEFULLY AS CLOSE AS POSSIBLE
TO WHERE THE VIOLATION OCCURRED
AND FOR PROJECTS THAT REMEDY
THAT THE IMPACT OF THE FILE --
OF A SIMILAR NATURE SO IF IT WAS
A COASTAL ACCESS VIOLATION WE
TRY AND USE THE FUNDS FOR
COASTAL ACCESS ENHANCEMENT.
QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS.
ELIZABETH THE PUBLIC HEARING
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY NINE CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING THIS MOTION BY CENTER
MONEY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
NOW SCHEME BY [inaudible]
REQUIRE [inaudible]
MONEY.
IT WAS CLOSE ROLE THAT MATTERS
IMPROVE FOUR ZERO HI ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTY THIS IS THE PROP.
SIX SIXTY EIGHT LOWER COST
COASTAL ACCOMMODATION PROGRAM
AND I AM RECEIVING AND EXPLORE
THE COAST OVERNIGHT.
BROCHURE AT THIS VERY MOMENT AT
THIS VERY MOMENT [inaudible]
DIRECTOR SMALL.
HI SO AB TWO FIFTY OUT WHICH WAS
PASSED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
CREATED AT LOWER COST OVERNIGHT
COASTAL ACCOMMODATIONS PROGRAM
AT THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY.
THE FIRST THING WE WERE DIRECTED
TO DO WAS TO COMPLETE A
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT -- OF BOTH
THE NEEDS AND OPPORTUNITIES.
AND THIS IS A HIGH LEVEL
BROCHURE THERE'S A MORE DETAILED
ASSESSMENT AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE.
I HAD THE REQUEST IS AN
APPROPRIATION OF PROP SIXTY
EIGHT FUNDS THAT ARE SPECIFIC
FOR LOWER COST OVERNIGHT COASTAL
ACCOMMODATIONS.
US SO THAT WE CAN START TO
IMPLEMENT THAT THE PROJECTS IN
THAT ASSESSMENT.
AT THE REQUEST IS HOLD OPEN
ALLEY -- NO FILE -- QUESTIONS.
WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT THIS --
LOOKS.
WE'LL HAVE THE PUBLIC HEARING
LATER CENSUS WERE HOLDING IS
OPEN THIS IS PROP SIXTY EIGHT OF
FUNDS FOR THE WEST COYOTE HILLS
CONSERVANCY PROGRAM.
HI ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTY ONE RIGHT THIS IS A
REQUEST FOR AN APPROPRIATION OF
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FROM PROP
SIXTY EIGHT FOR THE THE WEST
COMMITTEE HILLS.
THIS IS CRITICAL OPEN SPACE IN A
HEAVILY DEVELOPED AREA AROUND
THE CITY OF FULLER TEN IT ALSO
PROVIDES CRITICAL HABITAT.
AND AND WE'RE REQUESTING THAT
THOSE PROP SIXTY EIGHT FUNDS BE
APPROPRIATED.
AND STAFF REPORT INDICATES THAT
THE CITY FOR TEN AS REACH SAID.
AN AGREEMENT ON THE OF THE
PURCHASE TO SOME OF THE PROPERTY.
I GOT THAT RIGHT YEAH THAT'S
CORRECT WERE WAITING FOR UPDATED
APPRAISALS -- BUT WE ARE
OPTIMISTIC THAT THE PROJECT IS
READY TO MOVE FORWARD.
EXPAND THAT ROBERT E. WARD
NATURE PRESERVES ELLIE OKAY YOU
HAVE A COMMENT IS SICK IN SOME
CONTEXT THIS PIECE OF PROP SIXTY
EIGHT WAS SET ASIDE IN THE BOND
SPECIFICALLY FOR THIS PROJECT SO
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH FUNDING.
OKAY THE REQUEST IS THE HOLD
OPEN.
BEING THE QUESTIONS THIS MOVE ON
THE ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY TWO THIS
IS THE STATE OPERATION FUNDS.
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND REQUEST IN
A HUNDRED IN A MILLION POINT
ZERO NINE NINE THE WATER QUALITY
SUPPLYING INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENT FUND OF TWENTY
FOURTEEN ALSO KNOWN AS PROP.
ONE THANK YOU YESTHIS IS A
REQUEST TO SHIFT THAT FINDS
WITHIN THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY
SUPPORT BUDGET -- AS YOU NOTED
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE
PLATE AND A MILLION DOLLARS FROM
PROP.
ONE THIS IS -- FOR VERY SMALL
AGENCY THE COSTA CONSERVANCY HAS
A FAIRLY COMPLICATED SUPPORT
BUDGET -- AND THIS IS PART OF A
LONGER TERM EFFORT WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY. TO
STABILIZE OUR FUNDING A LITTLE
BIT TO REDUCE OUR RELIANCE ON
THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FROM
BOND FUNDS BECAUSE THOSE FUNDS
ARE BOTH LIMITED AND RESTRICTED
IN WHAT WE CAN CAN DO WITH THAT
SO THIS PROVIDE SOME GENERAL
OPERATING.
FUNDING TO THE LPF AND THEN THE
PROP ONE FUNDING I REFLECTS THE
CURRENT WORKLOAD WHERE WE'RE
CURRENTLY MANAGING ABOUT.
NINETY PROP ONE PROJECTS AND WE
JUST CLOSE THE GRANT ROUND
YESTERDAY OR MONDAY SO WE WILL
BE TAKING MORE PROP ONE PROJECTS
FORWARD.
WHO WOULD'VE THOUGHT DELL'S
BLACK AND YELLOW LICENSE PLACE?
BACK IN THE DAY.
COME SAVE YOU NOW -- MEMBERS
QUESTIONS UNDER STERN.
I JUST WANTED.
POINT OUT THOUGH IT IS STAFF NOW
SAYS NOTES IS ENTIRELY SAFE.
WE STILL THE STRENGTH THAT.
SO I JUST WANT TO GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE THE GOVERNOR VETOED.
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR THAT WOULD
HAVE OFFERED YOU ALL A NEW
LICENSE PLATE THAT WE THOUGHT
WAS GOING TO HAVE.
BIG CULTURAL APPEAL AND REALLY
SELL -- IS CONCERNED ABOUT DIEM
BE I GUESS HAVING TOO MUCH ON
THEIR PLATE.
BUT I WANT TO GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON OTHER WAYS TO GET
CREATIVE IS THE CONCERN HERE IS.
I I I LIKE THEY WERE GONNA FIND
YOUR OPERATIONS AND AND GET THAT
GOING BUT FUNDS ALREADY DEPLETED
RIGHT AND OVER NINE MILLION
DOLLAR A YEAR DEFICIT.
WHAT WHAT DO WE DO?
TO THE FED UP AGAIN I JUST AS A
TEASER IS BRINGING THE BILL BACK --
BUT BUT AT THAT I'M NOT SAYING
THAT'S THE FIFTH OF THE TOTAL
FIX SO.
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW THAT I
HAVE A TOTAL ANSWER I THINK THE
THE STRATEGY AT THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY HAS BEEN -- TO TO
DIVERSIFY THE FUNDS THAT ARE
SUPPORTING SO THAT WE'RE TAKING
ADMINISTRATIVE -- LITTLE
ADMINISTRATIVE PERCENTAGES OFF
OF ALL OF THE FUNDS THAT WE
ADMINISTER WE'VE ALSO BEEN.
I AM VERY SUCCESSFUL IN THE PAST
IN GETTING GRANTS -- FOR OUR
PROJECTS AND AND INCREASING THE
AMOUNT THAT WE WERE COVERED LIKE
THROUGH OUR FEDERAL INDIRECT
COST RATE.
UNFORTUNATELY FEDERAL FUNDS ARE
A LITTLE BIT SHAKY YEAR -- THAN
THEY WERE IN THE PAST I THINK
YOU KNOW IN THE LONG RUN I'M WE
ARE VERY INTERESTED IN HAVING
STABLE FUNDING.
I'M WE DON'T THINK THAT THE BOND
FUND SHOULD BE FUNDING OUR OUR
STATE OPERATIONS -- SO ANY
SOLUTION WERE WERE VERY HAPPY TO
WORK WITH.
ANYBODY ON AND I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT LATER ON I THINK WE'RE
GONNA HEAR.
AMONG THE REQUEST A NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD.
INCLUDE THE CONSERVANCY FOR A G.
G. R. F..
REQUEST WHICH I THINK THERE'S A
CASE TO BE MADE FOR ONGOING
FUNDING TO RESILIENCY EFFORTS
WRIT LARGE BUT FOR A FUTURE DATE
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER -- THIRTY
TWO OR THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY I
SEE -- IT'S CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING --
THIS IS A APPROVED AS REQUESTED --
MATTER.
THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER
MINING PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I CASTING I WHEN [inaudible]
MONNING.
IT'S CLOSE ROLE.
KELLY THE VOTE FOUR ZERO THE
MATTERS OUT SO NOW LET'S OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING ON ISSUES
NUMBER THIRTY AND THIRTY ONE
THIS IS THE PROP SIXTY EIGHT THE
WEST COYOTE HILLS CONSERVANCY
AND THE LOWER COST COASTAL
ACCOMMODATION THE THEY OVERNIGHT
[inaudible]
EXPENDITURES PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN OFFER THAT
WILL NOT BE HALF OF LATINO
ADORES ESALEN AUDIBLE ON
CALIFORNIA.
OR ACTUALLY AUTOMATES VICTIMS
SELVES -- AGAIN LOTS OF EFFORT
HAS GONE INTO THE FINAL
ASSESSMENT THAT WAS OUR PARTNER
AB TWO FIFTY FOR THE LOWER COST
OVERNIGHT ACCOMMODATIONS PROGRAM --
WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMB MOVE THIS
FORWARD UNDER THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND HOPE THAT WE GET THE
APPROPRIATION TO THE FINISH LINE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON RECALL MUST FOR
THE NOT A WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND -- AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE LOW COST
ACCOMMODATIONS ON THE COAST
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON AND FOR FOR A LONG
TIME LONG OVERDUE.
EXTREMELY NEEDED ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THE WEST KILEY A COYOTE HILLS --
A BUDGET PROPOSAL THIS IS
SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE WORKED ON
A COUPLE YEARS AGO FOUGHT HARD
TO GET IN PROP SIXTY EIGHT AND
AS THE DEPARTMENT.
OR THE CONSERVANCY MENTIONED.
THIS IS A VERY HEAVILY POPULATED
AREA THE TOM THIS COULD OFF
CREATE A LOT OF RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE OF THE MEAT ON A
WITHOUT A ONE CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE LOWER COST
COMMENDATION ISSUE.
WELL AS THE WEST PEORIA HILLS
ISSUE.
HE THAT AREA IS VERY SENSITIVE --
TO ENDANGERED SPECIES OF BIRDS
SO WE ARE INCREDIBLY SUPPORTIVE
OF MAKING SURE THAT THIS THING
BECAUSE FOR THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT LET'S CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING -- EVERY SMALL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND WE
WILL.
KEEP THOSE MATTERS OPEN LET'S GO
TO PARKS AND RECREATION THIS IS
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY THREE THIS
IS A COMMUNITY.
ENGAGEMENT HIGHLIGHTS
[inaudible] FOR FIVE HUNDRED
NINETEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS LIZ MCGURK I'M THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION.
AND THE DEPARTMENT'S REQUEST IS
FOR TO YOUR FUNDING FROM THE
STATE PARKS PROTECTION FUND AND
FOR POSITIONS FOR THE
CONTINUATION OF TO COMMUNITY
pPROJECTS.
THE FIRST IS OUR COMMUNITY OUT
REACH PILOT PROGRAM WHICH IS AN
INNOVATIVE APPROACH TO ENGAGING
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES FROM TWO
OF THE STATE'S LARGEST URBAN
AREAS THE BAY AREA AND LOS
ANGELES.
THIS PILOT PROJECT HAS
ESTABLISHED COMMUNITY LIAISONS
WHO WORK WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND NONPROFIT
GROUPS TO CONDUCT OUTREACH AND
ENGAGE WITH THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO CREATE PARK
PROGRAMMING THAT INCORPORATES
BUT THE ASSETS.
AND TO THE EXPERIENCES OF THESE
COMMUNITIES.
HOW THE HISTORY AND RELEVANCY
PILOT PROGRAM IS AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO IMPROVING AT PUBLIC
INTERPRETATION?
A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT TO
STATE HISTORIC PARKS EL PRESIDIO
DAY SANTA BARBARA.
AND THE CAL CITRUS STATE
HISTORIC PARK.
AND THIS PILOT PROGRAM ADDRESSES
AN INCREASING RECOGNITION OF THE
NEED FOR IMPROVED INTERPRETATION
PROGRAMMING THAT REPRESENTS THE
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AND CULTURES
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE GOAL IS TO CREATE CULTURALLY
RELEVANT AND INCLUSIVE
INTERPRETIVE PROGRAMMING AND IN
DOING SO PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CIVIC DIALOGUE
AND ENGAGEMENT WITHIN THE STATE
PARK SYSTEM.
SO THESE TWO COMPLEMENTARY
PROJECTS ARE KEY INITIATIVES IN
THE DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TO MAKE
PARK SERVICES MORE RELEVANT TO A
CONSTITUENCY THAT'S REFLECTIVE
OF CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSITY.
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE THANK YOU DEBBIE MCCOURT.
FILE ALEJO NO.
I'M QUESTIONS MEMBERS I'M HOPING
THAT WHEN YOU'RE AT CANDLESTICK
STATE PARK THAT THAT'S THE
MORNING MEANING VERSES AN
AFTERNOON MEETING.
THIS IS MY EXPERIENCE IF YOU'RE
NOT A WIND SURFER THAT'S A TOUGH
PARK.
AND AFTER THREE O'CLOCK I'D
LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC EARING
THIS IS A FIVE HUNDRED NINETEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
AND THIS CREATING GAUGE A PILOT
PROGRAM.
MORNING IN FEDERAL ON THE ON
BEHALF LETTING ALL DOORS THINK
MIGHT BE BREAKING A RECORD --
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT OF THIS AGAIN
I'M SEEING THE THE OUTCOMES THAT
ALLEY STATUS BURKE PARKER
PARTICULAR WITH THE FROM A
THOUGHT EXPROPRIATION HAS BEEN
HAS BEEN VERY PROMISING AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
EXPANSION OF THESE PROGRAMS.
OF THE STATE AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANKS.
HELLO AGAIN RECALL MáS FOR THE
NOT A WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LAND IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
THANKS.
READ OUT ASSEMBLY AFTER
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION CAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION -- CENTER
STERN QUESTION [inaudible]
QUESTION -- IMPORTANT PROGRAM
I'M JUST WONDERING NOTED THE
EFFORTS IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA -- BEEN LIMITED.
TO LA STATE HISTORIC PARK.
ANY PLANS TO EXPAND ON THAT I
KNOW STATE PARKS TO GET HUGE HIT
IN THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
DURING THE FIRES AND ALL THE ALL
THE CANCER SHUT DOWN WE WERE
SERVING. TWENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS YEAR IN THOSE MOUNTAINS
AND THEY'RE ALL GOING.
TO LOSE THAT CHANCE TO GET OUT
OF THE CONCRETE INTO THE PARK
SYSTEM SUGGEST ANY THOUGHTS ON
HOW.
TO DO WITH THAT GAP WE GOT NOW
POST FIRE WITH THIS YES THANK
YOU SENATOR YEAH SO WE HAVE
EVERY INTENTION OF WANTING TO
EXPAND THESE PROGRAMS TO MORE
PARKS WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO WE
ARE CURRENTLY EVALUATING THE
PILOTS THAT ARE AT LEAST IS.
PARK IN THE OTHER AREAS AND THEN
WE WOULD -- THROUGH THOSE
EVALUATIONS DETERMINE YOU KNOW
THE BEST NEXT STEPS AND
EXPANDING WHERE TO EXPAND WHAT
OUR LESSONS LEARNED FROM EACH
THAT WE CAN MAKE IT BETTER EVERY
TIME SO WE DO HAVE INTENTIONS OF
EXPANDING.
AND WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING THAT
EVALUATION NOW.
YES WILL TAKE A MOTION BY
SENATOR STERN THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTY THREE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
SB HI IN THE CHOIR.
MONEY.
IT'S CLOSE TO ROME TELLY DID
VOTE FOUR ZERO IT'S APPROVED.
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO DATA
TICKETS ONE SHIFT IN ISSUE
NUMBER.
THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF THE DEPARTMENTS
REQUESTING THREE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE STATE PARKS AND
RECREATION FUND TO PAY VENDOR
PROCESSING FEES AND OTHER FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH PARKING CITATION
DEBT COLLECTION SERVICES.
THIS IS NOT A NEW ACTIVITY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT AND THIS PROPOSAL
DOESN'T REPRESENT ANY CHANGE TO
POLICIES OR PRACTICES OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
HOWEVER A RECENT CHANGE IN OUR
VENDORS HAS AFFORDED US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MODERNIZE THE WAY
IN WHICH WE COLLECT OUTSTANDING
CITATIONS.
SO THIS PROPOSAL WILL RESULT IN
A NET INCREASE TO STATE PARKS
REVENUES WHICH WOULD OFFSET ANY
INCREASES TO THE EXPENDITURES.
I'M IN PRIOR YEARS PAYMENTS TO
THE VENDOR HAVE BEEN HANDLED
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT'S
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY THIS
PROPOSAL SEEKS TO MAKE THOSE
PAYMENTS THROUGH OUR NORMAL
SUPPORT APPROPRIATION WHICH IS
MORE IN LINE WITH -- APPROPRIATE
STATE BUDGETING PRACTICE
PRACTICES SO I WILL I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS HOW DOES THAT
TICKET AFFECT THE PARK
EXPERIENCE NOT JUST.
HELP MYSELF THERE -- LET'S OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC HEARING OTHER.
TICKET INTO CS THAT ARE HERE ON
RAISING MORE REVENUE AT THE PARK
SYSTEM.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING.
MOTION BY -- SENATOR MINING WILL
NOTE THAT THIS IS NOT A POLICY
CHANGE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
REQUIRE MORNING.
I CLOSE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE.
FOUR ZERO SEVEN THIS CALL OF THE
SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
REGIONAL FORCE THE FIRE CAPACITY
PROGRAM.
GRANT.
I AM BRING CASH WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY REPRESENTING
THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY TODAY.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IS FOR A
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE IN REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY.TO RECEIVE A GRANT
FROM THE REGIONAL FOREST AND
FIRE CPACITY BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM.
AND THAT PROGRAM IS FUNDED OUT
OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
AND ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION THEIR
DIVISION OF LAND RESOURCES
PROTECTION.
AND WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE AN
EXCELLENT ALIONA COMMENTS
[inaudible]
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
LET'S OPEN PUBLIC HEARING OTHER
MEMBERS.
HERE ON ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
THIS REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING MOTION BY
SENDER.
STERN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI [inaudible]
WIRE [inaudible]
MONEY.
CLOSE THE ROLE TELL YOU VOTE THE
I SEVEN FOUR ZERO MATTERS TO
PROVE THANK YOU.
THANK APRIL ON LOWER LOS ANGELES
RIVER AND MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THE BIG TIME [inaudible]
THIS IS.
THIS IS CENTER LARA'S.
SB.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR MY NAME IS
SELLING GARCIA I'M THE MANAGER
WITH THE RIVERS AMOUNTS
CONSERVANCY.
I'M HERE ASKING OF REQUEST
AUTHORITY FOR ONE ADDITIONAL
POSITION FOR THE NEXT THREE
YEARS. FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE LOWER LA RIVER RECREATION
PARK DISTRICT AS AUTHORIZED BY
SB.
THIRTY THIRTY FOUR IN SHORT SB
THIRTY THREE FOUR WAS AUTHORIZED
TO FOR THE FORMATION OF THE
DISTRICT.
INCLUDING THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
THIRTEEN MEMBER BOARD BOARD OF
DIRECTORS TO REPRESENT THE
SIXTEEN CITIES ALONG THE LOWER
LA RIVER WHICH INCLUDES THE
CITIES OF VERNON.
BELL CUT HAY AND SOUTH GATE.
THE TASK FOR THE DISTRICT
INCLUDES THE ACQUISITION
CONSTRUCTION IMPROVEMENT.
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS OF
THESE PARTS ALONG THE LOWER LA
RIVER.
THE ARMED SEE OVER THE
CONSERVANCY WHAT'S CALLED OUT IN
THE LEGISLATION OUR PRIMARY DUE
TO OUR SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE REVISED NATION PLAN IN AB
FIVE THIRTY AND THE WORKING
GROUP.
SO THIS POSITION WILL BE WORKING
WITH THIS WORKING GROUP AS WELL
AS THE CITIES LOCATED ALONG THE
LOWER LA RIVER.
HELLO THIS IS JUST A POSITION
AUTHORITY THAT THE MONEY'S
ALREADY CAME OUT OF CLASS BUT
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET RIGHT THIS IS
JUST THE POSITION OF THIRTY IN
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THAT
POSITION WOULD BE ABOLISHED
AFTER THREE YEARS THAT IT'S JUST
TO HELP WITH.
THE FORMATION AND ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE DISTRICT. TO OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER.
THIRTY SIX A NEW POSITION OR THE
LOWER.
LOS ANGELES RIVER CONSERVANCY
SAN GABRIEL CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING.
MOTION BY SENATOR MCGUIRE LIST
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB HI IN THE CHOIR [inaudible]
MONNING.
MATTER OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS -- CAN.
MOVE CALLED THE AIRPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THIS IS.
A MILLION DOLLARS ON EDUCATION
COSTS.
DEFENDING OUR CIVIL.
LITIGATION PLEASE PROCEED
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN OFWHITE
HOUSE E. S..
AND I SENATOR MONNING AND
MEMBERS OF THE CHANGE I'M A
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
AND I'M HERE TO SAY TALK OUR
REQUEST I'M THIS INCREASED
AUTHORITY WOULD ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE ACCESS TO SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO PURSUE ADDITIONAL
LITIGATION.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE A DIRECT
STRONG COUNT WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE OF THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
THE AG'S OFFICE CHARGES IS BASED
ON THE HOURS THEY DEVOTE TO OUR
CASES SO IT WE DON'T USE ALL THE
FUNDS EVERY YEAR IT DEPENDS ON
HOW COMPLEX OUR CASES ARE
WHETHER THEY GO.
TO EXPERT WITNESSES YOU NEED
TRAVEL THINGS LIKE THAT.
WE'RE ASKING UP OR IF FORTY A
MILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE WE HAVE
BUMPED UP AGAINST THAT'LL THAT
THREE POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
LIMIT IN PAST YEARS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE COMPLEX
CASES OR MULTIPLE COMPLEX CASES
AND WE ANTICIPATE INCREASED
COSTS IN THE COMING YEARS FOR
TWO MAJOR REASONS.
FIRST I'M FOR THE VOLKSWAGEN AND
FIAT CHRYSLER CASES WE WERE
FORTUNATE THAT THE AG'S OFFICE
REPRESENTED US THROUGH THE
CONSUMER LAW SECTION BECAUSE
THERE WERE CONSUMER CLAIMS.
AND WHAT THAT MEANT IS THEY
DIDN'T CHARGE US THEIR COSTS.
SO FOR THOSE TWO CASES WE
ACTUALLY -- WE'RE IN PRETTY GOOD
SHAPE FROM A FINANCIAL
STANDPOINT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE.
I'M THEY ARE NOT I'M CHIMING IN
FROM THE CONSUMER LAW SECTION OR
IN OUR REMAINING CASES WE ARE
CONTINUING TO INVESTIGATE.
ADDITIONAL EMISSION VIOLATIONS
AND BECAUSE THE NATURAL
RESOURCES SECTION IS
REPRESENTING US IN THOSE CASES --
THEY WE ARE BEING CHARGED FOR
THEIR WORK NOW.
THE SECOND MAJOR REASON AS THIS
COMMITTEE KNOWS WE'RE ENGAGED IN
A FIGHT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
OVER THE RIGHT OF CALIFORNIA TO
SET OUR OWN EMISSIONS STANDARDS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS TRYING
TO ROLL BACK OUR VEHICLE
STANDARDS MAKING IT HARDER IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO MEET
OUR AIR QUALITY AND CLIMATE
GOALS.
WE'VE ALREADY FILED A FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT LAWSUIT SEEKING
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
TECHNICAL BASIS BEHIND TO THEIR
PROPOSALS.
AND IF AS WE EXPECT EPA
FINALIZES A RULE TO WITHDRAW OUR
WAIVER AND TAKE AWAY OUR
AUTHORITY TO SET VEHICLE
STANDARDS.
YOU CAN THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
SELLING OVER THAT ONE THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE FIGHTING TO ENSURE THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE HELPFUL AIR TO
CALIFORNIANS.
NOW THEY MENTIONED AT THE
BEGINNING OF OUR OF MY REMARKS
IF WE'RE LUCKY AND OUR
LITIGATION COSTS ARE LOW.
WE WILL NOT BE EXPENDING THESE
FUNDS BUT IF WE NEED TO LITIGATE
TO PROTECT OUR AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS WE ABSOLUTELY WANT TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
WELL THE AP CHANGE YOU FEEL
LUCKY NOW IT'S JUST -- SO IN THE
STAFF REPORT NOTES IT WAS SIX
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR ON THIS
MULTIPLE COMPLEX LITIGATION
THIRTEEN YEARS AGO.
WHAT MAKES YOU THINK YOU GET TO
GET IT DONE WITH UNDER FIVE I
MEAN I?
AND THE FIVE MINUTES WE GET IN
THE BARGAIN FROM.
GENERAL STATE IT DEPENDS IT
DEPENDS ON WHAT'S HAPPENING SO
WE DID HAVE A CASE YOU KNOW
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO WHEN WE WERE
IN BROILED IN THE FIRST SET A
VEHICLE OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION STANDARDS.
THAT WE HAD VERY VERY HIGH COSTS
AND THAT TRIAL HAPPENS ON THE
EAST COAST THERE WERE A LOT OF
EXPERTS THAT WE HAD TO HIRE FOR
THAT.
SINCE THEN OUR COSTS HAVE BEEN
EITHER BELOW ARE THREE POINT.
FOUR MILLION PER YEAR OR SORT OF
RIGHT AROUND IT WE HAVE GONE
ABOVE IT A YEAR OR TWO I'M IN
THIS CASE AS I SAID WE SEE THESE
THINGS COMING AT US WE THINK A
MILLION.
IN ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY WILL
COVER US ON I'M GONNA STOP RIGHT
THERE I WAS GONNA SAY SOME IS
LIKE ALL STOP [inaudible]
THANKS.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE ACTUALLY
SUGGESTED STAFF SUGGEST THAT WE
APPROVE IS REQUESTED GOOD LUCK
ON KEEPING THOSE COSTS LOW I'M
LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING.
ANYBODY WANT TO COMMENT ON ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN ON
LITIGATION COSTS AGAINST THE
AUTOMOBILE INDUSTRY BY.
THE AIRPORT.
THERE'S RECOMMENDATION
MOTIONLESS CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB I FOUND MCGUIRE MINING.
THE MATTER HAS TWO VOTES WILL
KEEP IT OPEN FOR THE EXPECTED
RETURN OF THE ABSENT MEMBERS --
LET'S CALL AND THANK YOU LET'S
CALL UP TO THE TSC THIS IS PART
OF TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL.
THIS IS THE ARGONAUT DAM FEES TO
STORM WATER UP GREAT PROJECT
[inaudible]
IN WELCOME [inaudible]
DEPUTY COPE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN
WHAT CASKEY -- THIS IS ACTUALLY
RIGHT NOW ARE THEY A BRANCH
MANAGER FOR THE CLINTON PROGRAM.
HE IS HE IS HERE TODAY TO
REQUEST AN FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND GENERAL FUND MONIES
FOR FY TWENTY NINETEEN THREE
DESIGN ONE SECTION OF THE CITY
OF JACKSON STORM WATER SYSTEM.
THE COULD BE IMPACTED BY A DAM
THEY ARE NOT MINE.
THE DAMAGE PER SHOT ABOUT
DOWNTOWN JACKSON IS OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS OLD.
A FEDERAL ASSESSMENT OF THE DAM
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN FOUND THAT IT
WAS UNSTABLE.
AND THAT YEAH A COMPLETE DAM
FAILURE HAPPENED.
DOWNTOWN JACKSON COULD BE IN A
DAY BY -- MIGHTILY.
ALL THAT SOLD RIGHT NOW
EVIDENTLY HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND CUBIC YARDS OF TALES
TAILINGS THAT'S RIGHT YOU CAN
SEE IS AS AS DESIGNED
RETROFITTING COMPLETED
CONSTRUCTION OF THE RETROFIT IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE ISSUE NOW IS
THAT THE DAM STORM WATER SYSTEM.
IT'S DIRECTLY INTO THE CITY'S
STORMWATER SYSTEM RIGHT.
BUT THE DAM STORMWATER SYSTEM
CAN HANDLE ABOUT THREE TIMES
MORE WATER.
THE REQUESTED FUNDS ALLOW DTS HE
TO REDESIGN JUST THAT ONE
SECTION OF THE CITY STORMWATER
SYSTEM TO INCREASE THE CAPACITY.
ONCE THAT REDESIGNED IS DONE
WE'LL COME BATTERY MONEY TO
IMPLEMENT [inaudible]
HELLO.
IN RAISE ANY ISSUES.
I'M TRYING TO DO MY BEST TO
UNDERSTAND HOW IT WOULD HOW THAT
THE TAILINGS IN THE DAMS AND AND
THE STORM WATER SYSTEM WILL WORK.
I'M [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S HAVE A PUBLIC HEARING
ANYBODY WANT TO PRESENT OR
COMMENT.
ON THE ARONAUT DAM PHASE TWO
STORM WATER [inaudible]
IMPROVEMENT UPGRADE.
RIGHT STAFF RECOMMENDS IT WE
GIVE YOU THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER
MINING PLEASE CALL ROLE.
SB HI [inaudible]
WIRE MONEY.
THE MATTER HAS TWO VOTES WILL
KEEP.
IT OPEN FOR THE ROLES OF
REFERRED THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
IT'S CALLED THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE THIS IS THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
REAPPROPRIATON ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTY NINE SORRY ABOUT THE
INJURY.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN KOWSKI A
SENATOR MONNING RACHEL BRIAN
HERE WITH DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS --
PERCENT YOU GUYS HAVING US HERE
TODAY I'M WANTED TO COMMENT ON
ARE BUDGET ITEM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE REQUESTS THE
REAPPROPRIATION OF FUNDS.
WERE APPROPRIATED IN THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN BUDGET ACT TO FUND THE
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURAL
PROGRAMS.
CDFA EXPECTS TO USE THE
REAPPROPRIATION D. G. R. F.. TO
FIND NEW DERRY DIE JESTERS
ALTERNATIVE MANURE MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES AND THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROJECTS AS PART OF OUR CLIMATE
SMART I CULTURAL EFFORTS.
WITH ANY NEW SIZZLE
SOLICITATIONS APPLICATIONS
RELEASED IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY IN TOTAL
SEVENTEEN PROJECTS WERE
TERMINATED BY CFA WITHOUT ENOUGH
TIME TO REALLOCATE FINDING TO
ANOTHER PROJECT.
THAT INCLUDED TO DERRY DIGEST A
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. ONE ALTERNATIVE IN
YOUR MANAGEMENT PROJECT AND
FOURTEEN HEALTHY SOILS PROJECTS.
REAPPROPRIATION OF THE
UNENCUMBERED GRF BALANCE WILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE
TO FIND ITS CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURAL PROGRAMS AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
LA -- YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON
THESE CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURAL
PROGRAMS WE DIDN'T RAISE ANY
ISSUES WITH THE REAPPROPRIATION.
I'M.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S JUST COULD A
TAKE A LITTLE BIT.
LONGER TIME TO DO THE RIGHT
THING -- LET'S OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING ON THIS IS.
ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTY NINE THE LAST IN ARGENTA.
BACK IN MARK AS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM WE
APPRECIATE THE APARTMENTS
COMMITMENT TO GETTING THE MONEY
OUT FOR THESE IMPORTANT PROGRAMS.
GREETINGS DELTA MULLIN FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMPASS COALITION
ALSO THE COMMUNITY LINES WITH
FAMILY PHAM IS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BUT AFTERNOON KATIE PATTERSON
WITH AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
KATHY WENT REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION COMPOST PRODUCERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
AREN'T THIS IS --
REAPPROPRIATION.
IT'S CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
[inaudible]
THERE'S A MOTION BY SENATOR
MINING PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FIVE OWNS MCGUIRE MINING.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY NINE THE
REAPPROPRIATION OF THE
GREENHOUSE GAS FUNDS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
JONES MCGUIRE STERN.
LET'S CLOSE THE ROLE THAT
MATTERS APPROVED -- THREE ZERO
LET'S GO BACK IN CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON THE OUTSTANDING.
VOTES THIS WILL BE ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTY SIX THIS IS THE SAN
GABRIEL LOWER LOS ANGELES OF
RIVER THE VOTE IS THREE ZERO TWO
SURE VOTING I PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND DURING.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE OTE
FOUR ZERO THAT MATTERS APPROVED.
WITH THE AIR RESOURCE BOARD.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN
INCREASED LITIGATION COSTS.
THE VOTE IS TWO ZERO THE CHAIR
VOTING I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
FIRE STERN.
CLOSE TO ROLL KELLY KELLY TO
VOTE THREE ZERO THE MATTERS
APPROVED AND DTS SEE.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHTY
ARGONAUT DAM.
PHASE TWO STORM WATER UPGRADE
THE VOTERS TO ZERO SURE VOTING
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CHOIR STERN.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTES
THREE ZERO THE MATTERS OF PROOF
THAT CONCLUDES OUR FOLKS
[inaudible]
WHAT REMAINS?
BIG ISSUE DATE WITH THAT.
FIRST REQUEST. FOR FUNDING IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN FORGIVE MY
SEE GIVE ME A MINUTE I WILL FIND
MY SHEET
[inaudible]
I WAS BACK ON THE RECORD WE HAVE.
EIGHTY FOUR LEGISLATIVE REQUESTS
BEFORE THIS SUBCOMMITTEE. NINETY
THREE EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY THREE
OKAY LET'S GET [inaudible]
EIGHTY THREE LET'S NOT QUIBBLE
I'LL READ THE REQUEST AND THE
PUBLIC N. F..
AND THE PUBLIC COMIC WILL OCCUR
ON ALL OF THEM AFTERWARDS SO IF
YOU'RE MAKING A PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE MAKE IT.
PLEASE BE BRIEF BUT WILL MAKE IT
AT THE END SO.
AND THE NATURAL RESOURCES IN
THIS IS YOU CAN FOLLOW ALONG AND
LEGISLATIVE REQUEST THIS IS PAGE
FOUR OF TODAY'S -- AGENDA -- FOR
THE NATURAL RESOURCES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION WE HAVE
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA.
SCIENCE CENTER WE HAVE. FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN.
MUSEUM WE HAVE THIRTY ONE POINT
THREE SIX FIVE MILLION FOR
WETLAND RESTORATION THE ELEVATED
KERRY.
RESTORATION WE HAVE SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR PLANNING
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK FOR THE
CHILDREN'S NATURAL HISTORY
MUSEUM.
WE HAVE FIVE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND TO REPLACE.
BLACK WELL HAMBRE HEIGHTS OF
FIRE DEPARTMENT NEW FIRE ENGINE
WE HAVE. FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND TO
REPLACE THE BUILDING AT THE
LIGHT HAMMER HEIGHTS FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
THAT THE HOUSE IS THE
FIREFIGHTING VEHICLES WE HAVE
FIVE MILLION TO ACQUIRE TEN
PARCELS -- AROUND THE HA PEDAL
FORWARD PARK.
EXPANSION PROJECT WE HAVE THREE
MILLION TO UPDATE THE MASTER
PLAN ON THE SAN GABRIEL RIVER
MASTER.
PLAN UPDATE WE HAVE ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION TO DEVELOP A PARK
ON A PARCEL AT THE JAMES
WHITAKER SCHOOL PART.
WE HAVE SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
THE PURCHASE A MAKER SPACE THREE
D..
PRINTER AT THE COLUMBIA MEMORIAL
SPACE CENTER WE HAVE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND AND
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND AND NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND FOR THE PICO RIVERA
PARKS AND RECREATIONAL VARIOUS
IMPROVEMENTS.
WE HAVE ONE POINT THREE MILLION
FOR UPGRADES AND REPAIRS AT THE
MONTEBELLO CITY PARK.
IMPROVEMENT AND THE CITY -- PARK
GENERAL RE HAPPEN IMPROVEMENT.
WE HAVE ANOTHER MEANT MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CITY OF BALLPARK
RENOVATION AT MONTEBELLO CITY
PARK.
WE HAVE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
FOR THE OCEANS INSTITUTE THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY NEEDS WE HAVE.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND TO FOR
CONCEPTUAL PLAN AT THE BOW TIE
PARCEL FOR THE STATE PARKS --
TIE.
IS THE PARKS PULL TYPE PARCEL WE
HAVE TEN MILLION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL.
AND HISTORICAL ENDOWMENT FOR THE
MUSEUM.
GRANT PROGRAM WE HAVE TEN
MILLION FOR THE FIRST FAVOR THE
FACE OF THE NATURAL HISTORY
MUSEUM OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
A MUSEUM.
EXPANSION WE HAVE THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION FOR THE RELIEF FOR
HOUSEHOLDS STILL RECOVERING FROM
THE DROUGHT EMERGENCY.
WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
VARIOUS PROGRAMS UNDER THE SAFE
AND CLEAN DRINKING WATER THE
SOUTHERN CENTRAL VALLEY.
WE HAVE. FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
BUT THERE IS A SAFE INJURING.
SAVING CLEAN DRINKING WATER FOR
THE SOUTHERN -- CENTRAL VALLEY
BRANDT KERN A CANAL WE HAVE
EIGHTY FOUR MILLION
AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION ON GOING
FOR THIRTY ONE CAL FIRE ENGINES.
WE HAVE SEVENTEEN MILLION. ONE
TIME FOR A ENTERED LAKE AT
TUNNELS FISH GREENS IN.
LAKE SENSE SAN ANTONIO ON LAKE.
NASCIMENTO.
WE HAVE SEVEN MILLION GENERAL
FROM FOR THIS.
COUNTY OF SAN LUIS OBISPO FOR
THE HEY YOU GUYS VETERANS ALL WE
HAVE TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
ANNUALLY FOR FOUR YEARS FOR A
TOTAL F MILLION DOLLARSFOR THE
ITALIAN.
AMERICAN MUSEUM WE HAVE. FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR THE CLEAN
AIR AT TECHNOLOGY UPGRADES FOR
FOR SCHOOLS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
WE HAVE. TEN MILLION FOR THE UC
RIVERSIDE'S BORNS COLLEGE OF
ENGINEERING CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL RESEARCH AND
TECHNOLOGY CEASAR.
WE HAVE. 10% OR THREE HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY FOR GREENHOUSE
GASES -- FOR CONTINUOUS.
FOR MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE INCENTIVES DEMOS AND
HIGHLIGHTS.
WE HAVE. TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
FOR ONE TIME RESEARCH BIOSOLIDS.
WITH THE FROM THE FOR THE
SANITATION DISTRICT OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE HAVE ONE
MILLION FOR THE SANTA SUSANNA
TRAILS IN THE GREENHOUSE GAS.
EMISSION FUND FOR THE LA COUNTY
PARKS RECREATION.
TRIANGLE PARK AS A FOURTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR GREENHOUSE GAS
ONE HOUSE ONE TIME.
REQUEST FOR PHASE FOUR OF US
THAT SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
AREAS.
SEQUESTRATION PROJECT WE HAVE
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION BURKE
NATURAL ON WORKING LANDS
COALITION. FOR THE GREENHOUSE
GAS [inaudible]
FUNDS [inaudible]
FOR AS HE APPROPRIATIONS OF
WHICH 10% WILL BE.
ALLOCATED TO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD AND THE STATE
CONSERVANCY'S.
RESILIENCY WORK WE HAVE. TEN
MILLION FOR GREENHOUSE GASES FOR
WILDLIFE RESILIENCY OUT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
IN -- SET FORTH AS A COMPONENT
OF SB FOUR SIXTY TWO WE HAVE A
TOTAL OF TWENTY MILLION FROM
GREENHOUSE.
HI GAS FUNDS OR GENERAL FUND
OVER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD FOR
REDUCING.
FIRE RISK IN THE WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE EXTENSION PROGRAM WE
HAVE. THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD -- TO
REIMBURSE VERSE COUNTIES AND TO
TRAIN LOCAL PLANNERS.
IN THE S. STATE RESPONSIBILITY
AREA WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND FOR THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH.
OR REDUCING FIRE RISK IN THE IN
THE I LOST MY PLACE.
THE WILDLIFE URBAN INTERFACE
ZONE.
WE HAVE TWELVE MILLION THE BLOCK
GRANT ANNUALLY FOR THREE YEARS
TO THE CALIFORNIA FIRE SAFETY --
COUNSEL FOR REDUCING.
HOW FIRE RISK IN THE?
WILDLIFE WHILE.
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE.
AREA.
WE HAVE FIVE MILLION -- FOR FOR
THE PUBLIC SAFETY PREPAREDNESS
REMOTE SENS.
SENSING WE HAVE FIVE MILLION FOR
THE PUBLIC SAFETY PREPAREDNESS
THE MAINTENANCE AND EVACUATION
ROUTES FOR EMERGENCY.
WE HAVE AN UNSPECIFIED AMOUNT
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY PREPAREDNESS
THE TARGET IN TRACK VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
WE HAVE FIVE MILLION FOR A
TWELVE MONTH FEASIBILITY STUDY
ON THE SALTON SEA.
WE HAVE FIVE MILLION FROM
GENERAL FUNDS FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF PROPERTIES ON THE
POLL SAID SHE GOT A MESS --
SACRED SITES PROTECTION PROJECT.
WE HAVE FIFTEEN MILLION A FOR
THE DISCOVERY SCIENCE CENTER --
CHILDREN'S MUSEUM IN ORANGE
COUNTY WE HAVE THREE MILLION
FROM THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING.
OF FUN -- FOR A PILOT PROJECT IN
SAN FRANCISCO WE HAVE. FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND TO REPAIR AND
PRESERVE THE LIGHT HOUSE
ALCATRAZ WE HAVE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND FOR THE
LESBIAN GAY BI STE.
SEXUAL TRANS GENDER.
A QUEER HISTORIC ARCHIVES.
WE HAVE ONE MILLION FOR THE
LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER
QUEER PUBLIC SPACES IN IN SAN
FRAN CISCO.
NOW WE HAVE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
FOR THE RENOVATION OF EAGLE
PLAZA.
THE FIRST.
AT G. B. T. E. Q..
PUBLIC PLAZA FOR LEATHER
COMMEMORATION ELEMENTS WE HAVE.
TWO POINT TWO MILLION FOR A
INDIAN BASIN FOR MEDIATION
PROJECT IN SAN FRANCISCO WE HAVE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION TO IMPROVE
WATER QUALITY A MARINE
PROTECTION.
AREAS A COMPREHENSIVE BLU CARBON
STRATEGY RESEARCH WE HAVE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION OF GREENHOUSE.
GAS FUND.
FOR URBAN FORESTRY.
STATE WATER EFFICIENCY IN HAS
BEEN PROGRAM IRVING GREENING
WETLAND WHILE.
WATERSHED RESTORATION PROJECTS.
EXCEPT OUR ARE WE HAVE FIFTEEN
MILLION FROM PROP SIXTY EIGHT
FOR THE TIJUANA RIVER BORDER
POLLUTION CONTROL PRODUCT.
PROJECT WE HAVE NINE POINT TWO
FIVE MILLION ANNUALLY FOR SIX
YEARS FOR RESEARCH ON IMPROVING
ATMOSPHERIC RIVER RESEARCH.
WE HAVE FIVE MILLION ON FACE TO
THE BUILDING SOME SOCCER COMPLEX
AT THE SALINAS REGIONAL SOCCER.
FACILITY WE HAVE FIVE MILLION
FROM GENERAL FUNDS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND AG.
OF OR THE HAS PREVENTION EFFORTS
WE HAVE NINE POINT FIVE MILLION
TO PURCHASE AND PRESERVE A
COUPLE OF COASTAL PROPERTIES IN
SAN MATEO COUNTY OF THE CLOVER.
DEAL RANCH IN GORDON RIDGE.
WE HAVE.
A HUNDRED MILLION -- TO REDUCE
ORGANIC MATERIAL GOING TO LAND
FILLED FOR THE SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS WASTE
DIVERSION AND FOOD RECOVERY
PROGRAM WE HAVE EIGHT MILLION
FOR PLANNING OF ENVIRONMENTAL.
REVIEW FOR DECEMBER TAIL COUNTY
MULTI.
BENEFIT.
STORM WATER CAPTURE PROGRAM WE
HAVE TEN MILLION OR THE NEW
RIVER.
FOR NEW WATER TREATMENT AND
PEDESTRIAN AND BIKE.
PATHWAYS WE HAVE PROPOSED
TRAILER.
LANGUAGE.
FOR I CHANGING THE SCORING
REGARDING GREENHOUSE GAS GRANT
APPLICATIONS WE HAVE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION FOR CAPITAL OUTLAYS.
OF TO REBUILD CAMPS THAT WERE
DESTROYED IN THE WOLSELEY AND
TOPS [inaudible]
BUYERS.
I'M WE HAVE EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR THE LOS ANGELES
MUSEUM OF THE HOLOCAUST.
AND WE HAVE TEN MILLION TO BUILD
THE VISITOR CENTER AT THE OR MIL
REDWOOD.
VISITORS.
CENTER PROJECT IN THERE IS.
REDWOOD NATIONAL FORESTS IN THE
AREA OF ENERGY WE HAVE A MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A PROJECT IN TO
CONNECT SEVENTEEN AGENCIES.
GIGA BYTE BROADBAND NETWORK IN
THE SOUTH BAY WE HAVE TWO
MILLION FOR THECLEAN ENERGY
COMMERCIALIZATION -- MEMORANDUM
OF UNDERSTANDING WE HAVE SEVEN
MILLION.
PER YEAR FOR THREE YEARS THE
PARADISE IRRIGATION.
DISTRICT WE HAVE SEVENTY MILLION
CONTINUED THE DISSOLUTION OF THE
NORTH COAST.
RAIL AUTHORITY THAT BEGAN LAST
YEAR.
WE HAVE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION TO
SUPPORT THE SACRAMENTO AREA
COUNCILS GREEN MEANS GO PROJECT.
AND WE HAVE ONE MILLION TO
PROMOTE CLEAN VEHICLES IN THE
SAN GABRIEL.
VALLEY.
IN THE AREA OF TRANSPORTATION WE
HAVE FIVE MILLION FOR THE SABRE
CATS MAKES USE TRAIL.
WE HAVE TEN MILLION FOR THE
STATE ROUTE ONE FIFTY SIX
CASTROVILLE SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS.
WE HAVE EIGHTY MILLION FOR
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
BURBANK AND ANAHEIM METROLINK
CORRIDOR WE HAVE UP TO TWO
BILLION.
TAKE CELEBRATES OF SAND SOUND
WALL WRETCH AFRAID LISTS
THROUGHOUT THE WE HAVE ONE
MILLION -- VIA.
REVIEW UPGRADING AT THE PALO
ALTO GRADE SEPARATION PROJECT WE
HAVE TEN MILLION FOR A
FEASIBILITY STUDY TO REPLACE THE
I A FIVE EIGHTY RICHMOND SAN
RAFAEL BRIDGE.
WE HAVE TEN MILLION FOR THE
DESTINATION CRENSHAW ALL.
PUBLIC GARDEN GREEN WAY PROJECT
IN LA COUNTY WE HAVE. FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND FOR
ANY RESEARCHER RESCUE VESSEL AND
THAT THE SANTA CRUZ PORT
DISTRICT.
WE HAVE FIVE MILLION FOR THE
LOCK KENYATTA -- RICH SOUND
WALLS WE HAVE SEVEN MILLION.
FORTY IMPROVEMENTS IN
INVESTMENTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
SHORTLINE RAILROAD
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE HAVE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
IN FUNDING FOR THE BEACH
BOULEVARD C. WOLLIN PROMENADE IN
THE CITY OF PACIFICA IN.
SAN MATEO COUNTY WE HAVE TEN
MILLION FOR THE ANTI SUICIDE
MEASURES FOR THE SAN DIEGO --
CORONADO BRIDGE WE HAVE. THREE
HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND FOR
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION OF A
BIKE AND PEDESTRIAN A LANDSCAPE
IMPROVEMENTS.
IT THE FOOTHILL BOULEVARD LINK
BIKE LIKELY IN PEDESTRIANS
BELTWAY WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION FOR THE FOOTHILL.
BOULEVARD LINK.
I JUST SAID THAT.
YEAH WE HAVE TWO MILLION FOR THE
TRAFFIC CONGESTION RELIEF
PERCENT GABRIEL IN AND ROSE ME
AND WE HAVE FINALLY ONE MILLION
TO SUPPORT BY SERVICE AT THE
WITH THE OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND THAT'S ALL WE HAVE SO WHAT
PEOPLE WOULD LIKE.
TO SHARE THEIR VIEWS ON THE
VARIOUS PROJECTS THAT ARE BEFORE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
TO I AM ALL EARS [inaudible]
FIRST.
BRIEF OUR AYE I GUESS I SHOULD
AS A PRELIMINARY -- COMMENT.
IT'S IT'S THE CHAIR'S INTENTION.
TO USE THE THREE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS NUMBER FROM
GREENHOUSE GAS AUCTIONS EIGHT
INCLUSIVE OF THE MAY AUCTION
THIS IS AND THIS IS IN --
CONFLICT -- DISAGREEMENT WITH
THE WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION OR
BILLION WE HAVE COLLECTED TWO
POINT FOUR BILLION SO FAR IN THE
THREE OPTIONS SO THE
ANTICIPATION OF THIS CHAIR IS
THAT WE'LL GET ANOTHER.
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR SOME
OF THESE PROJECTS I THINK THE
40% COMES OUT TO BE. 40% OF OF
EIGHT IS THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND OVER AND ABOVE WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS WITH THAT
LITTLE CAVIAR.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU SENATOR
BY CASKET CAPPING LYNCH
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS RECYCLE.
CAN THE ASSOCIATION A COMPOST
PRODUCERS IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF ITEM FIFTY SIX WHICH IS THE
ORGANICS DIVERSION -- I THINK --
WITHOUT BELAY BRING EVERYONE
KNOWS THAT WE HAVE SOME UP GOALS
IN THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM TO
READ REMOVE ORGANICS FROM THE
WASTE STREAM SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS A SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE IS GOING THROUGH FORMAL
ROLE MAKING RIGHT NOW.
WE REALLY NEED TO GET -- OVER A
HUNDRED COMPOSTELLA FACILITIES
IN THE GROUND AND THE ESTIMATE
IT'S GONNA COST BETWEEN TWO TO
THREE BILLION SO WE REALLY NEED
THE RESOURCES FOR MARKETS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU.
THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
DANIELLE IN TYPE TWO COMMENTS TO
MAKE -- IF YOU WILL INDULGE ME
THE FIRST IS ON A ITEM NUMBER
FORTY THREE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS AS WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS.
BUDGET REQUEST FOR THREE MILLION
DOLLARS I'M TO ESSENTIALLY FIND
ONE OF THE PILOT PROJECTS --
THAT CAN NOW OCCUR BASED ON THE
PREVIOUSLY PASSED SB. FOUR FIVE
EIGHT I'M THAT DOES A DRESS --
AND ALLOW FOR MOBILE RECYCLING
CENTERS TO OPERATE IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHICH ARE CRITICAL IN
THIS.
UNIQUE ENVIRONMENT.
WHERE THERE IS A LACK OF MOBILE
OR?
LACK OF RECYCLING CENTERS THAT'S
CREATING -- PAINS FOR RECYCLERS
AS WELL AS CONSUMERS ARE LOOKING
FOR PLACES TO ACTUALLY RECYCLE
THEIR MATERIALS.
I'M AND THEN THE SECOND ITEM IS
ITEM -- FOURTEEN SORRY ITEM
FIFTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF THE MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT THIS IS THE NINE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST.
FOR I'M TO PROPERTY ACQUISITIONS --
WHICH ARE REALLY CRITICAL TO
ACQUIRE AND PERMANENTLY PROTECT
THESE TWO PROPERTIES.
INSURER -- THAT CREATION OF
PUBLIC ACCESS TRAILS PROTECTION
OF NATURAL RESOURCES -- SUPPORT
FOR THE NATURAL -- SUPPORT FOR
THE AGRICULTURAL WORKING
FAMILIES IN THE AREA EXCEPT FOR
WHICH WE THINK ARE REALLY
CRITICAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR RICO
MONSTER THE NOT A WITH THE TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND I HAVE THREE
ITEMS IS -- I'LL SPEAK.
TO THE FIRST IS NUMBER FIFTY THE
GDR A FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR ASK I'LL JUST NOTE THAT
THERE ARE NINETY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT GOT TOGETHER TO ACTUALLY
DELINEATE THAT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION AND TO SEPARATE.
BOX WHICH WE HAVE SUBMITTED TO
YOUR COMMITTEE OF COURSE -- IN
MY MIND AS SOMEONE WHO WORKS --
NOT PERSONALLY BUT OUR
ORGANIZATION WORKS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WE
SIMPLY CANNOT WAIT TO MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS IN URBAN FORESTRY IN
URBAN GREENING AND WETLANDS.
HE'S ON THE SHOULD BE MAY BE
MADE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND
PROP SIXTY EIGHT WAS NOT MEANT
TO SUPPLANT THOSE ALL JUST LEAVE
IT AT THAT.
MY NEXT -- IS FOR OF THE BOLSA
CHICA ACQUISITION WHICH IS LINE
ITEM NUMBER -- FORTY ONE WE UP
AND WORKING WITH THE BOLSA CHICA
LAND TRUST. FOR FOR DECADES TO
TRY TO ACQUIRE OF THE LAST PIECE
OF PRIVATELY OWNED.
PROPERTY TO STITCH TOGETHER THIS
ONE OF A BEAUTIFUL -- PRESERVE
THAT CHECKS ALL THE BOXES IT'S
ACCESS IT'S WILDLIFE IT'S
CLIMATE ADAPTATION.
LASTLY IS INDIA BASS AND A LINE
ITEM NUMBER -- FORTY EIGHT THIS
WOULD TRANSFORM A POST
INDUSTRIAL BROWNFIELD INTO A
LEGACY PARK ON THAT ALSO CHECKS
ALL THE BOXES FOR A PUBLIC ASSET
ACCESS OF SOCIAL EQUITY.
A RECREATION CLIMATE ON THIS IS
A NEIGHBORHOOD THAT HAS 85% OF
THE POPULATION LIVES TWICE BELOW
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL SO.
URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON ALL.
THREE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CENTER MY NAME
STILL GINSBURG I ACTUALLY RUN
SAN FRANCISCO'S RECREATION PARK
DEPARTMENT AND I'M GOING TO
FOLLOW UP ON ITEM NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT WHICH IS.
I. INDIA BASIN -- OUR GOAL HERE
IS TO REALLY CREATE AS A LEGACY --
PARK PROJECT IT'S A TEN ACRE
PARK PROJECT -- AS RICO NOTED IN
ONE OF THE CITY'S POOREST
NEIGHBORHOODS -- WORKING WITH
MANY MANY MANY DIFFERENT
PARTNERS -- OUR GOAL THIS THIS
PROJECT OFFERS CLIMATE
RESILIENCY.
IT'S A BIG ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
PROJECT -- AND VERY
SIGNIFICANTLY -- THE VAST
MAJORITY THE NEIGHBORHOOD THAT
THIS PARK WILL SERVE LIVES IN
EITHER PUBLIC OR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- WE HAVE THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF OUR MAYOR OUR LOCAL
LEGISLATORS SENATOR WIENER IS --
VERY ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN THIS
PARK AND THE TWO POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST WILL
ALLOW US TO COMPLETE
ENVIRONMENTAL REMEDIATION WITH
THE COMMUTER PUTTING THE
COMMUNITY TO WORK IN DOING THE
PROJECT.
SO WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND WHAT'S THE FULL PROJECT
ESTIMATE RIGHT NOW FOR PROJECT
ESTIMATE IS OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
AND OF THAT HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT US --
WELL WE HOPE TO RAISE SIXTY
MILLION IN PRIVATE FUNDING I DO
NEED TO RELY ONLOCAL STATE AND
HOPEFULLY SOME FEDERAL FUNDING --
FOR THE OTHER SIXTY WE HAVE SOME
FUNDING FROM THE BAY AREA
RESTORATION AUTHORITY WE
ACTUALLY A LITTLE BIT FUNDING
FROM FROM EACH FROM THE EPA WE
WILL APPLY. FOR SOME PROP SIXTY
EIGHT FUNDING BUT THE TIMING IS
OF THE ESSENCE -- ON THE
REMEDIATION PIECE WHICH WE WANT
TO BEGIN -- IMMEDIATELY.
THANKS FOR KEEPING ALL THE
MATTERS OPEN SO.
EVERYBODY KNOWS.
LACKEY FLYNN WITH THE A PHILIP
RANDOLPH INSTITUTE SAN FRANCISCO
WE'RE BASED IN BAYVIEW HUNTERS
POINT AND WE ARE VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT WITH IS.
THE INDIA BASS AND REMEDIATION
PROJECT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS BROOKE RIVERA I'M
A DIRECTOR WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO PARKS LANCE I'M
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ITEM FORTY EIGHT WE ARE PARTNER-WITH RECKON PARK AND TPL.
ON OTHER PARTNERS ON THE IN THE
BASIN PROJECT I'M ALSO HERE TO
SPEAK.
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT FROM MY
HEART FOR ITEM FORTY SEVEN OF
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
ALLOCATION FOR EAGLE PLAZA.
EAGLE PLAZA WILL BE A CRITICALLY
NEEDED NEW PUBLIC GREEN SPACE
AND COMMUNITY SPACE IN SAN
FRANCISCO'S WESTERN SOME A
NEIGHBORHOOD WHICH IS
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERSERVED BY
PUBLIC SPACE IT IS LESS THAN 1%
OF THE CITY WIDE AVERAGE RATIO
OF OPEN SPACE ACREAGE PER
RESIDENT.
BUT IS ONE OF SANTA'S BECAUSE
FASTEST GROWING NEIGHBORHOODS.
EAGLE PLAZA IMPORTANTLY WILL
ALSO BE THE WORLD'S FIRST PUBLIC
SPACE COMMEMORATING AND
CELEBRATING AN IMPORTANT SUB
CULTURE OF THE GLOBAL LGBT Q.
COMMUNITY.
CALLED LEATHER CULTURE I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THIS COMMUNITY ON
EAGLE PLAZA SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN
IT'S A GRASSROOTS EFFORT WITH-STRONG AND WIDESPREAD COMMUNITY
AND CITY SUPPORT.
INCLUDING DIRECT SUPPORT FROM
SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR BREED
SUPERVISORS HEINLEIN MANDEL MEN
SENATOR SCOTT WIENER AMON
HUNDREDS OF COMMUNITY LEADERS TO
DATE WE RAISE A ONE OVER ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS --
OF THE ONE POINT EIGHT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THE PROJECT
NEEDS WE'RE SEEKING ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
MORE WHICH IS WHY I'M HERE TODAY
FOR OUR ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR REQUEST.
WE THINK WE CAN MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE AND COMMUNITY
FUNDRAISING.
AS CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION GROWS
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE HONOR AND PRESERVE THE RICH
CULTURAL DIVERSITY THAT MAKES
OUR STATE SO UNIQUE PROGRESSIVE
AND CELEBRATED.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR CHASING AND SALAS
ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
WATER DISTRICT HERE IN SUPPORT
OF ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTY TWO FORECASTING FOR
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS YOU'VE SEEN I
SUSPECT THE LETTER FROM ABOUT
TWENTY OF YOUR COLLEAGUES -- AS
THIS YEAR INDICATED THAT WAS FOR
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS -- THEY COME
RATHER FREQUENTLY AND 90% OF THE
STATE'S PRECIPITATION COMES FROM
ATMOSPHERIC I'M SORRY FLOODING
COMES MADNESS RICK RIVERS AND
ABOUT HALF OF THE PRECIPITOUS
PRECIPITATION SO THIS WOULD
ALLOW US. TO FORECAST IN.
AND TO THE EXTENT YOU HAVE
AVAILABLE FUNDS IN YOUR
CHECKBOOK AS YOU KEEP MOVING
THROUGH THIS LIST -- ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF ROSEMEAD WE ALSO SUPPORT THAT
FOR THE TRAFFIC.
CONGESTION RELIEF WITHIN THAT
SEVEN TEN CORRIDOR AND JUST TO
CLARIFY IT IS NOT FOR THE TUNNEL
SO WE APPRECIATE IN SUPPORT YOU
MAY BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR ROCKY RUSSIAN WITH
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR.
HERE TODAY ON ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY SEVEN E. G. G. R. F. OF
MULTI YEAR FUNDING FOR MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
INCENTIVES DEMOS AND HIGHLIGHTS.
I'M ALSO REPRESENTING -- PRINCE
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION TODAY.
ECHOES OF CLEAN AIR WE DEAL WITH
A COMMUNITIES HEAVILY IMPACTED
BY AIR POLLUTION AS WELL AS
MANUFACTURERS -- YAMS AND WHILE
THEY COME FROM DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES WE HEAR THE SAME
THING FROM BOTH THAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS A STEADY CONSISTENT.
INVESTMENT IN. ZERO NEAR ZERO
FREIGHT MOVEMENT AND AT TO DO SO
WOULD PROVIDE CERTAINTY TO THE
MANUFACTURERS WHO NEED ONE FAST.
AND IT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE
CERTAINTY IN THE STATE'S
COMMITMENTS TO THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE FORCED TO BREED.
DIRTY AIR FOLLOWED BY DIESEL.
EMISSIONS SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH I WILL
NOTE THAT THE SKINNER
LEGISLATION.
TOOK OUT THE FUNDING MECHANISM
ON ON THAT ON THAT THIS IS THE
CORRESPONDING UNDERLYING
LEGISLATION BUT THAT'S CORRECT
THANK YOU FOR THE BENEFIT OF
YOUR THOUGHTS.
NEXT.
SHERMAN FIVE MARK A PREY ON
BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES HERE
ON ITEM FIFTY SIX IN SUPPORT.
AS THE CHAIR WELL KNOWS --
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE REQUIRES THAT 75% OF
ORGANIC MATERIAL CURRENTLY GOING
TO LANDFILLS.
BE REMOVED AND PROCESSED -- THE
FOLKS A CAL RECYCLE INDICATE
THAT THIS WILL TAKE. ONE TO
THREE BILLION DOLLARS AND ONE
HUNDRED FACILITIES -- THAT GIVES
US VERY LITTLE TIME. TO GET TO
THOSE GOALS BUT THAT WHICH ARE
AT AT TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND AS
A RESULT CAPITAL A AN INFUSION
OF CAPITAL IS NECESSARY. FOR
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
PROCESSING FACILITIES.
AS WELL AS FOR DEVELOPING
MARKETS AND THEREFORE WE WOULD
URGE YOU SUPPORT THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR I REQUEST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO GELLER ROBINSON ON BEHALF
OF RETHINK WAY STANDS HERE IN
OUR ENVIRONMENT TO SERVICES.
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
SIX I THINK MARK SPOKE WELL
ABOUT IT JUST WANT TO REITERATE
THAT IN ORDER TO ME SB THIRTEEN
EIGHT THREES.
ORGANIC WASTE A VERSION GOALS
THIS FUNDING WILL BE CRUCIAL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- SO IN
A NUMBER FIFTY SIX FOR THE
COMPOST COALITION AND THE
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH DIRECT IS
JUST TO AS YOU WELL ON THOUGH.
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE THE BEST
BANG FOR YOUR BUCK.
RESOURCES BOARD TWENTY NINETEEN
REPORTS INDICATED THAT THE MONEY
SPENT ON THE LOANS AND GRANTS
FOR THIS RECYCLING I GAVE US A
BASED RETURN ON GHG REDUCTIONS.
I ALSO WANTED TO SPEAK QUICKLY
ON NUMBER FORTY NINE THAT'S THE
COMPREHENSIVE BLUE CARBON
STRATEGY.
THIS REALLY IS A VERY VERY SMALL
INVESTMENT OF MONEY FOR THIS
MASSIVE IMPACT THAT.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS HAVING A
COASTAL AND OCEAN ENVIRONMENTS
IF YOU CONSIDER A IN THE LATEST
REPORT -- ON THE ON THE TIME AND
INVESTMENTS THE LATEST REPORT IS
22% OF OUR POPULATION -- 22% OF
THE OF THE AREA OF CALIFORNIA IS
IN THE COASTAL ZONE AND 80% OF
OUR GDP IS PRODUCED THERE.
AND THIS IS A REALLY SMALL
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO OFFSET
MASSIVE -- COSTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ON A COASTAL AND OCEAN
ENVIRONMENT SO WE OWE IT TO
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THE GERMANS I'M NOT REMOVE THE
GOVERNOR TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
HERE IN SUPPORT OF ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN THE 10% MULTI YOUR
PREPARATION OF A DID YOU ARE I
FUNDS.
I HAD THIS MONEY WILL GO TOWARDS
ALLOWING US.
TO INCREASED INCENTIVE MONEY FOR
OUR COMPANIES TO TURN OVER THEIR
FLEETS TO THE ZERO NEAR ZERO
EMISSION TRACKS.
I THEIR PLAN THEY'RE MAKING
PLANS FIVE TEN YEARS OUT AND
THAT'S CERTAIN TO WERE BY TO
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO HELP US
ENSURE THAT WE KEEP THE CLEAN
SLEEK IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIVALIK ON BEHALF
OF A COUPLE CLIENTS A COUPLE
DIFFERENT ITEMS FIRST I'LL BE AT
THIS NUMBER AND EVERY REAL
TRANSIT DISTRICT.
PRODUCTS OR RIDE NUMBER SIXTY
SIX THIS IS A KICK IN YOU THE
DISSOLUTION OF THE NORTH COAST
RAILROAD AUTHORITY.
WE GOT THAT PROCESS STARTED LAST
YEAR WE NEED TO MOVE INTO IT
THAT I'M RATTLED.
AND THEN ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT ITEM NUMBER -- EIGHTY
FOUR WHICH IS -- MONEY FOR THE
INDY FIVE PRIDE SETS.
UP A SERVICE FOR ANY PARTS.
A RICHER SUPPORT FOR THAT AS
WELL.
OKAY JUST GO GAGA HERE WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES AND ALSO
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY. FOR THE
LA COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICT'S
ON ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SIX AND
TWENTY EIGHT THOUGH FOR NUMBER
FIFTY SIX ON THE ORGANICS WASTE
DIVERSION.
MONEY -- I JUST A DEFERRED OF
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS AND WE'RE
SUPPORT FOR THOSE SAME REASONS A
NUMBER -- TWENTY EIGHT THIS IS
ACTUALLY A MULTI AGENCY RESEARCH
EFFORT TO EVALUATE THE SOIL
RECLAMATION ATTRIBUTES OF BILE
SALTS APPLICATION ON FIRE
RAVAGED LAND -- IT'S A
RELATIVELY SMALLER CLASSES TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT WE
THINK WILL YIELD REALLY VALUABLE
INFORMATION ABOUT STATEWIDE
WILDFIRE RECLAMATION PRACTICES
MOVING FORWARD SO.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SHARE BRING RC ON BEHALF OF CAL
STAR ALWAYS FOR ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN TO SO.
SENATOR I FUNDS TO MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE INCENTIVES ON
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION.
WE NEED THIS KIND OF MONEY TO
INVEST IN.
NEW VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY 3% OF
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD ARE MEDIUM
HEAVY DUTY BUT THEY MAKE UP
ALMOST A QUARTER EMISSIONS IF
YOU WANT TO MEET OUR GOALS. TO
MAKE AMERICA BUS FUNDING WE NEED
TO HAVE A MULTI YEAR THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISS CHAIR AND
STAFF -- I'LL FEDERAL NON BEHALF
OF THE LA RIVER STATE PARK
PARTNERS ON ITEM.
FIFTEEN RELATED TO THE STATE
PARKS BOW TIE PARCEL -- THIS
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
REQUEST FOR THE CONCEPTUAL PLAN
AND AN ADDITIONAL STAFF POSITION --
IS CRITICAL TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE BUT I PARCEL ACTUALLY COMES
TO FRUITION AS WAS INTENDED AS A
PARK.
CURRENTLY IT'S IT'S A POST
INDUSTRIAL LANDSCAPE THE
BASICALLY CEMENT EVERYWHERE YOU
SEE.
VERY NEAR -- COMMUNITIES THAT DO
NEED ACCESS TO TO SAVE GREEN
SPACES IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS --
AND PARTICULARLY ALONG THE LA
RIVER -- WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
COMMENT ON ITEM FIFTEEN AND AND
ACTUALLY OFFER A I THINK WHAT I
HAVE IS A PIECE OF CLARIFICATION
IN RELATION TO ITEM WITH --
THIRTY ONE THIRD ARE MENTIONED
THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR NATURAL LOOKING LANDS TO THE
FROM THE G. R. F..
I DON'T KNOW -- THIRTY ONE AFTER
SPEAKING WITH THE WITH THE
SENATOR THAT WAS LEAD ON THAT
LETTER GOT SOME CLARIFICATION
THAT THAT MAY INCLUDE AN
ADDITIONAL REQUESTS 410% OF THAT
FUNDING TO BE.
SET ASIDE FOR TO BE SEEING
CONSERVANCY'S I GOT THAT -- BUT
THE THE DIFFERENCE IN THE LETTER
THAT YOU RECEIVED FROM THE
NINETY OR SO NGOS -- THAT HAVE
COME TOGETHER BEHIND THE BROADER
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST IS ACTUALLY ASKING FOR
MORE MONEY.
BE A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION SPECIFICALLY FOR
W. C. B. IN THE CONSERVANCY'S
I'M TWENTY MILLION OF WHICH
WOULD BE FORCED THE COSTA
CONSERVANCY SEVENTY MILLION FOR
THE REST OF THE CONSERVANCY'S.
AND W. C. BEGINNING THE
REMAINDER -- IN ADDITION TO
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT'S ON MY
OUTLINED THE LETTER -- AND
MAKING THESE THOSE COMMON
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE DID YOUR
APP ON BEHALF OF BROWN OF THE
FENCE FUND THE CALIFORNIA PLANTS
SOCIETY.
I'M GONNA KNOW HAVE -- SOME
ADDITIONAL COUNTERPARTS HERE TO
THIS BECAUSE WELL.
THANK YOU.
BUT I'LL TELL ME ON A ONE UP
WITHOUT ONE CALIFORNIA WE ALSO
SUPPORT ITEM LANE WAS FIFTEEN
SAY PARKS A BOW TIE PARTIAL.
AND ALSO A LINE M COMMENTS
RELATED TO THE LARGER -- G. R.
F. ASK FOR FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ON NATURAL WORKING LANDS.
THE OTHER ITEMS THAT.
YELLOW ITEM LINE TWENTY ARE THE
SAFE CLEAN DRINKING WATER FOR
THE SOUTHERN CAL SOUTHERN
CENTRAL VALLEY PRANK CANAL FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME ALLOCATION -- TO
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES WE
HAVE SINCE SINCE SOME SINCERE
CONCERNS AROUND THAT ISSUE.
WE YOU DON'T BELIEVE THAT -- THE
STATE SHOULD BE FUNDING.
IN SUBSIDIZING USERS ARE ON THIS
ISSUE SO.
AN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE OTHER THING
THAT WE WOULD OPPOSE IS -- I
LOVE ITEM LINE FORTY SONGS SEE
STUDY.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING THE SALTON
SEA FOR A LONG TIME -- WE HAVE.
WE FINALLY BELIEVE THAT WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE SOME TRACTION IN
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S SOME
RESTORATION EFFORTS.
GOING ON THERE I THINK THIS
ISSUE WOULD JUST CONTINUE TO
DISTRACT FROM THE ACTUAL THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO DO IN THE SALTON
SEA.
AND WE WOULD BOB SINCERELY
OPPOSE THIS ISSUE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES HI I'M I'M.
SURE TO SUPPORT ITEM.
FORTY FOUR BE A ACROSS LIGHT
HOUSE RESTORATION PROJECT.
WHAT IS A LIGHT HOUSE DOING IN
THIS PROGRAM OF PROJECTS ARE SO
IMPORTANT THAT?
IT HERE WE ARE IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PROJECT WE FEEL I'M WITH THE U.
S. LIGHTHOUSE SOCIETY IN THE
THIRTY FIVE YEARS I'VE BEEN WITH
THE ORGANIZATION I'VE NEVER SEEN
A MORE IMPORTANT WHITE HOUSE
PROJECT.
BECAUSE IT'S ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PRESIDENT THAT PRISON RECEIVES
OVER TO WELL ALMOST TWO MILLION
PEOPLE A YEAR.
THE VISIBILITY OF THIS LIGHT
HOUSE PROJECT IS HUGE AND IT
NEEDS TO BE RESTORED AND IS TO
BE A PRIDE OF CALIFORNIA AS
OPPOSED TO SOMETHING
DETERIORATING AS IT IS NOW.
WE'RE NOT REQUESTING -- OR THE
PROJECTS NOT REQUESTING JUST
PUBLIC MONEY THIS IS GONNA BE A
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC CAMPAIGN.
IN THE SMALL AMOUNT THAT WE ARE
REQUESTING WILL HELP KICKSTART
THE OVERALL PROGRAM WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE FINAL.
SEPERTI NUMBERS GOING TO BE ON
THIS ACTUALLY.
COMPARED TO SOME OF THE OTHER
REQUESTS HERE IT'S RELATIVELY
SMALL THE OVERALL -- BUDGETS AND
WE THREE POINT FIVE MILLION.
ALL RIGHT THANKS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
HELLO GONZALEZ WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY HERE TO SUPPORT TWO
ITEMS -- FIRST OF ALL AND
FIFTEEN RELATING TO THE STATE
PARKS BOW TIE PARCEL NOT FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR LOCATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
AS WELL AS ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
REALLY DOES THAT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS EACH YEAR AFTER
ASK FOR CRITICAL NATURAL
RESOURCE PROGRAMS WE WOULD ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS MADE
BY.
AND FOR A LOT IT ON THOUGH --
JUST REGARD TO SOME OF THOSE
NUANCES THAT WERE DISCUSSED
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CLAIRE FARLEY AND I AM THE
SENIOR ADVISER IT'S AND MARYLAND
AND BREED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE AS
TRANSGENDER INITIATIVES.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT.
ON BEHALF OF MY OFFICE IN MERE
BREED.
NUMBER FORTY SIX AND FORTY SEVEN
THE PLAZA PROJECTS [inaudible]
I'M.
YOU KNOW WE REALLY SUPPORT THE
IS PROPOSED PLAZA AS BECAUSE
THEY WILL HONOR SAN FRANCISCO IN
CALIFORNIA'S INCLUSIVE VALUES
AND CELEBRATE OUR LGBT CULTURAL
HERITAGE.
AS WELL AS IT WILL SERVE AS OPEN
SPACES FOR ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES TO ENJOY A SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST DENSELY.
POPULATED NEIGHBORHOODS THE ONE
POINT ONE MILLION BEING
REQUESTED TO SUPPORT THE
CONSTRUCTION AND REHABILITATION
OF BOTH OF THESE PLAZAS WILL
HONOR SAN FRANCISCO IN
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESSIVE VALUES.
AND OMMITMENT TO THE LGBT
COMMUNITY.
THE HARVEY MILK PLAZA HAS SERVED
AS A CENTER FOR THE LGBT
COMMUNITY FOR MORE THAN THREE
DECADES AND WE SHARE THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE THIS
LEGACY AND AFFIRM THE IMPORTANCE
OF CELEBRATING OUR LGBT HISTORY.
MAYOR BREEDING MY OFFICE ARE
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT THE
SPIRIT OF HARVEY MILK'S LIVE
CONTINUES TO SERVE AS A CENTER
FOR THE COALITION BUILDING AS
WELL AS A PLACE FOR THE LGBT
COMMUNITY TO CONTINUE TO THRIVE
IN CALL HOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANDREA
I ELLO AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
FRIENDS OF HER FROM A POSSUM AND
I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT ITEM
NUMBER.
FORTY SIX ON THE SUPPORT FOR
PUBLIC SPACES IN SAN FRANCISCO --
HARPING ON PLAZA.
AND WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
PROJECT TH COULD BE IT'S A VERY
VERY COMMUNITY BASED GRASSROOTS
EFFORT SINCE -- CENTER WINNER
WAS OUR SUPERVISOR IN -- TWENTY
FOURTEEN IMPACT THE COMMUNITY
HAS BEEN WORKING ON A VISION TO
REALLY -- CREATE A PUBLIC SPACE
AT THE CASTER MUNIS STATION.
THAT TRULY HONORS HARVEY MILK IN
A WAY THAT IS COMMENSURATE WITH
THIS COMIC INDIVIDUAL AND WHAT
HE HAS STOOD FOR FOR BASICALLY
THE WORLD WIDE.
LGBT MOVEMENT.
I'M REALLY FOR FOR DECADES SINCE
THE HARLEM APOSTLE WAS.
INAUGURATED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE IT'S IT'S AN UNDERGROUND
DARK HIDDEN SPACE.
IN THE CASTER MUNIS STATION --
THAT HAS A PLAQUE AND THREE
PHOTOGRAPHS AND WE HAVE WE FEEL
LIKE THAT IS REALLY NOT ENOUGH
TO HONOR THIS INCREDIBLE
INDIVIDUAL.
WHO IS SO IMPORTANT FOR SAN
FRANCISCO FOR CALIFORNIA AND
REALLY FOR THE WORLD -- SO WE
ARE AND AS I SAID THE
COMMUNITIES BEEN TRYING FOR
DECADES TO DO THIS AND ON THIS
CURRENT EFFORT IS THE FURTHEST
THAT ANYONE HAS EVER GOTTEN.
WE ARE RAISING MONEY WE HAVE
OBVIOUSLY THE SUPPORT OF CENTER
WIENER MAY YOUR BREED OUR
CURRENT SUPERVISOR AND TO
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IN SAN FRANCISCO -- WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED WE HAVE DAYS WHEN
APPROVAL THROUGH THE ARTS
COMMISSION AND WE HAVE
RENDERINGS WE HAD A
INTERNATIONAL COMPETITION OR
FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE COMMENTED.
ARE 40% OF THOSE PEOPLE WERE
FROM NINE FOUR ONE ONE FOR THE
CASTRO ZIP CODE.
THE WILL E. ARE YOU KNOW VERY
EXCITED AND IT REALLY WOULD
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT IT REALLY
IS SUPPORT WOULD GIVE OUR
PRIVATE DONORS.
CONFIDENCE THAT THE STATE -- IS
BEHIND THIS AND THAT THIS
PROJECT WILL REALLY GET OFF THE
GROUND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TAX.
HI THERE DANIEL BIRCHER ACT
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CASTRO MERCHANTS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY I INDIVIDUAL INDEPENDENT
MERCHANT MEMBERS.
WE ARE IN FAVOR OF ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY SIX HARVEY MILK PLAZA AND
LOOK FORWARD TO BEING ABLE TO
PROPERLY HONOR THIS AMERICAN
HERO THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RAY
CALMLY I'M A RESIDENT BUSINESS
OWNER AND A BUILDING OWNER IN
THE CASTRO AND I ALSO IN THE
ACTING.
FUNDRAISING CHAIR FOR THE
FRIENDS OF HER EMAIL BEHIND THIS
PROJECT.
AND WE ASK THE YOU APPROVED THE
ONE MILLION DOLLARS. TO GO
TOWARDS IS PROJECTS TO THE WE
CAN.
CREATE A DESTINATION FOR NOT
ONLY THE RESIDENTS OF SAN
FRANCISCO BUT THE TOURISTS TO
COME TO VISIT SAN FRANCISCO
EVERY DAY.
AND THAT WE CAN HONOR HARVEY
MILK IN THE WAY THAT WE SHOULD
BE HOVERING HAN HONORING HARVEY
MILK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MAX.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
SEVENTY MORAL HERE ON BEHALF OF
RECALL GEE I ON TWO ITEMS.
SPECIFICALLY ITEM NUMBER FORTY
THREE THE THREE MILLION --
THAT'S GOING TOWARD THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PILOT
PROJECT IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I
DON'T NUMBER -- FIFTY SIX
REGARDING ORGANICS WASTE
DIVERSION I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS
BRIEF AND SAY THAT WE ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS.
THANK YOU.
HI CHRISTINA LACKEY WITH THE
SACRAMENTO AREA COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS HERE IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTY SEVEN AND GOES A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT SAY COG DEVELOPED
AT THE DIRECTION OF THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IN ORDER TO HELP
US RETURN NEW 19% GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS REDUCTION TARGET.
IN OUR UPCOMING SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES STRATEGY REMAINS GO
LOOKS ALRIGHT INFILL DEVELOPMENT
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS AND
ELECTRIFICATION OF POSSIBLE
PASSENGER VEHICLE TRIP.
AND IT'S SIX TO PROVIDE
INCENTIVES TO LAYER THESE THREE
COMPONENTS IN AND FILL AREAS IN
ORDER TO PAIR HOUSING AND OTHER
INFILL INVESTMENTS WITH
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS TO
CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY OF
DEVELOPMENT AND ARE SIX COUNTY
REGION.
WORKING WITH THE STATE WE HOPE
TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO ACHIEVE OUR
MULTIPLE OF MUTUAL REGIONALS AND
STATE HOUSING AND ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS WITH GREEN MEANS GO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
SHARE JOKES WHO'S ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY SAN MATTEO WE RESPECT
THE REQUEST -- FUNDING FOR A
COUPLE ITEMS ITEM FIFTY SEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN SAN MATEO COUNTY
MULTI BENEFITS STORMWATER
CAPTURE PROGRAM.
THIS WOULD FUND EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN PLANNING.
ENVIRONMENTAL AND REVIEW.
OF OF SEVERAL REGIONAL STORM
WATER RETENTION PROJECTS REALLY
TO HELP CITIES AND COUNTIES
IMPROVE THEIR FLOOD CONTROL IN
SINGLE SYLLABLE RISE RESILIENCY.
AND SECOND IS ITEM EIGHTY IT'S A
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
FUNDING REQUEST.
FOR THE FUN THE BEACH BOULEVARD
SEA WALL IN PROM NOT PROJECT.
THANK YOU.
YES AFTERNOON MY NAME'S DUSTIN
COOPER I'M HERE ON AGENDA ITEM
SIXTY FIVE PARADISE YOUR GEISHA
DISTRICT.
AND IN SUPPORT OF THEIR BACK
FILL FUNDING REQUEST.
I AM A RESIDENT PARADISE AND I'M
A CAMPFIRE SURVIVOR I CAN'T TELL
YOU HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS TO US.
BE DISTRICT IS REALLY AND
FINANCIAL CRISIS AND IT'S
UNPRECEDENTED IN ITS SCOPE AND
MAKE THE SITUATION PRESENTED
BEFORE US.
WE HAVE SUFFICIENT FUNDS FROM
FEMA AND CAL WE **** TO RECOVER
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WAS
DAMAGED AS A RESULT OF HIGHER.
WHAT WE DO NOT HAVE WHAT THOSE
FUNDING SOURCES DO NOT PROVIDE?
IS FUNDING FOR THE ONGOING
OPERATION OF THE DISTRICT.
SO THESE ARE THINGS LIKE IT'S
BEEN A LIGHT ON KEEPING A
SKELETON CREW OF EMPLOYEES.
THEIR BUSINESS.
MAINTAINING THE TREATMENT PLAN
AND RESERVOIRS THOSE TYPES OF
OPERATIONAL EXPENSES.
ALL THROUGH THIS FUNDING GAP.
NORMALLY THOSE TYPES OF EXPENSES
WOULD BE FUNDED BY THE CUSTOMERS
THE HOMES AND BUSINESSES IN
PARADISE.
BUT OBVIOUSLY THE FIRE
DEVASTATED THAT COMMUNITY.
AND THEY'RE NO LONGER ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE DISTRICT
[inaudible]
SO I'VE.
I KNOW THROUGH THE ACTIONS AND
STATEMENTS OF THE GOVERNOR.
MANY OF YOU ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES HAVE
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR REBUILDING
PARADISE.
AND I WOULD PROFFER TO YOU SIR
THAT THIS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT WITHOUT A SAFE
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
THIS COMMUNITY CANNOT REBUILT.
AND THIS I REQUEST IS ESSENTIAL
TO THAT REBUILDING EFFORT.
COULD YOU ENLIGHTEN ME ON THE
STATUS OF THE DISCUSSIONS YOU'VE
HAD WITH CONSOLIDATION OF OTHER
WATER DISTRICTS PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC IN BUTTE COUNTY.
THIS IS A BIG CONCERN TO THIS
COMMITTEE ALSO IS THESE.
LEGACY SMALL PRIVATE WATER
PROVIDERS IN THE AREA.
THE GENERAL MANAGER OF HER
RESERVATION DISTRICT IS SPEAKING
AFTER ME I'M I'M MEDICAID YOU MY
BEST AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE HIM
TO ANSWER THIS AS WELL -- WE DO
NOT USE THE TERM CONSOLIDATION
WE USE THE TERM IN OUR TIME
[inaudible]
I'M THE SILVER LINING SO TO
SPEAK. ONE OF THE SILVER LININGS
FROM THIS FIRE IS.
THE ID'S ESERVOIRS AND
TREATMENT PLANT WAS LARGELY
UNTOUCHED.
AND CAN BE UTILIZED IT'S IT'S
ESSENTIALLY STRANDED ASSETS AT
THE MOMENT.
IN COULD BE UTILIZED --
REGIONALLY TO BENEFIT.
OF THOSE PARTIES.
AND ALSO BENEFIT THE DISTRICT IN
TERMS OF FINANCIAL SUPPORT --
CANDIDLY THAT'S A VERY COMPLEX
TRANSACTION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
AND WE NEED TIME.
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE A REGULATORY
APPROVALS FUNDING.
NEGOTIATE THOSE TYPES OF THINGS --
SO THIS IS A THREE YEAR BACK
REAL BILL REQUEST TO SUSTAIN THE
DISTRICT.
WHILE THE COMMUNITY REBUILDS AND
IN ORDER.
TO TO DISCUSS THOSE TYPES OF
PROJECTS THIS I MEAN THESE ARE
DISCUSSIONS THAT.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN GOING ON HAVE
BEEN GOING ON WHATEVER VERB WE
WANT TO USE ABOUT THE THOUSANDS
OF WATER DISTRICTS TAT EXISTED
IN.
IN THROUGHOUT THE STATE NOT JUST
PICKING ON DYSON IN VIEW COUNTY
BUT THIS CHAIR.
AND WHEN I WAS A CHAIR VQ IT
MADE MY VIEWS CLEAR ABOUT THE
NEED TO GET THESE FEELING WATER
DISTRICTS.
AT THE PARADISE IS FAILING BUT
GIVEN WHAT THE SITUATION IS AND
COME TOGETHER COLLABORATIVELY --
AND LOOK AT THE WATERSHEDS AND
LOOK AT THE BIGGER BIGGER SYSTEM
OTHER THAN GRANDPA PAAS SET UP A
PRIVATE WATER DISTRICT ONCE UPON
A TIME SO.
I ENCOURAGE THOSE DISCUSSIONS GO
ON AND WILL CONSIDER MATTER
THANK YOU.
I WAS HERE FOR THE GENERAL
MANAGER.
HELLO KEVIN PHILLIPS DISTRICT
MANAGER PARADISE IRRIGATION
DISTRICT HERE TO SUPPORT ITEM
SIXTY FIVE THE BACK FILL FOR
PARADISE IRRIGATION DISTRICT.
JUST TO LET YOU KNOW WE ARE
GOVERNMENT AGENCY THAT IS --
OWNED BY THE RESIDENTS OF
PARADISE AND WE ARE ESTABLISHED
IN NINETEEN SIXTEEN BY A BOND
MEASURE AND WE ARE RULED BY.
AN ELECTED BOARD OF FIVE SO WE
ARE -- WE THAT THE CITIZENS OF
PARADISE OWN PARADISE IRRIGATION
DISTRICT.
THEY ON THE WATERSHED THEY ON
THE THE AND LIKE DOESN'T SAID WE
ARE LOOKING FOR FUNDING FOR
THREE YEARS TO TRY TO DEVELOP A
DIFFERENT BUSINESS MODEL. FOR
OUR CUSTOMERS SO THAT WHEN THE
CUSTOMERS TO COME BACK TO
REBUILD THEY HAVE THE WATER
SYSTEM THAT THEY'VE.
BEEN INVESTING IN OVER THE LAST
HUNDRED YEARS -- THIS -- PROJECT
THIS YEAR FOR PROJECT THAT WE
CALL. FOR THE INTERTIDAL YARN --
TALKS WITH THE COUNTY AND WITH
OTHER WATER AGENCIES OUT THERE.
TO MAKE THIS WORK THIS IS A WIN
WIN PROJECT FOR ALL -- AGENCIES
WITHIN THE BUTTE COUNTY AND THIS
THREE YEAR -- BACK BILL WOULD
HELP SUPPORT PROJECT SO THAT WE
COULD DEVELOP PARDON -- NEW
BUSINESS MODEL SO WE CAN TO BE
SUSTAINABLE ALL THE WAY THROUGH
THE REBUILD IN INTO THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
TAX.
BUT YOU'RE DOING GIVENS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY FIVE PARADISE
YOUR CATION DISTRICT FUNDING.
AS AS YOU'RE.
WELL AWARE THERE'S HAVE BEEN
LEGISLATION TO PROVIDE THE
PROPERTY TAX.
TO THE THE PUBLIC AGENCIES IN
YOU COUNTY HOWEVER I THAT ONLY
COVERS 5% OF THEIR BUDGET --
THERE THEY'LL SEE VERY LITTLE OF
OF THAT.
GOING FROM. TEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED SERVICE CONNECTIONS DOWN
TO SEVEN HUNDRED ACTIVE.
IS SIGNIFICANT IT'S COMPLETE AND
AS SUCH IT'S ALMOST COMPLETE
LOSS OF OF THEIR FUNDING SOURCE.
TO YOUR QUESTION AS FAR AS THE
THE CONSOLIDATION AND AS YOU AS
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
WITH YOUR OFFICE SAID AND DONE
ON LEGISLATION STATEWIDE LOOKING
AT THOSE LEGACY.
STONE IS THE THAT ARE THAT ARE
NOT PUBLIC AGENCIES BUT LOOKING
HOW WE CAN CONNECT THEM AND A
WHAT IT WILL TAKE IN A STATEWIDE
TO TO BRING THEM INTO COMPLIANCE
PROVIDE CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
THAT THAT WILL BE PART OF THE
DISCUSSION AS AS THINGS GO FOR
BUT THIS FUNDING IN PARTICULAR.
IS NECESSARY TO PROVIDE THAT FOR
THAT COMMUNITY BE REAL BILL
REBUILT AS WE'VE DISCUSSED MANY
TIMES THAT WATER IS LIFE.
AND WITHOUT THAT WATER WITHOUT
THIS CONNECTIONS WITHOUT THIS
DISTRICT.
I DON'T KNOW THE PARADISE CAN BE
REBUILT.
THANK YOU NEXT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ABROAD FOR THE
TEAMSTERS I JUST LIKE TO ECHO
THOSE COMMENTS WE REPRESENT SOME
OF THE WORKERS AT PARADISE
IRRIGATION DISTRICT -- YOU KNOW
I I THINK THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT WATER IS A FOUNDATIONAL
NEED AND AFFORD SERIES ABOUT
REBUILDING PARADISE.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT P. ID
CAN KEEP THE LIGHTS ON THANK YOU.
I JUST.
CAN'T UNDER SCORE THE CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE STATEWIDE FOR SOME
OF THESE FEELING DISTRICTS TO
COME TOGETHER AND I'M NOT
PICKING ON PARADISE YOU JUST
HAPPEN TO BE IN FRONT OF ME
RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT THAT THIS IS A BATTLE
THAT WE GO ON IN THE DE.
THIS SANDERS PARTS OF THE PARTS
OF THE STATE THAT HAVE PRIVATE
AND LEGACY WHAT DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE GONE ON FOREVER AND THIS IS
A CHANCE FOR US TO SAY LET'S
MAKE EVERYTHING WORK.
PROPERLY AND AND MORE
EFFICIENTLY SO NOT PICKING ON
YOU BUT I HOPE YOU GET MY DRIFT
[inaudible]
NEXT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN NAME IS BONNIE
BONNIE WALL FROM THE MARLINS THE
GROUP CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
I'M I'M HERE SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
TWO ITEMS NUMBER FORTY THREE AND
FIFTY SIX I'M IN THE TO ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS ABOUT FIFTY
SIX THAT YOU'RE OFF.
REQUESTS FOR CAL RECYCLED BUT I
DID WANT TO ADD.
THAT -- FUNDING FOR THIS
FACILITY IS NOT ONLY A
WORTHWHILE INVESTMENT BUT HAS
BEEN PROVEN TO BE AMONG THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE IN TERMS OF
DOLLARS SPENT PER.
TON OF GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCED
NOT TO MENTION THE BENEFITS OF
IMPROVING SOIL HEALTH AND
SEQUESTERING CARBON AS WELL --
ADDITIONALLY IN TERMS OF ITEM
NUMBER FORTY THREE THE SAN
FRANCISCO BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PILOT PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING
SIGNIFICANT PREVENTABLE LOSS OF
FUNDING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
RECYCLING THE STATE'S NATIONS --
ONCE NATION LEADING BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM A
WE'RE DOWN 273% WILL OTHER
STATES ARE STILL RECEIVE --
COLLECTING 85290%.
OF THE CITY OF SAN JUST GO IN
PARTICULAR HAS BEEN HIT HARD AS
MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF ITS
RECYCLING CENTERS HAVE BEEN
SQUEEZED OUT OF THE CITY.
I'M AND BECAUSE THE DEPOSIT
SYSTEM HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING OR
STAR IN -- INCREASING RECYCLING
I REDUCING LITERATE ACTION
IMPROPER RESOURCE MANAGEMENT WE
MUST CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THEM --
IMPROVEMENT OF THIS PROGRAM AND
HIGHLY NEW TECHNIQUES TO BRING
THE CONVENIENCE TO THE CONSUMER
IN ORDER TO BETTER COLLECTION
RECYCLE HIGH QUALITY REUSABLE
MATERIAL THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
TAX.
MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY MCHALE
WITH ERIN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING CAL FIRE LOCAL.
TWO EIGHT EIGHT ONE IN SUPPORT
OF ITEM.
TWENTY ONE WE APPRECIATE ALL OF
THE ADVANCES IN TERMS OF BOB
VEGETA ANISH MEN AND NEW
TECHNOLOGY WE STILL NEED
FIREFIGHTERS WE STILL NEED
ENGINES.
AND JUST AS A SIDE NOTE WE DID.
A CALL IN THE TWENTY ONE UNITS
WITHIN CAL FIRE WE HAVE FEWER
FIREFIGHTERS WORKING THIS YEAR
AND WE HAD LAST YEAR -- WE
REALLY DO SIGNED IS THIS ON
PRESCRIBED BURN SAID IN AN
CLEARING THE NOT FOR HARD TO
JUST IN TERMS OF HOW MANY
THEY'VE HIRED IN PREPARATION FOR
THE FIRE SEASON COMING OUT.
OKAY THANK YOU OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'M JENNIFER GREG THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ONE ARCHIVES
FOUNDATION LOCATED IN LOS
ANGELES AD I'M HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT ITEM.
FORTY FIVE LGBT Q. HISTORICAL
ARCHIVES THIS IS THE FIRST
STATEWIDE PUBLIC FUNDING
INITIATIVE FOR LGBT Q. ARCHIVES
SUPPORT IT 1100%.
I BY 1100% OF THE LGBT Q.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS ONE ARCHIVES
FOUNDATION WAS FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO BY A GROUP OF
VERY BRAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
SEEKING.
INFORMATION AND HISTORY ABOUT
THEIR LGBT COMMUNITY WHERE THE
OLDEST CONTINUOUSLY OPERATING
LGBT Q..
ORGANIZATION IN THE COUNTRY AND
NOW ALMOST SEVENTY YEARS LATER
THERE ARE MORE THAN THREE
MILLION PIECES OF LGBT Q.
HISTORY.
HOUSE AT THE ARCHIVES THESE ARE
RARE AND UNIQUE ARTIFACTS THAT
ARE ONE OF A KIND. ONE ARCHIVES
MAINTAINS THREE LOCATIONS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE ARCHIVES
ARE HOUSED IN THE WEST ADAMS
DISTRICT OF LOS ANGELES IN OUR
STUART IT BY THE ONE ARCHIVES
FOUNDATION.
MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND
RESEARCHERS WORLDWIDE VISIT THE
ARCHIVES ANNUALLY AND THE
MAJORITY OF MATERIALS HOUSE OF
THE ARCHIVES ARE BASED ON
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY WITH
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
COLLECTIONS AS WELL.
IT IS THE LARGEST LGBT ARCHIVE
IN THE WORLD OUR PROGRAMS AND
PRESENTATIONS INCLUDING OUR
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND
EXHIBITIONS ARE STATEWIDE SUMMER
INTERNATIONAL PROVIDING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CONSTITUENTS
INFORMATION ABOUT THE LGBT
COMMUNITY.
I RESPECTFULLY SUPPORT REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE LGBT Q.
HISTORICAL ARCHIVES IT IS VITAL
TO CONTINUE TO PRESERVE OUR LGBT
Q. HISTORY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN I
AM ERICA DAM AND THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION AT THE ONE
ARCHIVES FOUNDATION.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT
ITEM FORTY FIVE AS WELL THE
LEGISLATIVE REQUEST FOR LGBTQ
HISTORICAL ARCHIVES -- STUDIES
SUGGEST THAT LGBT Q. STUDENTS AT
SCHOOLS WITHOUT GB TO HEAR
INCLUSIVE CURRICULUM ARE HALF AS
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
VICTIMIZATION BECAUSE OF THEIR
SEXUALITY AND GENDER IDENTITY.
AND ARE TWICE AS LIKELY TO HAVE
SUPPORTING PIERS.
THIS IS WHY THE ONE ARCHIVES
FOUNDATION IS SO IMPORTANT AT
THE ONE ARCHIVES FOUNDATION WE
SHARE ACCURATE AN AUTHENTIC LGBT
Q. HISTORY.
FROM THE ONE ARCHIVES AND OTHER
LGBT Q. ARCHIVES AROUND THE
STATE AS PARTNERS IN THE FACT
COALITION BY TRAINING TEACHERS
TO CREATE LESSON PLANS AROUND
LGBT Q. HISTORY AND MENTORING
TEENS THROUGH OUR YOUTH
AMBASSADORS FOR QUEER HISTORY
PROGRAM.
THE STORIES FROM THE ARCHIVES
ENGAGE AND EDUCATE PROVIDING
YOUTH ANOTHER STOP PRETENDED TO
LEARN ABOUT THEIR LGBT Q.
ANCESTORS PIONEERS IN THE
COMMUNITY AND IN THE MOVEMENT
FOR LGBT Q. EQUALITY.
SUPPORT FOR THE LGBTQ HISTORICAL
ARCHIVES IS VITAL TO MAINTAIN
AND SHARE LGBT Q. HISTORY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MELISSA ROMERO
WITH A CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF TWO ITEMS NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
THE MULTI YEAR FUNDING FOR
EMISSION REDUCTIONS THEIR MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
INCENTIVES.
AS WELL AS ITEM FIFTY THE
NATURAL RESOURCES PROGRAMS A
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION ASK BOTH
FROM SHOULD YOUR ****.
I WOULD I DON'T ONE OF REPEATING
THE POINTS ARE MADE BY THE
SPEAKERS BEFORE ME WHICH WERE
ALL GREAT.
BUT I DID WANT TO ADD THAT BOTH
OF THESE WOULD ADD GO FAR IN
PROTECTING VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES FROM AIR POLLUTION
AND THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
THERE DOLPHIN BAFFLING
CALIFORNIA CITIES HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT BY NUMBER -- FIFTY SIX
WHILE I WILL ALSO LIKE TO ALIGN
MY COMMENTS WITH SOME OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS ON THAT ITEM.
THESE FUNDS IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED BY CITIES TO START
COMPLYING WITH THEIR ORGANIC
WASTE DIVERSION TARGETS IN THEIR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION TARGET
GOAL O -- WOULD LOVE TO URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE ITEM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MARK FENCER MAKER HERE ON
A QUICKLY IN A COUPLE OF ITEMS.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY TWO IN HERE
FOR THAT CINEMA WATERS WELL AS
SEVERAL OTHER WATER AGENCIES IN
THE STATE.
LOCKYER NATION DISTRICT YOU
WATER AGENCIES SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO PROTECT
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS IT'S GOING TO
BE KEY TO UNDERSTANDING
PRECIPITATION.
GOING FORWARD AND IT WILL ALLOW
US TO WORK WITH THE ARMY CORPS
ON EITHER PRE RELEASING SO WE
CAN AVOID.
WORST FLOOD IMPACTS OR HOLD MORE
WATER BACK SO THAT WE CAN BE
BETTER PREPARED FOR DROUGHT
CONDITIONS.
YOU THINK THIS SIX YEAR.
OR FIFTY FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT WHAT WITH THE DO YOU.
IN ADDITION TO WHAT NOW IS DOING.
SO IT'S GOING TO ALLOW FOR
BETTER -- MODELING -- WE'RE
WORKING WITH SCRIPTS IS GOING TO
ALLOW FOR ABOUT THE WATER
AGENCIES INCLUDING THE ONE I
REPRESENT US NO MORE WATER.
TO IMPLEMENT PILOTS -- AT SOME
OF OUR RESERVOIRS WE ARE -- JUST
FINISHING UP A PILOT AT LAKE
MENDOCINO.
WORKING WITH THE CORPS ON A ON A
DEVIATION SO THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY HOLD MORE WATER BACK
THIS YEAR.
ABOVE THE BROKER I I GET I GET.
THE IDEAS I'M JUST WONDERING
WHAT NO WAY WILL BE DOING A WE
EXPECT THEM TO DO OVER THE NEXT
SIX YEARS.
AGO BUT WOULD BE FILLING IN YEAH
SO -- WORKING WITH THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION AT NOW I THEY DO
PROVIDE SOME TECHNOLOGY BY WAY
OF DRONES AND PLANES TO BE OUT.
OVER THE OCEAN TO START TO
GATHER SOME OF THE INFORMATION.
FOR THE STATE IT'S WORKING ON
SOME OF THE MODELING WORKING ON
SOME OF THE IN M. THAT GOES
ALONG WITH THAT SOME OF THE
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS THE THAT THE
COMPUTERS AND THAT THOUGHT THE
SYSTEM SOFTWARE SO THAT WE CAN.
BETTER ADVANCE AND ENHANCE THE
MODELING CAPABILITIES THAT WE
NEED SO WE CAN IMPROVE THE
ACCURACY AND PREDICTABILITY I
GUESS MIKE MIKE THAT.
THE A BEG THE QUESTION WHAT WILL
THE FEDERAL OPERATORS AT THE
RESERVOIR FACILITIES DO WITH
THIS ACCURATE INFORMATION THAT
YOU GIVE THEM WILL THEY ACTUALLY
COMPLY WITH IT OR SAY WE KNOW
BETTER.
WE'RE RELEASING WELL IT'S THE
WATER THAT'S A REALLY REALLY
GOOD QUESTION AND AND I THINK
OUR EXAMPLE.
HOPEFULLY MEANS THAT THEY WILL
START TO WORK MORE IN TANDEM
WITH CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
SO THAT.
THEY CAN START TO ADJUST THOSE
BROKERS WE START TO MAKE SOME
PROGRESS WITH THEM -- THERE AT
LAKE MENDOCINO -- SOME OF WHAT
WE'VE PICKED UP IN TALKING WITH
SOME OF THE FOLKS AT THE ARMY
CORPS IS THEY'RE STARTING TO
FIND SOME BELIEF THAT HESE REAL
CARS THAT ARE FORTY FIFTY YEARS
OLD SHOULD BE AJUSTED -- AND
THAT THIS DATA CAN YOU KNOW HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND THAT THAT IT'S
TIME TO TO MAKE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS THERE NEXT MATTER
S. ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT YOU
HEARD EARLIER FROM MID PENINSULA
REGIONAL -- YOU KNOW TO SAY THAT
THAT THERE THIS PROPERTY DOES
CONTAIN WATERSHEDS THAT.
ARE ONE OF THE HIGH PARTY'S FOR
COHO SALMON REINTRODUCTION AND
YOU KNOW WE'RE PROVIDING A
CONCERT AMOUNT OF PRIVATE
DOLLARS THAT.
YOU KNOW IT'S GONNA BE A THREE
TO ONE LEVERAGE FOR WHAT THE
STATE SEN.
I HAD LAST WEEK ITEM FORTY ONE
PAUCITY GALANTER REST YOU HEARD
FROM TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR DECADES THIS
IS THE LAST PIECE OF THAT PUZZLE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY A OFF FROM
CALIFORNIA RELIEVE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ITEM FIFTY AND I JUST
WANT TO ECHO WHAT THE OTHER
COMMENTS THAT ARE FEDERALLY
LAUNDERING AUDUBON MADE.
REGARDING THIS.
ITEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TERRY KOWSKI JOHN IS
THE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROUNDWATER COALITION
WE'RE HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTY TWO WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
CRITICAL FUNDING FOR THE
ATMOSPHERIC REVERSE RESEARCH
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MR TURNED THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US TODAY MY NAME'S KAELIN CLUE
I'M POLICY ANALYST CALIFORNIA
COULD CAUSE KEEPER LINE SOME
ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
BECAUSE FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION THE
INSTITUTE.
FOR FISHERIES RESOURCES IN THE
GOLDEN GATE GAMMON.
SORRY GOLDEN GATE SALMON
ASSOCIATION.
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OR IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM FORTY NINE THE
COMPREHENSIVE BLUE CARBON
STRATEGY AND RESEARCH -- THE
REQUESTED OF THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION WILL SUPPORT
SCIENCE BASED PROGRAMS. TO
CONSERVE PROTECT RESTORE AND
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE CALIFORNIA'S
COASTAL AND OCEAN ECOSYSTEMS IN
THE FACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
THIS REQUEST PROVIDES FUNDING
FOR DISCREET YET CRITICAL
PROGRAMS TO IMPROVE COASTAL
ECOSYSTEM HEALTH.
AND TO PROTECT KEYSTONE SPECIES
THAT ARE VITAL TO CALIFORNIA'S
BIODIVERSITY.
SPECIAL COMMITTEES AND ASIAN
ECONOMY.
THIS FUNDING WILL GO TOWARDS
AMONG OTHER THINGS CONTINUING
PILOT PROJECTS THAT I'VE ALREADY
SHOWN MEASURABLE MEASURABLE
BENEFITS TO PROTECT COASTAL
COMMUNITIES FROM RISING SEA
LEVELS.
HELLO I'D DOWN SHIPS TO IMPROVE
AIR QUALITY WHILE PREVENTING
FATAL WILL STRIKES AND HELP
RESTORE CALIFORNIA COULD HELP
FOREST'S. SEVEN THAT'S MADE A
CLIMATE CHANGE AND BY INVASIVE
SPECIES.
EACH OF THESE PROGRAMS WILL
ENSURE THE LONG TERM HEALTH AND
VITALITY OF CALIFORNIA'S OCEAN
AND COASTAL ECOSYSTEMS
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITIES.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT.
IN ITEM FORTY NINE FOR
COMPREHENSIVE BLUE CARBON
STRATEGY AND RESEARCH AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE REQUEST
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI CRISTINA GALLAGHER ON
BEHALF OF THE JEWISH PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF
ITEMS. SIXTY SIXTY ONE AND SIXTY
FOUR THE JEWISH CAUCUS BUDGET
REQUESTS FOR REBUILDING CAMPS
THAT WERE BURNED DOWN BY THE
WILL SEE AN TYPES WILD FIRES.
AS WELL AS FUNDING FOR THE LOS
ANGELES MUSEUM OF THE HOLOCAUST
AND FUNDING FOR THE THREE
INTERNATIONAL COULD COME.
TOMORROW.
COME HEARST FISHING -- HUGHES.
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU.
DOES SENATOR I GUESS A GOOD
AFTERNOON AIR MORENO ABOUT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HERE
IN SUPPORT TWO ITEMS -- FIRST OF
ALL ITEM FIFTY SIX THE G. JURA
FUNDING FOR THE SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS WASTE
DIVERSION FOOD RECOVERY.
I WOULD THINK THAT'S BORN TO
HELP GROCERS COMPLY WITH THE SB
THIRTY NEED TO REQUIREMENTS.
THE SECOND ONE A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF ITEM FORTY THREE
THE THREE MILLION -- TO YOU --
ESTABLISH OR TO HELP ESTABLISH
THE SERVICE CO PILOT PROGRAM
JUST A BY WAY OF BACKGROUND --
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM
TO PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN AMONG OTHER BUSINESSES
GROCERS OTHER DEALERS AND CISCO --
WITH THIS AMP DISCO DEPARTMENT
OF ARGUMENT TO CREATE A BILL BY
PARTNERSHIP TO SERVE ALL THE
CONVENIENCE OF THE SAN FRANCISCO.
THIS MONEY IS CRUCIAL TO GET
THAT -- PROGRAM OFF THE GROUND
AND ALLOW TO LEVERAGE FUNDS AT
GROCERS ARE PREPARED TO TO BRING
TO THE TABLE.
TO PROVIDE FOR RECYCLING BUSY
SAM JUST GOT SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
CHARLES WATSON ON BEHALF OF
PATEROS THE LINE ELECTRIC
COMPANY AND DINNER IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN THE
MULTI YEAR ALLOCATION. FOR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
INCENTIVES AND JUST ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF CAL START OTHERS
SPEAKERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR Y. KOWSKI
FOR ANNIKA PART -- ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL NORTHERN DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ITEM. FIFTY
SIX ONE HUNDRED MILLION IN G. G.
R. F. ALLOCATION THE CAL RECYCLE.
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS SUPPORTERS BUT WOULD
LIKE TO ADD THAT IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE THE AMBITIOUS GOAL OF
75% A VERSION BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE WE WILL NEED TO NEARLY
TRIPLE.
OUR CURRENT ORGANICS MANAGEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE NO EASY PASS SELF
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN I
MISSED THE LAST WILD AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUSEUMS I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT
ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTEEN BUT WHICH IS THE MUSEUM
GRANT PROGRAM IT'S TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE MUSEUM GRANT
PROGRAM THAT IS ADMINISTERED BY
THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
HISTORICAL ENDOWMENT.
I WE HAVE A LETTER OF SUPPORT
THAT IN ADDITION TO OUR
ASSOCIATION THAT HAS NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED MEMBERS INSTITUTIONAL
MEMBERS WE HAVE A LETTER OF
SUPPORT THAT ALSO HAS TWELVE
MUSEUM SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE CO SIGNED.
AND FORTY SEVEN MUSEUMS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE THOSE FORTY
SEVEN MUSEUMS INCLUDE SOME
LARGER ORGANIZATION SUCH AS LACK
MAN EXPLORATORIUM AS WELL SOME
SMALLER ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
THE HAIR HAYWARD AREA HISTORICAL
SOCIETY WHICH IS IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT -- FOR
THIS MUSEUM GRANT PROGRAM IT'S
BEEN IN EXISTNCE FOR ONLY TWO
ROUNDS AND IN THOSE TWO ROUNDS
ONLY 24% OF THE APPLICATIONS
WERE ACCEPTED BASED ON THE
FUNDING THAT WAS AVAILABLE AND
THAT WAS FOR THE RESIDUAL
FUNDING A PROP.
FORTY WHICH HAS NOW EVAPORATED
AND HAS BEEN EXHAUSTED.
YOU WANT TO SPEAK SOME OF THIS
GRANT MONEY BEING USED FOR
EXHIBITS THAT WOULD TRAVEL
BEYOND.
CALIFORNIA.
DID ANYBODY IN WISCONSIN AND
PENNSYLVANIA WHAT'S NO BUT I
KNOW THAT ONE OF THE WAYS THAT
MUSEUMS MAKE MONEY AS THEY PUT
TOGETHER A UNIQUE EXHIBIT AND
THEN THEY TAKE IT ON THE ROAD
AND OTHER.
WASHINGTON DC NEW YORK PAYS FOR
THOSE -- THOSE -- SHOWS.
I MEAN I CERTAINLY EXHIBITION
DESIGN IS SOMETHING THAT WE
ENVISION AS SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE AN ELIGIBLE YOU KNOW PROJECT
FOR THIS IT THIS MUSEUM GRANT
PROGRAM USED TO JUST BE CAPITAL
GRANT FUNDING.
FOR WHAT THE PROP FORTY BUT LAST
YEAR -- WE WERE ABLE TO BROADEN
THE SCOPE OF IT SO IT'S NOT JUST
CAPITAL ANYMORE NOW IT'S CAN
INCLUDE PROGRAMMATIC.
OKAY EXPENSES AS WELL SO THAT
WOULD CERTAINLY IN OUR MIND
WOULD BE AN ELIGIBLE.
PROJECT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANKS VERY TIME.
BACK TO MARCUS REPRESENTING
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRIES TO
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK AND THE
CARBON CYCLE INSTITUTE.
AND WE'RE SUPPORT OF THE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION TWO YEAR AFTER
PREPARATION FOR NATURAL WORKING
LANDS CONTAINED IN ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTY AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
FUNDING ALLOCATIONS DILEMMA
DELINEATED IN THE LETTER THAT
YOU HELD UP EARLIER FROM THE AT
YES THAT'S EXACTLY IT SO WE
SUPPORT THAT FUNDING.
ALLOCATION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE FAN ON
HAVE EVERY PLANET IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM FORTY THREE THE THREE
MILLION FOR THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PILOT
PROJECT.
WE WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
ORIGINAL LEGISLATION.
PASSED A TWO YEARS AGO.
I JUST WANT TO SEE THE PROGRAM
I'M HAVING A FUNDING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL THANK YOU.
OKAY SUPPORT THE SANTA MONICA
PROGRAM ALSO RIGHT.
WE'VE GOT THE ORIGINAL.
THE ORIGINAL WAS THE ORIGINAL
MOBILE NOW.
WAS IT SANTA MONICA THEY HAD
[inaudible]
IN THE NEXT THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS JASON'S REALTOR ABOUT
FAT.
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT OF A NUMBER.
SIXTEEN FLUSTERED CAM SAID
EVERYTHING THAT NEEDS TO BE SAID
BUT WERE IN STRONG SUPPORTER
DRIVE OUT THERE.
I ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER FORTY
THREE THE BOTTLE BILL.
OF PROGRAM THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
TALKED ABOUT ONE POINT I WOULD
ADD IS.
YOU KNOW AS AS WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE BOTTLE BILL AS WE ALWAYS DO
I AND WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT
CONVENIENCE MEANS GOING FORWARD
AS OPPOSED TO THE LAST THIRTY
FORTY YEARS THIS IS A GREAT
INCUBATION PROJECT TO HELP THE
STATE DETERMINE FUTURE POLICY
MOVES THAT ARE GONNA BE MADE.
RELATIVE TO THE IDEA OF
CONVENIENCE AND HOW IT WORKS IN
LAW AS WERE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
INNER DRIVE OUT THERE AND THEY
GO AND LEAVE THE THE AUTHOR OF
SP ONE SIXTY A THESE ACUTELY
AWARE OF OF THEIR RICA RECYCLING
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE IN THE
STATE BUT ABSOLUTELY.
APPRECIATE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
THREE ABSOLUTELY AND THEN ON
BEHALF OF THIS OLD WAY SAYS HE
SHOULD IN NORTH AMERICA I'LL ME
TO STOP WASTE.
I WESTERN PLASTER WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY NATIONAL
STIR EXTRACTION COUNCIL AND THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS YOU'RE TO
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTY SIX GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND CAN UNITS ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES.
HERE IN CASE ANYONE HAS SAID WE
ARE ONLY OPPOSES THINGS. ONE
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR REQUEST
NUMBER TWENTY RELATED TO THE
FRANK KERN CAN NOW.
I REQUEST NUMBER THIRTY TWO
RELATED TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAMS ON FOREST MANAGEMENT.
REQUEST NUMBER FIFTY TWO
REGARDING -- ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS
RESEARCH.
AND THEN REQUEST NUMBER SIXTY
FIVE REGARDING.
IMMIGRATION DISTRICT.
AND IF I COULD I KNOW I WANT TO
SEE MY COMMENTS WITH THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF PARADISE YOUR
GEISHA DISTRICT BUT PRESS IF IF
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE EVER REBUILD
THAT TOWN -- AND WHETHER OR NOT
YOU KNOW YOU'RE TALKING
CONSOLIDATION OR NOT.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP THAT SYSTEM
RUNNING FOR THE RESIDENTS THAT
ARE THERE AND THE ONES THAT PLAN%
TO MOVE BACK IN THE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS -- SO WE ARE VERY SUPPORT
OF THAT REQUEST.
I TRUST THE PEOPLE GOT THE
CHAIRS.
MESSAGE ABOUT TALKING WITH YOUR
NEIGHBORS.
THANKS.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH A RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO ON BEHALF OF SEIZE ACT FOR
ITEM FIFTY SIX HUNDRED MILLION
FOR ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY VITAL FOR US
TO COMPLY WITH SB THIRTEEN THE
THREE REQUIREMENTS ON ORGANIC
WASTE DIVERSION.
SO STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT MEASURE
AND ALSO IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
SIXTY FIVE THE PERIOD PARADISE
IRRIGATION DISTRICT REBUILDING.
IT'S VITAL TO HELP THEM SUPPORT
AND SURVIVE THANK YOU.
YOU.
ASHLEY WALKER WITH NAS MEN ON
BEHALF OF THE MODERATE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY TWO FUNDING FOR THE FISH
SCREENS FOR THE INTERLAKE TUNNEL
PROJECT WHICH IS A CRITICAL
REGIONAL WATER STORAGE PROJECT.
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF ITEM FIFTY
THREE THE SALINAS REGIONAL
SOCCER COMPLEX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
X. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN IT WAS
JOSIAH YOUNG MY FIRST COMMENTS
ARE IN SUPPORT OF ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLES
COALITION.
AS WELL AS THE BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
IS DEFINITELY WANT TO SUPPORT
THIS ITEM -- AND SEE MORE MONEY
GOING TO THE ZERO IN NEW ZERO
APPLICATIONS IN THE HEAVY DUTY
SECTOR.
AND THEN THE OTHER ITEM I WAS
SPEAKING ON IS -- ITEM FIFTY SIX
ON BEHALF OF THE BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THIS FOR TWO PRIMARY
REASONS -- ONE BIO ENERGY
INCLUDING WASTE DIVERSION DERRY
DIE JESTERS AND FORCE FOR
REMOVAL WHERE THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE OF ALL CAP AND TRADE
INVESTMENTS CORD TO EARLIER
REPORTS.
ALSO BIOENERGY PROVIDES THE
GREATEST OVERALL BENEFITS OF ANY
INVESTMENT FOR THOSE REASONS
WERE SUPPORTING THEM ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR ASK OF THE LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION FUND. TWO
HUNDRED MILLION TO CAL RECYCLE
FOR ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION AND
THE 20% OF SB NINE A ONE FUNDS.
THANK YOU.
YOUR PERSONAL AYE CASKEY NICOLO
DELUCA ON BEHALF OF MANY
ENTITIES WITH THAT SIX ITEMS.
THE FIRST ITEM NUMBER NINE THE
JAMES WHITAKER SCHOOL PARK
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF WHEN A
PARK.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN THE MUSEUM
GRANT PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF THE
OAKLAND MUSEUM OF CALIFORNIA THE
OAKLAND ZOO -- ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN THE SAFE AND CLEAN
DRINKING WATER ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SELMA IN THE CITY OF DIE
NUBA -- ITEM NUMBER FORTY TWO
THE FUNDING FOR THE DISCOVERY
SCIENCE CENTER ON BEHALF OF THE
DISCOVERY SCIENCE CENTER.
AND THE CITY OF SANTA ANA.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY FOUR GRADE
SEPARATION FOR THE CITY OF PALO
ALTO ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
PALO ALTO.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR THE
MONEY FOR THE OAKLAND UNIFIED IN
AC TRANSIT ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF OAKLAND AND THEN JUST
PERSONALLY.
I LOVE SCENE FUNDING FOR THE
ITALIAN AMERICAN MUSEUM THANK
YOU [inaudible]
MAMMA MIA [inaudible]
NEXT.
THANK YOU CHAIR READ DATA SON BE.
A COUPLE ITEMS SO FIRST I AM
SIXTY TWO ON BEHALF OF SEE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE AND CAL TROUT.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT FACILITY IS
THAT IS NEEDED ON THE NORTH
COAST OF CALIFORNIA.
AS YOU MAY WELL KNOW THIS IS A
UNESCO WORLD HERITAGE SITE BUT
WE DON'T HAVE A PROPER FACILITY
ACTUALLY TAKE PEOPLE IN THE
ORIENT AND OUT A RECREATION USE
THAT THIS.
IS PART OF THE STATE.
PROBABLY ALSO IMPORTANT IS SHARE
THAT THIS FUNDING WOULD LEVERAGE
OTHER PUBLIC DOLLARS.
AND ALSO WOULD HELP THE THE
ECONOMY UP THERE -- THIS PART OF
THE STATE IS DESPERATELY
DEPENDED ON A TOURISM.
THE NEXT ITEM WOULD BE ITEM
NUMBER.
THIRTY TWO ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION AND
THE LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS IS
IN CALIFORNIA.
WELL IT'S TERRIBLE THAT WE'VE
HAD THESE DISASTERS ESPECIALLY
RELATED TO FIRES IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT AS WE LOOK
AT RESTORING IN DEALING WITH THE
CLEAN UP OF THESE VARIOUS SITES.
THAT WE CAN HAVE PROGRAMS THAT
ACTUALLY HELP GET PEOPLE.
EMPLOYED TO DO THAT WORK AND SO
WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE WORK
PROGRAM THAT THAT THOSE FUNDS
REPRESENT.
THIRD ITEM.
FIFTY TWO ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS A LOS ANGELES RIVER I
THINK PEOPLE PARTY TALKED ABOUT
THIS SO WOULD YOU SAY WERE ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THE ATMOSPHERE.
ATMOSPHERIC REVERSED RESEARCH
THERE.
AND THEN FINALLY WILLA.
ON ITEM.
FIFTY BEHALF A LAND TRUST TO
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA
TROUT NOBLE OF MINOR COMMENTS
WITH THE EARLIER AS SUPPORTERS
OF THAT MEASURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR OF DOUG HOUSTON I
WANTED -- TO COMMENT ON PERHAPS
THE MOST IMPORTANT PROJECT WE
HAVE A SUPPORT IN CONCEPT NUMBER
SIXTY NINE THE SAME PER CAPITA
RAIL PROJECT.
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
WE ARE SUPPORTING THAT IN
CONCEPT LIKE TO LEARN THE MORE.
DETAILS ABOUT THE PROJECT AND
THEN ON BEHALF OF COUPLE OTHER
CLIENTS SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE.
AND  CINEMA COUNTY REGIONAL
PARKS.
BOTH IN SUPPORT OF ITEM.
SIXTY SIX WHICH IS THE
DISSOLUTION IN NORTH COAST RAIL
AUTHORITY.
THIS WILL GIVE RISE TO A VERY
TRANSFORMATIVE TRANSFORMATIONAL
PROJECT IN THE GREAT REDWOOD
TRAIL.
BOLSTERING ARE ALREADY VERY
ROBUST OUTDOOR ECONOMY HEARING
CALIFORNIA NINETY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS THE TERRIFIC PROJECT AND
URGING YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THE HEARING ALL PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL CLOSE PUBLIC PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD.
ON THE MEMBERS REQUEST.
WE ARE ADJOURNED